Hallo, herzlich willkommen, hier ist die Freakshow und ich hoffe,
ihr seid alle richtig reingeplugged in diese Sendung.
Dank des Adapters.
Nur echt mit wahrem 50-Hertz-Bruck.
Meine Leute.
Ich finde, es wurde Zeit, dass es ein Loblied auf den Adapter gibt.
Denn nur der Adapter stellt die wahre Kompatibilität sicher.
Ja, denn ohne Änderung kein Fortschritt.
Ja, und Fortschritt muss sozusagen zwangsläufig adaptiert werden.
Ja, an die Vergangenheit nämlich.
Und da hilft einfach nur der Adapter.
Und damit auch ihr den Dank des Adapters erfahrt, gibt es jetzt Freakshow Nummer
281 direkt live aus der Meta-Ebene mit original Wackelstream,
wie unser Chat gerade berichtet.
Es tut mir natürlich furchtbar leid, ich habe genau gar keine Möglichkeit, das zu beeinflussen.
Das kommt davon, wenn man kein Multimillionen-Unternehmen ist,
sondern nur so ein dahergelaufener Internet-Hallo-Dreh.
Genau, so ein Hobby-Podcaster.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, wenn man das Ganze in Deutschland macht.
Das kommt noch dazu. Das ist auf jeden Fall immer ein Problem.
Das ist ein Risiko. Das ist ein Risiko und man kann sich nicht mal dagegen versichern.
Da hilft auch kein Adapter.
Da hilft auch kein Adapter. So sieht es aus. Genau. Also hier ist die Freakshow.
Ich bin's Tim und mir gegenüber Roddy. Hallo Roddy.
Hallo Tim.
Links.
Heute auf Mikrofonport Nummer 2, Ralf.
Natürlich links, ja, einen wunderschönen guten Abend.
Links ist ja sehr relativ, wenn man so im Dreieck sitzt, ja.
Ja, ich musste in der Tat noch rechts anfahren, weil als ich dieses Lied im Radio gehört habe,
das habe ich wirklich zuvor vor vier Tagen im Radio gehört und so alle Jubeljahre
erwischt mich ein Song so dermaßen hart,
dass ich im Interesse des allgemeinen Straßenverkehrssicherheitsregularien dann
mal in mich gehe und mir kurz ein Parkplätzchen,
um das vollständig würdigen zu können.
Aber ich kann es sehr gut verstehen. Der letzte Song, der mich total gepackt
hat, war dieser niederländische War is me ein Toasty-Apparat-Song.
Der ist schon auch extrem absurd.
Den kenne ich, glaube ich, noch gar nicht.
Wo jemand darüber singt, dass er seinen Toaster nicht findet.
Er würde halt ungern Käsesemmel essen oder einen Bau bannen,
sondern ein Toasty und dazu War is me ein Toasty-Apparat. Ja.
Okay. Es ist noch einiges zu holen hier in dieser Sendung.
Auf jeden Fall.
Jetzt müssen wir auch dafür sorgen, dass wir, du kannst schon mal den Link raussuchen,
mein Freund, weil was hier erwähnt wird, gehört ja auch in die Shownotes.
Schaffen wir zwar auch nicht unbedingt immer so den richtigen Link zur richtigen
Zeit, aber wir geben uns Mühe und dementsprechend hauen wir das hier alles in den Chat.
Und was im Chat landet, das hat auch eine gute Chance in den Show Notes zu landen.
Abgesehen natürlich von den ganzen Themenfremden Links, die uns hier von den
Leuten reingekübelt werden.
Wo ich immer das Gefühl habe, die Sendung ist wahrscheinlich ganz schön langweilig,
dass sie jetzt so parallel sich dann über andere Themen unterhalten.
Kommt euch das auch manchmal so vor?
Nein.
Also eigentlich ist unser Chat aber recht diszipliniert.
Ja, eigentlich.
Könnte ich jetzt gar nicht sagen.
Beziehungsweise es wird frei assoziiert, was sozusagen. Und vielleicht sind
es auch nur Vorschläge, die wir da nicht aufgreifen. Man weiß es nicht.
Man weiß es nicht. Dank des Adapters kann man das aber auch noch beheben.
Wer den Tonfall noch nicht erkannt hat und vielleicht noch gar nicht weiß,
welche Gruppe dahinter steht, das muss man auch nochmal erwähnen. H-G-I-T.
Ich würde sagen, wenn man so ein Craziness-Level von 1 bis 10 hat,
rangiert H-G-I-T irgendwo so zwischen 12 und 13.
Und es ist so ein klassisches Beispiel für kann man gut finden,
kann man auch nicht gut finden.
Da trennt sich dann die Spreu vom Weizen, das Plus vom Minus,
muss das auf und ab. Da gibt es keine einhellige Meinung.
Auch als die Truppe mal auf dem
Chaos Communication Kongress vor einigen Jahren in Hamburg Wann war das?
Das musste der letzte oder der vorletzte Kongress gewesen sein. Was war das nochmal?
Der letzte oder vorletzte? 32?
Man weiß es nicht. Einer von den paar und 30 Kongressen, die die in Hamburg
waren, bevor es dann nach Leipzig ging.
Ich glaube, 1933 war der letzte, aber...
Das kann sein und ich weiß es auch nicht mehr ganz genau. Auf jeden Fall gab
es ein Konzert von HGIT auf diesem Kongress und ich muss sagen,
das war für mich ein Moment des Innehaltens.
Weil also ganz klar, die Crowd trennte sich haarscharf, aber auch wirklich so
mit einem japanischen geschliffenen Messer in zwei Hälften.
Die einen dachten sich nur, oh mein Gott, was ist hier los? Ich muss hier raus.
Was ist mit dem Kongress passiert? Das ist ja unerträglich.
Und der Rest ging einfach nur steil ab, weil einfach diese Performance von HGIT einfach krass ist.
Das ist halt so eine Hamburger Kunst.
Studenten. Verbindung, glaube
ich, ursprünglich mal gewesen oder ist es vielleicht auch immer noch?
Seit fast 30 Jahren. So lange gibt es es schon. 96 gegründet.
Genau, das merkt man auch so ein bisschen daran, dass sie so noch in den guten
alten Goa-Party-Ding irgendwie hängen geblieben zu sein scheinen,
wenn man sich so die Videos anschaut. Auch die Musik, ja.
Und an dieser Stelle muss ich auch aufhören, das zu beschreiben,
weil HGIT ist schwer zu beschreiben.
Es ist wirklich, die Konzerte sind mehr so ein,
Die kommen so ein bisschen rüber wie so ein Verkehrsunfall in Zeitlupe und das erstreckt sich dann.
Immer wenn man denkt, der Wahnsinn wäre kaum noch zu steigern,
steigert er sich ins Unermessliche und wie gesagt, das kann man halt mögen oder nicht.
Ich fand es einfach atemberaubend großartig, weil es halt einfach so eine Antithese
zu allem, was irgendwie angeblich so Geschmack ist oder musikalische Großkunst.
Das wird einfach von diesem Projekt komplett ignoriert und stattdessen schaffen
sie es einfach durch proletenhaften Goa-Techno-Wahnsinn Memes zu produzieren,
die sind like no other.
Ich sage nur Hauptschule. Hauptschule.
Das kennst du nicht, oder? Nee. Aber ich bin mir hundertprozentig sicher, dass unter unseren,
mit Adaptern ausgestatteten Hörern hier schon das Ohr klingelt.
Adapter des Todes.
So. Also, hallo. Ja, hier ist die Metaebene und wir haben unsere Sommerurlaube
unterbrochen oder noch nicht angetreten, je nachdem.
Oder nie einen in Aussicht gehabt. Ich weiß nicht, Roddy, wie es bei dir so aussieht.
Das weiß ich noch nicht.
Das weißt du noch nicht so ganz genau. Also Unklarheit steht im Raum.
Ich habe jetzt schon viel Zeit in der Sonne verbracht, allerdings nicht in der
fernen Sonne, sondern in der nahen Sonne, weil es war ja heiß genug.
Und das wird dann auch das ein oder andere Thema beeinflussen, das wir heute haben.
Und fangen wir denn an? Ich würde sagen, wir fangen an mit ein bisschen Feedback, oder?
Aber ja. Ja.
Aber ja. Und zwar ähm,
Wir hatten eine, das muss ich gleich nochmal drüber nachdenken,
was war denn das für eine Diskussion?
Da ging es um, wie man, Gott, was war denn da der Kontext nochmal?
Ich habe beklagt, dass es doch so schwierig ist, Dateien zu übertragen.
Es ging um iPhone-Mirroring und iOS 18 bzw.
MacOS 15, also die auf der WWDC vorgestellten neuen Betriebssystem-Versionen,
wo ja dann dieses iPhone-Mirroring auch vorgestellt wurde und man es schön mit
Drag & Drop aufs iPhone Sachen übertragen konnte.
Und da habe ich dann halt so einfach gesagt, ja Skandal, wie kann es denn eigentlich
sein, dass sowas erst heute kommt, weil das wollte man ja eigentlich schon immer mal haben.
Und dazu gab es einen Kommentar von Michael, er zitiert mich hier, glaube ich zumindest.
Das hatten wir, glaube ich, noch gar nicht, aber das ist das,
was ich schon immer wollte.
Ich wollte schon immer mit Trick und Drop etwas auf einem anderen Mac bringen
und ich hoffe, dass wir das auch für den Mac noch bekommen.
Also von Mac zu Mac, nicht von Mac zu iPhone.
Und da wies er mich doch darauf hin, ganz korrekt, dass es das ja schon gibt.
Und in dem Moment wurde mir klar, dass ich ein Feature, was vor ein oder zwei
Betriebssystemversionen kam, aus bestimmten Gründen noch nie wirklich getestet
hatte. Nämlich dieses Universal Control.
Habt ihr das schon mal getestet?
Universal Control?
Das ist, wenn man mit der Maus auf das andere Gerät rüberkommt.
Das habe ich bisher eigentlich nur zwischen Mac und iPad gehabt.
Das geht aber auch von Mac zu Mac?
Das mag sein. Ich habe momentan, bin ich etwas knapp an Macs?
Ich habe eigentlich nur einen aktuell.
Ja, ja, genau. Also ich bin in dem Moment so, ich bin überhaupt nicht knapp
an Macs. Ich habe hier irgendwie zwei stehen, habe es ausprobiert und es funktioniert auch einfach.
Es ist tatsächlich nicht genau das, was ich in dem Moment gemeint habe,
aber trotzdem hat es mir die Gelegenheit gegeben, das überhaupt nochmal auszuprobieren
und ich finde, es ist relativ gut funktioniert.
Also wer das noch nicht ausprobiert hat, wenn jetzt so zwei Geräte in der Nähe
sind und die laufen halt unter derselben Apple ID und man ist da auch irgendwie
eingeloggt und keine Ahnung, was da so noch die,
weiteren Voraussetzungen sind, dann kann man dann tatsächlich mit der Maus so
an den Rand gehen und wenn man es so ein bisschen übertreibt mit dem Maus an
die Rand gehen, dann nimmt das Betriebssystem an, dass da wohl an diesem Rand,
der andere Mac steht, den das System zu dem Zeitpunkt sieht und über Hand-Off
und Security und Auto-Login und so weiter stellt er halt eine sichere Verbindung
her und macht dann quasi so ein Screensharing, was den Effekt hat, dass man mit der einen,
Tastatur und der einen Trackpad-Maus, was auch immer man benutzt,
tatsächlich beide Rechner steuern kann und das geht natürlich auch in die andere Richtung.
Und das ist ganz schön pfiffig eigentlich.
Also es geht mit Macs und iPads, aber nicht mit iPhones, so wie ich das hier hinstelle.
Genau, das kommt nämlich jetzt quasi dazu, warum auch immer,
aber ich denke mal, das hat Gründe und wahrscheinlich hat es was mit Screensize
zu tun oder was weiß ich, was so die Gründe sind.
Ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, wie zuverlässig das ist, aber es funktioniert.
Was ich aber eigentlich meinte in dem Moment, als ich diesen Kommentar gesagt
habe, ist, dass ich so eine Art Interface gerne hätte mit,
Macs, die nicht mit meiner Apple-ID laufen und wo ich nicht gerade eingeloggt
bin, also wenn ich jetzt dir was schicken will, ja, dann ist das irgendwie immer
noch ein Problem, da schickt man das irgendwie in iMessage,
dann hat iMessage irgendwie gerade mal wieder einen Korken oder,
früher hat man ja noch Server aufgemacht, das ist irgendwie so ein bisschen
außer Mode gekommen, aber in gewisser Hinsicht wäre das ja dann eigentlich so
der Weg, aber so, keiner benutzt eigentlich wirklich noch File-Sharing,
weil es dann auch so, dann gibt es natürlich AirDrop.
Ja, klar, AirDrop ist irgendwie da und funktioniert im Prinzip auch schon so relativ gut.
AirDrop funktioniert eigentlich.
AirDrop funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut muss ich jetzt auch zugeben,
dass das eigentlich ganz gut funktioniert.
Wir haben vorhin haben wir darüber gesprochen was in der neuen Version von iOS
eigentlich geil ist und ich weiß jetzt wieder was es ist,
und es ist eigentlich so ein völlig absurd einfaches Feature,
was sie schon längst hätten bringen können ist wenn man in so ein iOS,
Gerät einen USB-Stick einsteckt, dann kann man per Dateien einfach drauf zugreifen.
Das ging vorher nicht und ich weiß nicht wieso und jetzt ist es einfach so, wie es sein soll.
Man steckt ihn rein und dann hat man die Dateien da.
Also das ist irgendwie so, dass in iOS 18, ich sage es ungern, aber in der 18.
Version dieses Betriebssystem, das endlich mal geht, schon fast peinlich.
Das ist so ein, wo ich am Anfang so dachte, so ja, nett und so,
aber ich benutze es relativ viel. Einfach mal gucken.
Und das hieß jetzt erst ein iOS 18? Und was war vorher?
Na ging das nicht.
Also auf welche Art und Weise ging es nicht?
Gar nicht. Auf die gar nicht. Also auf die ist nur ganz blöd, Art und Weise.
Also ich hatte so einen Stick von irgendeinem Hersteller, da war dann so eine
Software dabei, wo man dann die App runterlädt und die App, mit der kann man
dann von dem Stick Dateien auf das iPad kopieren.
Und inzwischen ist es halt so, genau den gleichen Stick ohne die Software,
ich stecke ihn rein und der wird einfach erkannt und los geht's.
Also es ist irgendwie, und der kann auch die üblichen Apple-Betriebsdateisysteme,
so APFS und HFS und so dieses ganze FAT-Gedöns und so weiter, das tut einfach.
Das finde ich, ja, keine Ahnung.
Du willst mir erzählen, dass man vorher, also ich muss zugeben,
dass ich das relativ selten getan habe, aber ich bin jetzt dann doch ein bisschen
überrascht und werde das jetzt live ausprobieren.
Tim kramt gerade diverse Meshbacks mit Adaptern raus.
Dank des Adapters kann ich das jetzt hier dann auch gleich mal ausprobieren
und ich fange an mit iPad.
Früher kannten wir ja noch jedes Detail von diesen scheiß Maschinen und jetzt
kommt man schon echt ins Schludern.
Es ist wirklich zum Heulen. Ich würde ja mal sagen.
Diverse Leute sagen, es ging vorher schon. Also gut, beim iPhone weiß ich es
nicht, beim iPad ging es vorher nicht.
Ohne diese Spezialsoftware. Ich meine nämlich, dass sich das in dem Moment geändert
hat, wo Apple die Treiber für die Dateisysteme so geändert hat,
dass die nicht mehr im Kernelspace laufen.
Und das ist schon zwei oder drei Releases her.
Ja, vielleicht sogar schon noch ein paar mehr, weil sie das quasi immer deshalb
nicht gemacht haben, weil das eben Exzess in Kernelspace bedeutet hätte.
Hier zeigt einer ein Screenshot, Xpand Drive steht da. Das ist genau der Stick,
den ich hatte und ohne die Software Xpand läuft es halt nicht.
Ja.
Und jetzt geht es halt ohne.
Wie Xpand Drive?
Keine Ahnung, was für ein Hersteller ist. Das ist halt die Software,
die dazu gehört. Die musst du halt haben.
Es ist... Egal. Es war für mich ein kleiner Moment des Klicks.
Wo ist denn dein Xpand Drive? Das ist doch genau das, was wir da sehen.
Da oben steht es. Also.
Naja. Egal.
Vielleicht bin ich auch einfach late to the party, aber es funktioniert jetzt.
Ja, also ich habe das jetzt hier mal live ausprobiert und es funktioniert.
Okay.
Also insofern bin ich jetzt ein bisschen...
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht ging es ja nur über, wie heißt diese dämliche Schnittstelle,
Lightning, nicht so richtig.
Sogar das würde ich bezweifeln. Es gab nur relativ wenig Lightning.
Irgendwas macht hier Töne.
Ralf, dein Rucksack spielt eine Melodie ab.
So, was wolltest du uns damit sagen?
Und Ralf muss jetzt schlafen gehen.
Ist das deine persönliche Glücksmelodie?
Ja, okay, gut. Also, für Sie getestet, funktioniert. Wir wissen gar nicht, worüber wir reden.
Also insofern hast du irgendwas anderes, was iOS kann, was die anderen nicht gründen?
Ist es viel Kleinkram dabei?
Nee, so richtig.
Jetzt haben wir so ein Kapitel. Weißt du, wie ich das Kapitel jetzt nenne?
IOS 18 kann was, was iOS 17 schon konnte. Super.
Bester Titel ever.
Ich überlege gerade, nee. Also ja, es gibt halt jetzt diesen Dark Mode für die Icons.
Erstaunlich viele Icons können das schon.
Aber das ist ja jetzt auch keine weltbewegende Änderung irgendwie.
Irgendwie, ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe das ja alles noch nicht installiert. Ich lasse mich dann immer ganz gerne überraschen.
Bin dann allerdings etwas enttäuscht, dass wenn es dann so weit ist,
dass man das Release drauf macht und sich freut, jetzt kommen die gut abgehangenen,
ordentlich durchgetesteten Features,
dass dann nicht das Internet sozusagen so im Minutentakt meldet,
was es für neue Features gibt, weil sich alle schon drei, vier Monate vorher
darüber ausgekotzt haben, was alles neu ist.
Und bestenfalls noch das eine oder andere Update geliefert haben.
Also muss man sich dann mühsam wieder die Liste zusammen klicken.
Und da gibt es ja die Liste von Apple und dann gibt es, was es sonst noch konnte.
Und das finde ich eigentlich immer gerade interessant.
Also muss man dann zu irgendwelchen Happy Sites gehen, die einem dann schön
erklären, was insgesamt alles noch dazugekommen ist. Na gut.
Ralf, du wolltest in die Zukunft schreiten. und in die Vergangenheit schauen
oder sowas ähnliches und hast von einer Webseite berichtet, die hieß,
K. Serra?
Damals wusste ich nicht, wie sie heißt. Dank meiner Frau, die natürlich ein
ewiges Gedächtnis hat und niemals irgendetwas vergisst.
Die wusste sofort, dass es K. Serra hieß. Genau, ich wusste,
es hatte irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, aber hat es dann nicht gefunden.
Und weder Google noch KI haben irgendwo weitergeholfen. Aber K.
Serra, und zwar mit K geschrieben.
K-E-Z-E-R-A.com. Und es gibt diesen Dienst immer noch, nach all den Jahren.
Was ist denn das für eine fiese Schreibweise?
Ja, das andere war schon weg und das klingt dann irgendwie cool.
Und in der Tat findet man dort auch noch meine Predictions.
Das heißt also, wenn man jetzt einfach auf die Seite geht und dann irgendwo
irgendeinen beliebigen User eingibt und dann slash Rstock M,
dann landet man in der Tat auf den Predictions, die ich damals vor zehn Jahren
oder sowas dort eingestellt habe.
Und ich muss sagen, ich bin aus mehreren Gründen emotional berührt,
weil zum einen ist das echt so eine Zeitkapsel in Sachen Webdesign.
Das war so zur Hochphase der Web2-Dienste.
Alle können plötzlich selber Content generieren und sind selber irgendwie Teil
des User-Generated-Content.
Und die haben also seitdem das Design glaube ich nicht mehr angefasst,
aber es sieht echt immer noch ganz schön aus.
Also irgendwo das ist schon so meine Internetzeit auch, die man hier so bestaunen kann.
Deine Internetzeit ist jetzt vorbei?
Ja, also man hat doch schon irgendwie
so einen emotionalen Anker irgendwie häufig zur Technologie und so.
Diese ganzen wilden Web-2-Dienste, das war schon sehr meins.
Ich habe das schon sehr gefeiert.
Wenn ich das richtig entsinne, waren das irgendwie zwei Münchner, die das gemacht haben.
Also ein komplettes Hobbyprojekt ohne jedes Venture-Capital und dieser scheiß
Server läuft immer noch und du kannst immer noch dort Content reinstellen.
Also wenn jemand die Betreiber kennt oder die vielleicht mal irgendwie auf dem
nächsten Kongress aufschlagen oder sowas, mit denen würde ich sehr gerne mal
ein paar Bier mehr ausgeben, dass sie diesen Dienst am Laufen halten,
weil das, was jeder da draußen irgendwie mal sowas gemacht hat,
so alleine den alten Server die ganze Zeit irgendwie durchzupatchen,
das ist schon irgendwie Arbeit.
Und gerade diese Prediction-Seiten leben ja davon, dass sie dann eben auch in
fünf oder zehn Jahren noch erreichbar sind.
Ansonsten ist das Ganze ja so ein bisschen pointless. Dann schauen wir doch mal.
Was du so alles für dich gegeben hast. Hier steht zum Beispiel,
zum Thema Technik sagte Ralf Stockmann voraus, spätestens am 14.
Juli 2020, wir haben heute den 25.
Juli 2024, hat jeder oder jede zweite heutige Smartphone-Besitzerin auch eine Smartwatch.
Aussage kam, das steht aber jetzt hier nicht, warte mal, muss man da draufklicken,
wo steht denn wann das war?
Das war vor neun Jahren, habe ich das eingestellt.
14.
Juli 2015, also du hast es gewagt, fünf Jahre in die Zukunft zu schauen.
Nee, das muss länger her sein. Also hier ganz unten steht, Airstock M hat diese
Vorhersage vor neun Jahren erstellt.
Ja, 14. Juli 2015.
Achso, okay, ja.
Wie ist es denn damit so gelaufen? Es gab sechs Zustimmungen und vier Gegenstimmen.
Also man konnte dann in der Version, die sie irgendwann dazu gebaut haben,
konnte man halt sagen, ja glaube ich auch oder kann man sagen, nee glaube ich nicht.
Vermutlich hat jede zweite Smartphone-Besitzerin heute eine Smartwatch.
Also in unserer Bubble mit Sicherheit, aber in der Gesamtbevölkerung glaube ich.
Hier ist die Quote zwei von, nee drei von drei. Sehr überraschend.
Ja gut, aber wir sind jetzt auch hier in der Opfer-Bubble, was das anbelangt.
Also bei mir auf der Arbeit, auf der Bibliothek, ich gucke da in der Tat drauf,
was haben die Leute für eine Uhr. Das finde ich schon immer noch ein bisschen interessant.
Gerade die Leute, die dann dezidiert keine Smartwatch haben,
sondern so eine Original-Casio noch irgendwie und so. Das ist ja auch immer noch so ein Statement.
Ich würde sagen, bei mir auf der Arbeit erfüllt sich das. Da sind es über 50 Prozent.
Bei dir auf der Arbeit ist übrigens, da du diese Arbeit ja frisch angetreten
hast, überhaupt gar keine Aussage, weil du hast ja gesagt, spätestens 2020,
also vor vier Jahren, sollte ja schon die Hälfte erreicht worden sein.
Ja, also vor vier Jahren war es wahrscheinlich knapp und heute wird es auch
immer noch nicht 50 Prozent sein, glaube ich nicht. Also der bundesrepublikanischen
Bevölkerung glaube ich nicht.
Also ich stelle mir Ralf jetzt gerade so vor, wie er den Leuten an den Arm guckt.
Was haben sie denn für eine Uhr? Ne, das Buch können sie nicht ausleihen.
Also ich würde mal behaupten, das war etwas bold, das Statement und da sind sie nicht so ganz so.
Dann spätestens am 10. November 2012, warte mal, von wann ist denn das?
Das ist am 11. September 2012, also du hast von zwei Monaten gesprochen,
wird Kisera immer noch nicht den Durchbruch geschafft haben,
wenn sie nicht ernsthafte Gamification-Ansätze einführen.
Genau, dazu müssen wir auch wieder ein bisschen in diese Zeitkapsel rein.
Diese Web2-Sturm-und-Drang-Phase, da hat sich halt wirklich binnen Wochen auch
entschieden, ob so ein Dienst halt irgendwie Durchbruch bekommen hatte und auf
Sponnen besprochen wurde und alle Millionen Leute drauf kamen oder eben auch nicht.
Und ich war ein totaler Fan von diesem Konzept und hätte denen das gerne gewünscht
und habe aber halt Unzulänglichkeiten entdeckt und habe die hier schonungslos
in Form von Prediction modelliert und ja, so war es halt auch.
Ja, der nächste Punkt war noch einschlägiger.
Spätestens am 29. August 2012 wird niemand mehr von Kaysera reden,
da sie es nicht schaffen, a.
Vorhersagen öffentlich einsehbar zu machen und b. verifizierbar.
Das erste haben sie dann gemacht in der Tat. Das ist mit Sicherheit nicht jetzt
aufgrund meiner Prediction, aber damals war es so, dass du wirklich eingeloggt
sein musstest in diesen Dienst und nur dann konntest du überhaupt auf irgendwas irgendwie zugreifen.
Und mir war völlig klar, wenn du sowas bringen willst, dann musst du das auf
Twitter verlinken können und alle klicken drauf und finden es lustig und machen
sich dann auch einen Account, aber du musst denen erstmal was zeigen.
Ja, da kannst du nicht drauf rechnen, dass die Leute irgendwie einen Screenshot machen.
Mit dem Verifizierbar, ich glaube, das gibt es immer noch nicht,
das Feature, dass man am Ende sagen kann, ja, hat er recht, hat er nicht recht.
Also ich war immer der Meinung, das muss man stärker mit Gamification halt alles
machen, dass du dann quasi Punkte dafür kriegst, wenn du richtige Vorhersagen
gemacht hast oder dich an andere Vorhersagen drangehangen hast.
Wir kommen gleich zu ein paar Diensten, die das da glaube ich in der Richtung anders machen.
Ich meine, es ist schon, ich wünschte, ich hätte das häufiger gemacht,
so etwas auch aufgeschrieben und so, weil ich ja auch einige wenige Voraussagen
gewagt habe und natürlich davon ausgehe, dass die allermeisten auch zugetroffen haben.
Natürlich.
Habe, dann auch nochmal hervortun. tun. Also falls jemand sich da mal wirklich
auf die Suche begeben möchte, keine Ahnung, inwiefern die Tools da heutzutage
schon ausreichend helfen, da wäre ich auf jeden Fall ganz scharf drauf, also in jeder Hinsicht.
Ich arbeite da an was.
Aber das kann hier und jetzt noch nicht verraten werden, weil es jetzt gar nicht
im Podcast, also nicht in meinem Privat-Podcast-Bereich ist,
sondern weil ich da vielleicht,
Eckgeschichte für Berlin und Podcasts und sowas habe und Infrastruktur.
Also ein Infrastrukturmensch. Und da würde das in der Tat eine Rolle spielen.
Ich melde mich mal wieder, wenn ich da ein bisschen was vorzuweisen habe.
Okay, ich glaube, die Kisera-internen Predictions können wir jetzt mal ignorieren.
Eins würde ich vielleicht noch aufgreifen oder zwei.
Spätestens im Mai 15 wird man keine Handys mehr ohne Retina-Display kaufen können.
Und das ist auch gut so.
Da bin ich mir nicht so ganz so sicher, ob das dann auch so war.
Also keine, keine wahrscheinlich nicht. Also es war natürlich schon immer etwas schärfer formuliert.
Also was du meintest, es werden keine neuen Telefone mehr gebracht,
die das nicht haben und ich glaube, das war dann auch so.
Naja, ich weiß nicht, ob am unteren Ende des Android-Spektrums da nicht vielleicht
doch noch das eine oder andere Gerät war.
2015 ist aber auch schon lange her.
Ja, schon lange her.
Für Apple mag das hinhauen.
Weil Aber was du vielleicht überprüfen könntest, ist spätestens am 30.
Dezember 2012 wird der Begriff Narrativ eine eine höhere Google-Trendscore für
Deutschland erreichen als Diskurs.
Was auch immer das wieder für ein Ralf-Stopp-Einsatz ist.
Daran erinnere ich mich noch ganz gut, weil das war ja auch zu Hochzeiten unseres
Wikigeeks-Podcasts mit Claudia zusammen.
Und das war wirklich eine Sendung vorher sind wir zum ersten Mal in unserem
Leben über den Begriff Narrativ gestolpert.
Der hat euch auch nicht losgelassen, oder?
Also heute kennt man das ja auch, was ich alternativlos mit Major Major Constant
Narrative, doch, der Begriff hat definitiv deine echte Karriere auch gemacht.
Ob jetzt mehr als Diskurs, müsste ich in der Tat, ich kann das ja nebenbei mal
versuchen irgendwie rauszukriegen und falls ich da zu Ergebnissen komme, gucke ich mir das mal an.
Gibt es Google Trends überhaupt noch oder haben die das auch abgestaltet, wie alles was gut war?
Keine Ahnung.
Mal erstmal gucken, es gibt es glaube ich noch.
Google Trends gibt es noch, ja. Ja.
So, genau. Machen wir mal so nebenbei.
Es kamen dann von Hörerinnenseite aus auch noch andere Dienste.
Unter anderem eine davon, die auch in der Freakshow besprochen wurde.
Damals noch Mobile Max. Und zwar in Ausgabe 72, nämlich GetAmen hieß der.
Die haben also was relativ ähnliches gemacht und der Dienst ist so nicht mehr
auffindbar, dass selbst die Wayback-Maschine nicht mehr vernünftig findet.
Ich habe eben mal versucht, da irgendwie zurückzugehen und zu gucken, wie sah das Ganze aus.
Und es kommen irgendwie kryptische China-Zeichen und kaputte 404er-Seiten.
Also ich habe irgendwo einen Link gefunden, der so halbwegs funktioniert.
Aber die haben es also mal nicht geschafft, wie die beiden Münchner ihren Dienst
einigermaßen am Start zu halten.
Und das ist natürlich für so eine Prediction-Geschichte schon dann ein bisschen tragisch.
Dann gibt es noch longbets.org.
Was wurde noch genannt? Habe ich mir jetzt nicht genauer angeguckt,
aber würde ich mal sagen, ist ziemlich halt auch die Einflugsschneise.
Und einen Dienst, den ich auch noch, auf die gucke ich mir irgendwann mal genauer
an, was davon zu halten ist, Liste setzen würde, war metaculous.org.
Da geht es weniger darum, dass
man jetzt privat irgendwelche Wetten und Vorhersagen macht, sondern eher,
was sind Indikatoren aufgrund von welcher Datenlage auch immer,
mit der man quasi so datengetriebene Vorhersagen in die Zukunft machen kann.
Das kommt, glaube ich, aus einer etwas problematischen Ecke,
müsste ich mir nochmal angucken, also in Richtung Silicon Valley und wir glauben
daran, dass man mit Technologie alles lösen und alles erklären kann,
müsste man sich nochmal ein bisschen genauer angucken.
Wenn das interessant ist, dann bringe ich das irgendwann nochmal mit rein in die Sendung.
Who will be elected US President in 2024?
Und da kann man sich jetzt hier Prediction-Kurven anschauen und da tut sich gerade was.
Wo hast du das? Kannst du daraus irgendwie einen Link generieren oder sowas?
Ja, da kann ich auch einen Link mal hier in den Slack.
Ah, da gibt es ja auch den Election Hub. Okay, da hast du.
Genau. Vielen Dank.
Ich weiß noch nicht so ganz genau, wie das funktioniert, aber das sieht auf
jeden Fall alles sehr aufwendig gemacht aus, mit Kommentaren und so weiter.
Die waren auf jeden Fall der Meinung in den letzten Wochen, dass Joe Biden keine Chance hat.
Das hat Joe Biden wahrscheinlich gelesen und ja.
Ja, das wird es gewesen sein.
Man geht ja auch, also so habe ich tatsächlich aber auch die Story gehört,
dass er sich am Ende wegen der Vorhersagen dazu entschlossen hat, zu gehen.
Weil er eingesehen hat, dass er sozusagen nicht mehr das Mojo hat,
mit dem er jetzt irgendwie.
Es gab, ich glaube in der Tat am Anfang auf X, aber dann auch auf so ziemlich
allen anderen Plattformen, hat so jeder Zweite den Vergleich dann aufgegriffen,
dass wer sich jetzt beschwert, warum ist beiden so spät zurückgekommen und hätten
die nicht früher überzeugen können,
dieses ja hast du schon mal versucht deine Eltern davon zu überzeugen ihren
Führerschein abzugeben, weil sie zu alt sind.
Das ist so in etwa dieselbe Debatte.
Das ist ja auch schwierig, also man fühlt sich ja, also wenn du mir jetzt sagst,
ich bin alt, so dann ist das so rein, also es ist ja immer eine relative Geschichte erstmal,
aber man will ja nicht alt sein,
weil man eben denkt, dann habe ich sozusagen die Spritzigkeit von Joe Biden.
Das wird damit halt so.
Tech-Aspekt. Jetzt hat ja dieser Trump diesen J.D. Vance-Alternat, als Vizepräsident,
Vizepräsidentin, Kandidat vorgeschlagen und dann auch wohlbekommen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, muss das eigentlich von der Partei dann auch abgenommen werden?
Egal, das findet ja eh alles so per Akklamation statt.
Und der Typ ist ja nun wirklich shady.
Shady Vance.
Ja, shady Vance.
Der ist ja Ja, der ist ja noch nicht mal zwei Jahre überhaupt in der Politik.
Jaja, der wurde ja quasi von Peter Thiel großgezogen.
So sieht es aus. Und wem der Name Peter Thiel nichts sagt, das solltet ihr mal
nachschlagen, weil das ist so ein bisschen...
Der hat zusammen mit Elon Paypal gegründet.
Er hat mit Elon Musk Paypal gegründet, der ist auch ein ganz wichtiger Frühfinanzierer
von Facebook gewesen, hat also ganz erheblich dazu beigetragen,
dass Facebook am Anfang überhaupt die Kohle hatte, um durchzustarten.
Peter Thiel ist dementsprechend Multimilliardär und so weiter,
aber eben einer, der nicht so sehr im Licht der Öffentlichkeit steht,
jetzt permanent zum Mikrofon greift, aber überall mit drin steckt.
Und was ich ja wirklich für einen extrem beunruhigenden Trend halte,
ist so diese libertäre Verrohung des Tech-Sektors im Silicon Valley und beyond.
Also das ist ja wirklich etwas, was sich jetzt so in den letzten zehn Jahren
immer weiter abgezeichnet hat.
Ich habe es am Anfang selber nicht so gesehen, dann vielleicht auch nicht glauben wollen,
aber vielleicht mal zu dem Begriff, also Libertär ist ja so ein Begriff,
wenn ich das richtig sehe, primär so in der amerikanischen Welt.
Denkweise überhaupt definiert ist.
Und Libertäre sind halt so Antistaat pro Markt, so ein bisschen FDP auf Drogen.
Und diese Libertäre-Bewegung,
die ist halt unter anderem bei diesen ganzen Silicon Valley-Interpreneuren ist
das halt einfach schon so richtig zu so einer Religion geworden.
Nicht nur jetzt bei den total super Reichen, sondern es ist einfach generell
etwas, was man dort findet.
Und dieses Libertäre ist extrem, also antisozial geprägt in meiner Sicht der Dinge.
Und am Ende heißt es eigentlich auch nur so, ich bin reich, so soll es bleiben.
Nach dem Motto, ihr könnt mir irgendwie gar nichts und das Das Ganze wird natürlich,
wie immer, über diesen Begriff der Freiheit kanalisiert.
Und Reichtum manifestiert sich in dieser Denkweise eben auch auf völlig gerechte Art und Weise.
Weil also Intelligenz ist der alles entscheidende Faktor. Und wer nur intelligent
genug ist, der wird dann auch reich werden, automagisch.
Und das sind dann auch diejenigen, die gefälligst dann alles zu steuern haben.
Also lest euch mal wirklich zu Peter Thiel den deutschen Wikipedia-Artikel durch,
Wo man jetzt glaube ich nicht irgendwie besonders skandalträchtig das unterstellen würde.
Also ich lese jetzt mal nur einen Satz vor, daraus zum Thema Ideologie.
Aus ähnlichen Gründen sieht er das Frauenwahlrecht kritisch,
obwohl man es seiner Einschätzung nach auch nicht abschaffen sollte.
Aber Beteiligung von Frauen sei, wie Wahlen und demokratische Partizipation
überhaupt, kein erfolgsversprechender Weg zur Steuerung einer freien Gesellschaft.
Okay.
K is closed. Wie gerade eben gesagt, also J.D.
Vance ist also wirklich ein totales Ziehkind von dem und genau der soll jetzt
also stellvertretender Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika mit den
meisten Atombomben werden. Da kann einem ein ganz klein wenig gruselig werden.
Genau, weil der ist jetzt überhaupt in die Politik überhaupt nur durch die Kohle
von Peter Thiel gekommen.
Vorher hat er in all seinen ganzen Venture-Kapital-Buden irgendwelchen Quatsch gemacht.
Und warum Thiel ausgerechnet ihn jetzt gewählt hat, weiß ich nicht, aber,
offensichtlich hat er da einfach die passend formbare Person gefunden,
die er da so als Tool in die Gesellschaft reinbringen kann und hat dann irgendwie
mit viel Kohle ihn zum Senator für Ohio gemacht.
Also jedes Land in den USA, jeder Staat, stellt ja zwei Senatoren im US Senate.
Einer davon ist halt dieser J.D. Vance.
Ja, und dann ist er auch von so einem Trump Also es ist ja von ihm verschiedenste
Verlautbarungen bekannt,
wo er Trump irgendwie mit Hitler vergleicht und viele andere schlimme Dinge
über ihn sagt, die man durchaus hat teilen können.
Mittlerweile ist er sein Vizepräsidentenkandidat und es macht also sehr den
Eindruck, dass dieser Vance eigentlich nur von Trump gewählt wurde.
Einerseits, weil er halt so ein Asskisser ist, dem also nicht dazwischen redet.
Ganz ehrlich, meine persönliche Theorie ist, dass Trump die hat alle auflaufen
lassen und gesagt hat, hier, wie viel?
Naja, damit wollte ich meinen Satz gerade beenden. Es ist halt im Wesentlichen
die unmittelbare und schlecht verkleidete, unmittelbare Verbindung zum Großgeld.
Also Peter Thiel mit seinen Milliarden stellt dann hier mal so die Person und
worum auch immer der sich dann kümmern soll, Hauptsache es erstmal platziert
und Trump ist es halt eigentlich egal, weil ihm geht es sowieso nicht um Politik.
Es geht ihm nur um sich selber und um Geld und um Macht und Reichtum und Einfluss
und behaupten, dass alle die ganze Zeit um ihn herumlaufen und erzählen,
wie großartig er ist. Das ist sozusagen alles.
Also die Kombination ist jetzt mal wirklich scheiße.
Es ist einfach so absurd, es ist eine Grand Old Party, die Republikaner solche
Leute aufs Schild heben und es nicht gebacken bekommen, dort irgendwie mal resiliente
Kräfte weiterzulassen.
Also ich war noch nie ein besonderer Fan der amerikanischen,
republikanischen Partei, aber es ist jetzt nicht besser geworden.
Aber man sieht hier sehr schön, wie es bei uns auch gelaufen ist, so vor 100 Jahren.
Und das ist durchaus leider ein kopierbarer Vorgang und du hast halt immer die
Religion mit drin, du hast das Geld mit drin und du hast Leute drin,
die sich eigentlich nur um sich selber kümmern primär.
Aber natürlich die ganze Zeit behaupten, es wäre genau das Gegenteil.
Mich schmerzt konkret diese Verbindung zum Tech-Sektor,
weil das natürlich so für meine
Generation war natürlich dieser ganze Technologieaufbruch mit Computern,
so Gründung des Chaos Computer Clubs und so weiter, das war ja auch so ein bisschen so eine,
Befreiungslehre von unten so dieses, jetzt haben wir die Werkzeuge,
um mitspielen zu können, jetzt haben wir die Werkzeuge, um kommunizieren zu
können wir haben uns der Illusion hingegeben, dass wir alle erstmal ein Sprachrohr haben,
dass das eine gute Sache ist und so weiter und es ist halt sehr viel dieser
alten Illusionen die wir hatten.
Ist zusammengebrochen mit Mit Social Media und dieser ganzen Verrohung und der
Totalüberwachung der Kommunikation in einem System,
wo wir immer gedacht haben,
das Internet schleicht sich immer wieder um die Ecke und ist gar nicht so richtig abhörbar.
Ist auch alles geplatzt und jetzt gehen halt auch noch so die letzten helden die,
früher mal so steve jobs und so eine leute die wie soll ich sagen auch mit einer
gesellschaftlichen verantwortung und mit mit mit so einer gebildeten agenda
daher kam da würde ich sogar bill gates nennen ja der.
Jahrzehnten mittlerweile seine Kohle nutzt, um Dinge besser zu machen.
Da kann man dann im Einzelnen drüber streiten, ob er das dann auch Erfolg hat
oder nicht, aber der hat viel Geld in die Entwicklung von Impfstoffen gesteckt.
Toiletten und so ein Kram. Ja, genau.
Dann, was weiß ich, Malaria-Forschung und so weiter.
Also alles Mögliche auch im Energiebereich und so.
Ich will jetzt gar nicht Ich habe es auch als Detail jetzt nicht einzeln überprüft,
wie erfolgreich das ist.
Das muss es ja auch nicht unbedingt immer sein, aber zumindest so ein bisschen diesen Weg zu weisen.
Und dann hatte ich auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl am Anfang,
dass auch dieser Elon Musk mit seinen tollen Elektroautos auch diesen Pfad einschlägt
und dass man so mit der Power of Tech die Welt zu einem besseren Ort machen
kann. Und was haben wir jetzt?
Jetzt rantet der den ganzen Tag irgendwie über Lips und, was ist nochmal das andere Schimpfwort?
Woke-Gruppen? Wokeismus. Und ist generell einfach nur abstoßend und scheiße.
Und damit bricht eigentlich so ein bisschen meine alte Welt zusammen, was das betrifft.
Ich meine, ich bin fern davon jetzt gerade Silicon Valley und sozusagen Amerika,
ich bin jetzt wirklich kein Amerika-Fan per se, war mir immer schon so ein bisschen,
suspekt, aber es sind ja auch nicht alle Menschen gleich und man kann jetzt
auch nicht sagen, die sind so und die sind so, sondern du hast immer solche und solche.
Aber wir sind ja immer davon ausgegangen, dass im Tech-Sektor sind alle so ein
bisschen intelligenter, im Tech-Sektor haben alle irgendwie so ein bisschen so Checkung,
die können so in die Zukunft gucken und was sollte man sonst mit der Zukunft
machen, als sie besser werden zu lassen, als sie war und mit Tech kann man das
ja ganz toll machen und überhaupt,
jetzt haben die auch noch Geld und jetzt können die das formen und die alten
blöden Politiker, die räumen wir jetzt mal aus dem Weg und jetzt ist alles scheiße.
Also, das ist frustrierend. Ich glaube, du musst den Stream mal neu starten,
die Leute beschweren sich ganz fürchterlich. Was?
Dass es irgendwie scheinbar knistert und knuscht.
Ja, ich wüsste nicht, was ich da...
Ich kann vielleicht die Pause nutzen, um noch einen Begriff reinzuwerfen,
den man auch mal gerne ein bisschen nachlesen kann in dem Kontext.
Das ist Effective Altruism, also effektiver Altruismus.
Und das ist halt auch so dieser Grenzbereich von, ja so ganz schlecht ist die
Idee ja eigentlich gar nicht, aber wenn sie dann eben doch von den falschen
Leuten zu Ende gedacht wird, dann kommen dann doch wieder gruselige Sachen bei raus.
Also gestartet ist das halt unter der Prämisse zu sagen, okay,
wenn man denn altruistische Aktionen machen möchte, also sprich Geld spenden,
Projekte unterstützen,
also Bill Gates mit Impfstoffen und so weiter, dann sollte man das so tun,
dass das eingesetzte Geld maximalen Effekt hat und nicht irgendwelche Quatschprojekte unterstützen.
Da kann ja erstmal keiner was gegen haben.
Wenn man sich gerade so die Historie der Entwicklungshilfe anguckt,
da ist ja auch vieles wirklich versenkt worden und dort irgendwie grundsätzlich
zu schauen, okay, was hat auch langfristig welchen Einfluss,
da kann ja keiner was gegen haben.
Und dann hört man sich aber diese Typen an, wenn die dann halt sagen, ja,
aber langfristig, da wollen wir schon so ein paar Jahrhunderte denken und das
Einzige, was uns dann da interessiert, ist also so die menschliche Intelligenz
und menschlicher Geist und wir sind der Meinung, dass sie durch Maschinen viel
besser transportiert werden können als durch Menschen.
Und wenn jetzt hier dafür ein paar Millionen oder auch mal ein paar Milliarden
über die Klinge springen müssen an Menschen, dafür, dass wir irgendwie dann
eine super KI stattdessen gebaut
haben, die uns dann weiter ins All hinaus führt, dann merkst du, okay,
die gehen halt dann in ihrem Mindset auch wirklich gerne und bewusst über Leichen.
Das muss man schon auf so eine harte Formel bringen. Also lest euch da mal ein bisschen ein.
Das ist alles wirklich nicht erfreulich und die haben halt wirklich mal viel Geld und viel Einfluss.
Das sind jetzt nicht irgendwelche Spinnerten und Idioten, worunter man so ja
die Trump-Follower gerne mal irgendwie subsumiert, sondern das sind Leute,
die meinen das schon ganz schön ernst.
Ja klar, die wollen natürlich diesen faschistischen Rechtsumschwung,
den Trump quasi verkörpert, den wollen die natürlich.
Was ich bei Elon Musk auch ganz interessant fand war, dass er seinen Nimbus
so komplett verloren hat, weil er den Cybertruck so verkackt hat.
Also das Auto ist ja nur richtig Kacke.
Ja, aber die Leute, die es jetzt beim Cybertruck merken, oh,
er kann es nicht mehr, die sind aber auch irgendwie drei, vier Jahre zu spät, oder?
Ja gut, der Start von Model 3 war auch ganz schön rocky.
Also das war schon auch ganz schön fies, was da am Anfang passiert ist.
Aber so schlimm wie beim Cybertruck war es da glaube ich nicht. Also, naja.
Kennt ihr dieses Video, Mum versus Cybertruck? Das suche ich mal raus.
Das ist herrlich. Ich muss mal gucken, ob ich das finde.
Also, diese Gleichziehung mit irgendwie, was Elon Musk kann und was seine Firmen
können, ich glaube, das Narrativ kann man mal begraben, ja.
Arbeiten ja mehrere Leute, wie ihr wahrscheinlich gemerkt habt und diese Darstellung,
dass Elon Musk überall ist und alles macht, kann man sich glaube ich von trennen.
Der ist so damit beschäftigt, auf Twitter alle niederzuschreien.
Niemals ist der noch nennenswert an der Entwicklung oder an der Definition,
was diese Produkte können und so weiter aktiv beteiligt.
Er mag so ein bisschen, er mag nach wie vor so eine Trajektorie Industrie vorgeben,
die sagt, ja, be bold und reißt alles mit dem Arsch ein, was die Industrie bisher
gemacht hat. Und wir denken das mal anders.
Und das ist ihm ja sowohl mit Tesla gelungen, als auch mit SpaceX,
das muss man ja auch mal zugestehen.
Und das machen jetzt diese Unternehmen auch noch eine Weile so weiter,
ganz unabhängig davon, was jetzt sein konkreter Einfluss ist.
Alles richtig, aber so Unternehmen fangen schon vom Kopf an aus zu stinken und
wenn Elon Musk sich ähnlich wie Steve Jobs damals hingestellt hätte und die
Leute irgendwie direkt gefeuert hätten,
wenn die irgendwie Mist abliefern,
dann würden die keinen Mist abliefern.
Also ich glaube, das ist so, naja.
Auf jeden Fall, Silicon Valley ist ein Problem. Wer gewinnt jetzt?
Wer wird jetzt Präsident?
Also seid ihr optimistisch, dass jetzt Kamala es reißen wird?
Ich bin jetzt verhalten optimistisch. Also vorher war es schon irgendwie im
Bereich von hoffnungslos und jetzt hat man überhaupt mal wieder irgendwie sowas,
wo man sagen kann, daran kann es überhaupt eine Strategie hängen.
Weil also an irgendjemanden, der egal bei welchem Fernsehauftritt eigentlich
den Eindruck hat, macht gleich Kippter bewusstlos nach hinten über,
dass du so einen nicht als Präsidenten haben willst, ist irgendwie schon nachvollziehbar.
So und jetzt können sie ein bisschen was reißen.
Also ich würde sagen, mein Optimist-O-Meter hat schon einen gewissen Ausschlag
gehabt, aber eingefahren ist das noch nicht, der Sieg, würde ich mal sagen.
Nee, auf keinen Fall ist da irgendwas eingefahren, aber es nimmt natürlich eine
interessante Wendung und ich finde es insofern auch schon ganz bemerkenswert,
als dass ja alle nun gedacht haben, nach diesem komischen Attentat auf Trump,
jetzt wäre ja irgendwie alles vorbei.
Und eine Woche später wird der ganze Newsflow schon wieder von anderen Nachrichten diktiert.
Also da steht uns sicherlich noch einiges bevor. Ich persönlich bin ja eigentlich
schon immer ein Fan, ist jetzt ein großes Wort, aber mir gefielen von den damaligen
Präsidentschaftsbewerbern,
wo sich dann beiden ja letzten Endes durchgesetzt hat, gefiel mir Kamala Harris
und Pete Buttigieg sowieso am besten.
Und klar, die hatten damals einfach nicht diesen Appeal und sicherlich war Biden
damals auch die richtige Wahl, das hat man ja gesehen, er hat ja immerhin gewonnen.
Aber dass sie quasi jetzt als Vize so die potenzielle Nachfolgerin werden könnte,
die Hoffnung hatte ich eigentlich schon immer.
Nur hat Biden das irgendwie zu spät gemerkt.
In gewisser Hinsicht ist es jetzt auch schon wieder geil, weil jetzt durch diesen
Move sich das Tramplager komplett auf einen anderen Gegner eingestellt hat und
jetzt so ein bisschen in der Luft rudert.
Denen werden sicherlich ein paar schlimme Sachen noch einfallen,
aber sie können auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge der Pläne wegschmeißen.
Was ich lustig fand, ist, dass sie ja auf Fox News erstmal diskutiert haben,
dass Kamala Harris ja will, dass Plastikstrohhalme verboten werden.
Und irgendjemand meinte, they are clutching at straws.
Also es ist irgendwie… Sie was? Sie halten sich an Strohhalmen fest. Achso.
Also, ja, nee, keine Ahnung. Also es ist sicherlich, glaube ich,
auch ganz gut, dass die ganze Trump-Campaign jetzt echt auf dem falschen Fuß erwischt wurde,
weil die, glaube ich, wirklich das nicht auf dem Plan hatten,
dass so eine Wende so kurz vorher noch kommt.
Das ist, glaube ich, einerseits gut, andererseits ist es, glaube ich,
auch ganz gut, dass Harris jetzt mehr oder weniger schon...
Ich sag mal, quasi gesetzt ist und sich die Demokraten eigentlich intern gar
nicht mehr streiten können.
Also ich glaube, der Vorteil ist vor allem, dass man an sie jetzt überhaupt
mal wieder sowas wie eine Kampagne dranhängen kann.
Das war bei beiden einfach völlig unmöglich. Es gibt da jetzt eine Sache,
die mag ich persönlich sehr. Ich glaube nicht, dass sie sonderlich wirkungsmächtig
wird, aber ich habe sie gerade mal in den Chat reingepostet.
Ihr erinnert euch alle an die Barack-Obama- Pop-Art-Poster, wo Hope so der der große Slogan war.
Mit irgendwie das blaue, etwas stilisierte Porträt von ihm, wo er so schräg
in die Zukunft nach rechts oben guckt.
Ach, die Zukunft ist rechts oben?
Es gibt ja in der Psychologie irgendwie, ob du nach links oben oder rechts oben
guckst, das hat unterschiedliche Bewandtnisse.
Zwischen irgendwie ich erinnere mich und ich erfinde gerade irgendwie etwas. Müssen wir mal gucken.
Bewegung von Augen in den Ecken kann ich gleich auch mal nachrecherchieren.
So, also dieses Hauptplakat war damals bei Barack Obama so allgegenwärtig.
Jetzt hat sich jemand hingesetzt und hat das quasi jetzt mal auf die weiteren
Präsidenten ausgeführt.
Also sprich, dann hast du halt so ein typisches Trump-Bild, wo er also durch
die Gegend schreit und da ist dann unten drunter der Claim Hate.
So, und dann hast du den sehr seriös distinguiert schauenden Biden.
Darunter war dann der Claim Heal. Ja, also der musste heilen,
das was Trump vorher kaputt geschrien hat mit seinem Hate.
Und über all dem ist jetzt also Harris mit dem Slogan rise, also empor wachsen
wieder und jetzt mal gemeinsam in die Zukunft.
Das ist einfach ein schönes Meme und sowas hättest du mit beiden einfach nie machen können.
Mal gucken, wo das noch hingeht. Ich bin da, also ich glaube die Demokraten
sind auch nicht so völlig verdeppert, wie es immer behauptet wird.
Die Rückkehr der Jedi-Ritterin.
Genau, ich glaube da geht noch was.
Ja.
Jetzt mache ich nochmal hier ein Zitierfegen, wo das Bild enthalten ist.
So.
Alright.
Genug Politik.
Zu dem Politik-Teil. Kurze Anmerkung übrigens noch.
IOS 18 kann doch was Neues mit deinem USB-Stick machen.
Formatieren.
Genau.
Ja, super.
Das kannst du ja mal ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert.
Ja.
Hier, den kannst du formatieren.
Soll ich dir mal dein USB-Stick formatieren?
Kannst du da drauf gehen. So Ralf, jetzt hast du vorhin Wir essen ja immer vor
der Sendung Das macht sich auch ganz gut Du wirkst doch schon sehr viel frischer
als noch vor einer Stunde,
Zur Kenntnis gegeben, dass weder Oliven noch rohen Käse Also was meinst du mit rohen Käse?
Du meinst roh Milch Nicht überbackenen Käse Nicht überbackenen Käse?
Nicht überbackenen Käse Eine Scheibe Gouda ist für dich roher Käse? Oder was?
Meinst du jetzt ohne Hitzezuführung oder was?
Also es gibt ja Lebensmittel, die einfach ihren Geschmack sehr radikal ändern,
wenn man sie kocht oder überbackt.
Das gilt für nahezu alles, ja.
Nicht alles, aber einiges mehr, anderes weniger. Zum Beispiel radikal Tomaten.
Eine rohe Tomate schmeckt wirklich sehr, also eine Möhre.
Aber was schmeckt denn nicht anders, wenn du sie erhitzt?
Eine Möhre, sag ich ja gerade.
Eine Möhre ist furchtbar, wenn du sie erhitzt.
Naja, das hängt mal ganz davon ab.
Wie du sie erhitzt. Also Möhren nur roh.
Also ich würde sagen, ja, fast
jeder Geschmack ändert sich, aber halt mal stärker und mal weniger stark.
Und der Unterschied zwischen einer gekochten Möhre und einer rohen Möhre ist
deutlich geringer als der zwischen einer rohen Tomate und einer gekochten Tomate.
Das ist plötzlich ein komplett anderer Geschmack.
Das sehe ich überhaupt nicht so.
Ich kann dir auch noch nicht ganz folgen, aber mach erstmal weiter.
Und so ist es bei Käse halt auch. Auch überbackener Käse wechselt sehr dramatisch
seinen Geschmack gegenüber rohem, nicht überbackenen, unprozessierten Käse.
Okay.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht, worüber du
reden möchtest, aber ich kann gerne weiterreden. Also so ist es ja nicht.
Naja, ich hatte dich so verstanden, ich dachte jetzt, es geht um Rohmilchkäse.
Nee, nee, nee, Käse. Ich mag keinen Käse, Punkt. So, jetzt ist es raus.
Ja, auch keinen Rohmilchkäse, auch keinen französischen wunderbaren Stinkelkäse.
Frischkäse geht. Also als Kind habe ich überhaupt gar keinen Käse gegessen. Nicht überbacken.
Darum sind auch Gerichte wie Pizza für mich, bis ich Mitte 20 war,
völlig unattraktiv gewesen, weil ich halt schlicht keinen überbackenen,
auch damals nicht überbackenen Käse mochte. drin.
So Stückchen für Stückchen robbe ich mich daran.
Mozzarella?
Ungern. Essig, wenn es sein muss und es nichts anderes gibt,
aber eigentlich ungern.
Und Oliven?
Oliven zu mögen ist doch im Prinzip der Einstieg ins Erwachsenensein.
Ja, das habe ich dann.
Na gut, nicht alle Oliven sind so, dass man sagen würde, Also bei mir gibt es
auch eine gewisse Grenze. Wenn die zu heftig sind, dann...
Zu heftig? Zu heftig was?
Kann ich schwer beschreiben, aber es sind vor allen Dingen die Schwarzen,
die kleinen Schrumpflingen, die schon extrem reinhauen.
Aber alles bis Kalamata ist kein Thema.
Also es gibt halt, also bei Oliven sage ich aber auch so, das muss man nicht.
Also Oliven schmecke ich halt und Olivenöl nehme ich, wenn ich irgendwie mediterran
koche, dann nehme ich freiwillig Olivenöl, das schon.
Aber bei Käse bedauere ich halt, ich würde halt gerne Käse mögen,
weil das halt einfach so ein schöner, großer, riesiger Kosmos ist,
in dem man sich da tummeln kann.
Aber was für ein...
Von daher probiere ich es auch regelmäßig, ein paar Mal pro Jahr,
ob es jetzt endlich mal Klick macht. Also Parmesan auch gut.
Dann musst du mal nach Frankreich in die Käsetherapie gehen.
Käsetherapie?
Ja, also ich meine, Frankreich ist einfach das Käse-Epizentrum.
Das kann man nicht anders sagen.
Ja, ich weiß, auch andere Länder
und so und die Holländer rollen das zum Bahnhof, alles schön und gut.
Aber ich finde einfach, Frankreich führt die Welt kulturell einfach an,
was das Essen betrifft in puncto Milchprodukte.
Also es gibt andere Segmente wie Fisch zum Beispiel, da führen die Japaner.
Aber Käse, everything cheese, ist einfach Frankreich, das haben einfach alle
anderen Kulturen der Welt, haben niederzuknien vor Frankreich,
weil die es einfach mal raus haben.
Also ich bin ja Team Italien, aber gut, da wären wir jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht offen.
Aber nicht beim Käse.
Ja, es gibt gute italienische Käsesorten, aber wenn du dann erstmal in Paris
auf so einem Käsemarkt stehst und einfach die ganzen schleimigen, schimmligen,
beim Hinschauen so zerfließenden Käse, die einfach einen furchtbaren Gestank
von sich geben und so lecker sind, ist einfach.
Ein Einwand eurer Ehren?
Schweiz.
Naja, die Schweiz hat ja einen französischen Teil. Ich glaube, daran liegt es so.
Und ich bin auch, was das Fondue betrifft, ganz dabei.
Also Fondue ist sehr lecker.
Auch im Chat gerade Raclette liebe ich mittlerweile. Ist aber halt überbacken.
Und da kann es dann auch gar nicht heftig genug sein von der Käsesorte her also
auch Parmesan habe ich auch gerne den, der dann schon ganz schön,
zuschlägt, also von daher es hat so eine gewisse irrationale Note und ich hoffe
auch das hat Geschmack immer Gebt mich nicht auf, ja da komme ich gleich noch
wenn es auf meine Jungs geht irgendwie also gebt mich nicht auf,
irgendwann wird das vielleicht mit dem Käse noch so, also es ist ja nicht so,
dass ich nicht will, ganz im Gegenteil Ja okay.
Werd mal erwachsen, isst mal einen Oliven.
Ja und was mich halt aber wirklich verstört sind halt jetzt meine Jungs Also
ich habe einer von den sieben, einer fünf und der eine probiert sehr sehr viel,
nicht alles, aber sehr sehr viel.
Der andere ist praktisch überhaupt nichts.
Der hat einen Korridor, der noch viel enger ist als mein eigener,
obwohl wieder selbe Erziehung, selbes Genmaterial, dieselben Gerichte vorgesetzt.
Und die beiden zueinander haben auch praktisch null Überschneidung von dem, was sie dann mögen.
Das heißt also die wenigen Dinge, die der eine nicht mag, die mag dann der andere wiederum.
Da fragt man sich dann schon immer, warum?
Wo ist der evolutionale, evolutionstechnische Vorteil davon,
dass Kinder so absurde Nichtgeschmäcker haben? Weil so vieles,
wenn es irgendwie bitter schmeckt, kann ich alles nachvollziehen,
dass man das dann nicht irgendwie haben will.
Aber der eine isst irgendwie keine Pommes oder Schokolade.
Anton isst keine Schokolade.
Was, also, warum?
Bei meinen ist es so, dass die insgesamt sehr unterschiedlich sind.
Der Große war schon immer experimentierfreudig ohne Ende.
Da sind wir irgendwie im Restaurant, alle anderen Kinder Pommes mit Wurst und
viel Ketchup und haste nicht gesehen und er wollte Königsberger Klopse haben.
Wo du so denkst, was geht denn jetzt, was geht denn hier schief irgendwie.
Und der Kleine, der hatte eine sehr lange Zeit, dessen Kohlenhydrate mit Ketchup.
Was anderes ging im Wesentlichen nicht.
Und dann war das auch egal, ob Reis oder Nudeln oder Kartoffeln oder Pommes.
Ich weiß, das ist eigentlich das Gleiche, aber du weißt, was ich meine.
War einfach Kohlenhydrate mit Pommes fertig, mit Ketchup.
Aber der hat sich auch geöffnet. Also das ändert sich dann schon auch.
Ja, ich bin da auch bei beiden ganz zuversichtlich, weil ich glaube,
das Interesse an Kochen, das haben sie beide.
Ja, die finden das schon spannend und ich lasse die auch immer alle mitmachen
Und die dürfen auch schon da das Rührei bauen und sowas. Alles unproblematisch.
Aber wie gesagt, ich sehe da den Evolutionsvorteil nicht. Warum?
Apropos Käse und Evolution, im Chat wird ja gerade erwähnt, Cheddar völlig unterschätzt
und da muss ich auch sagen, ja das stimmt,
also jedes Land hat auch irgendwie immer irgendeine Art oder zwei Käsesorten,
wo ich sagen würde, das ist auch ein Beitrag zum Weltkulturkäsegut, definitiv.
Cheddar is among them und es ist halt nur so, die Franzosen haben halt das 100-fache davon.
Also es ist einfach überhaupt kein Vergleich.
Trotzdem Cheddar ist toll. Warum heißt der Cheddar Cheddar?
Wahrscheinlich, weil man das, wie er ursprünglich hieß, doppelt so lange geschrieben hat.
Und das ist nur quasi die Kurzform dessen, was...
Cheddar ist die Stadt Cheddar, Cheddartal.
Und da gibt es, wo es Teller gibt, gibt es auch Berge. Und diese Berge sind so Kalksteinberge.
Und wo es Kalksteine gibt, gibt es... Na?
Keine Ahnung.
Höhlen, weil die dann ausgewaschen werden mit der Zeit. Also hast du dann sehr
viele Höhlen und wo du Höhlen hast, hast du Kühle.
Und das war die Voraussetzung dafür, dass es da diesen Käse geben konnte,
weil du dann halt lange Zeit kühlen müsstest.
So eine Abwesenheit von Kühlschränken und all diesen ganzen anderen technischen
Innovationen. Deswegen gibt es ja auch das Pilz nicht in Berlin.
Deswegen haben wir mit der Berliner Weiße so ein Sommerbier,
für das man halt nicht Eisblöcke aus den Alpen schlagen muss oder in Tschechien
in irgendwelche Höhlen schleppen.
Höhlen.
Das ist halt einfach immer alles auch geografisch definiert.
Und jetzt haben sie dann in einer dieser Höhlen vor ein paar Jahren den Cheddar Man gefunden,
der halt irgendwie, ich weiß nicht mehr wie alt der ist, aber der Cheddar Man
ist 10.000 Jahre alt, genau.
Ist der dann älter oder jünger als Ötzi? Bisschen jünger, ne?
Ich, keine Ahnung, hat sich bei Ötzi nicht gerade irgendwas geändert?
Das Irre war bloß, dass sie dann genetische Untersuchungen gemacht haben und
sie haben tatsächlich in Cheddar,
in dem Dorf, ein Nachfahren von diesem 10.000 Jahre alten Mann gefunden,
wo sie sich relativ sicher waren.
Irre, oder?
So viel zur Evolution und Käse. Man kann da auch ganz toll beim Käse machen,
zugucken und so weiter, habe ich alles gemacht.
Ich habe generell was übrig für so besondere Farben auch, also so schönes,
sattes Orange hat mich schon immer gut angesprochen.
Cheddar kann was, aber muss halt auch aus Cheddar sein und nicht so Cheddar-ähnlich.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, habe ich die Erfahrung gemacht, dass die Cheddars,
die nicht ganz so orange sind, meistens die besseren sind.
Wenn die weniger Farbstoffe reinmachen, dann machen sie meistens mehr Geschmack rein.
Die Farbe alleine ist natürlich jetzt keinerlei...
Jaja, aber es ist also in sehr viel Cheddar ist schon sehr viel künstlicher
Farbstoff drin, also das...
Ja, guter Cheddar, schlechter Cheddar.
Gut, das Käse fangen, das hatten wir glaube ich letztes Mal schon in der Sendung.
Ja.
Wo waren wir stehen geblieben? Ah ja, Sommer.
Urlaubszeit. Ist bei mir Festivalzeit. Ich weiß nicht, was ihr so bisher mit
dem Sommer gemacht habt. Habt ihr nur gearbeitet?
Bisher nur gearbeitet und Wasser aus unserem Keller an der ZRB geschippt.
Da hatten wir einen Wassereinbruch.
Fallrohr geborsten.
Du hast das selber eigenständig geschippt?
Ich hab da mit geschippt. Da waren wir mit 60 Leuten.
Im Vorstand schippst du noch selbst.
Da mussten auch die Herren Frauendirektoren dann mal mit ran.
Mit 60 Leuten haben wir da unten im Archiv gestanden und es war so am Ende so
ein, anderthalb Kilometer, anderthalb Zentimeter vor der untersten Buchreihe.
Wer ein echtes Herz für Bücher hat, der muss dann ran.
Ja, wenn mal Zeit für ein neues Gebäude war.
Tja, wer Zeit für ein neues Gebäude, jetzt wo du es sagst.
Also ich war ja beim Void Camp, da haben wir aber auch schon drüber gesprochen,
aber mehr ist bei mir noch nicht passiert.
Da warst du oder warst du in Fersen?
Fersen ich da war.
Okay, also gibt es nichts Neues zu berichten. Ja, ich habe in der Zwischenzeit
das BlinkLights Projekt nochmal aufgewärmt.
Letztes Jahr haben wir ja fürs Camp diese Polychrom-Installation gemacht und diese,
Kästen, diese diese Panels, die wir gemacht haben, um sie von hinten gegen die
Fenster zu schieben, besitzen eine Eigenstabilität, konnten also eingelagert
werden und auch unabhängig von diesen Glasbausteinfenstern nochmal genutzt werden.
Und das haben wir dann getan auf meinem Lieblingsfestival, den Nation of Gondwana.
Und konnten auch das erste Mal den interaktiven Teil so gestalten,
wie wir das eigentlich auf dem Camp schon vorhatten.
Jetzt tut es mir fast noch ein bisschen mehr weh, dass uns das nicht schon mal
vorher gelungen ist, nachdem ich jetzt gesehen habe, wie das eingeschlagen ist,
weil es sind ja immer die einfachen Sachen, die gut funktionieren.
Und zur Erinnerung, das sind ja so zehn Fenster gewesen, also zehn Panels mit
so einer 8x8 Matrix, die hingen jetzt in der Dunkelheit.
In den Bäumen sozusagen, also man blickte so auf so eine Waldkante und so auf
60 Meter Breite waren dann diese 10.
Panels relativ hoch, so 5, 6 Meter hoch angebracht und 20, 30,
40 Meter davor konnte man dann mit so einem Controller mit 10 Buttons quasi
so eine Wacky Mole Variante spielen.
Und das fand dann tatsächlich Regenzuspruch, es wurde also die ganze Zeit da
rumgedattelt, fast passt schon ein bisschen zu viel, weil dann der Rest des
Contents gar nicht so richtig zum Tragen kam.
Aber ja, das war auf jeden Fall wieder ein schönes Experiment.
Es ist immer gut, wenn man sowas auch so als Außenraumgestaltung beitragen kann,
auch die Gelegenheit hat, mal wieder ein bisschen den Code zu tunen und ein
paar neue Sachen auszuprobieren.
Diesmal haben wir nämlich ausprobiert, das zu tun, was wir ursprünglich mal
vorhatten, aber das ganze Camp nicht getan haben.
Abgesehen von diesem Spiel, das auch noch, nämlich die LEDs,
die wir dort zum Einsatz gebracht haben, sind ja keine RGB-LEDs, sondern RGBW-LEDs.
Das heißt, sie haben noch einen vierten Kanal, den kann man bei der Bestellung
dann in Kaltweiß oder in Warmweiß bestellen und das haben wir in Warmweiß erworben. Natürlich.
Und haben aber wirklich, jetzt bis vor zwei Wochen das noch nie im Betrieb gehabt.
Also wir haben es noch nicht mal gesehen.
Wir wussten noch nicht mal, wie es aussieht. Ob das wirklich was ist.
Und es gab dann so den Durchbruch, weil wir so Text angezeigt haben und der Text war weiß.
Und aus 300.
Meter Entfernung, soweit konnte man da Gott sei Dank gucken,
weil da so eine riesige Wiese davor ist, aus 300 Meter Entfernung oder 400 Meter
waren es sogar, sah man tatsächlich noch, und die Pixel sind ja nur...
20 mal 20 Zentimeter groß, also aus der Nähe groß, aber aus der Ferne natürlich
nicht mehr, sah man trotzdem bei jedem einzelnen Pixel irgendwie noch so eine
blau-rote Überstrahlung.
Also es war wirklich krass, also das Weiß war alles andere als Weiß,
sondern man merkte so richtig, dass das so ein Konglomerat aus Farben war und
das irgendwie sich nicht so richtig mischte, trotz der großen Distanz,
trotz Doppeldampfbremsfolie davor und so weiter.
Und dann wurde noch mal ein bisschen Aufwand getrieben und dann tatsächlich
mal diese W-LED herausgekitzelt und siehe da, es sah aus wie Glühbirne.
Das war einfach hervorragend.
Also kann ich nur empfehlen, wenn ihr mit solchen Lichtinstallationen rumarbeitet,
abgesehen von der absolut notwendigen Farbkalibration, die sich auch diesmal
wieder sehr bewährt hat.
Wenn monochrom, dann am besten auch mit monochromen LEDs.
Wie habt ihr das? Wie macht ihr die Farbkalibration eigentlich?
Mit so einem ganz normalen Spider-Farb-Kalibrationsmessgerät,
was du normalerweise auf deinen Bildschirm draufklebst.
Ah, okay. Und das zeigt dann irgendwas an?
Ja, da läuft ja meistens so eine Software im Browser, die irgendwie Farben durchrotiert.
Und das Ding schmatzt du da halt wie so einen kleinen Saugnapf auf den Bildschirm drauf.
Und die Software sagt so, das hier ist die Farbe. Was siehst du?
Und dann so, ich sehe aber die Farbe.
Ja, okay.
Ja, okay. Ich habe die jetzt mal ein bisschen geändert. Passt das jetzt mehr?
Und das heißt, die Software probiert dann so eine Stunde rum,
die richtige Verteilung von Farben zu finden.
Also umso länger du diese Kalibration laufen lässt, umso ein akkurateres Ergebnis
bekommst du, weil du ja theoretisch 24 Millionen unterschiedliche Kombinationen hast.
Und ihr habt aber selber Software dafür geschrieben?
Nee, wir haben tatsächlich diese Open Source Software genommen.
Wie heißt die denn nochmal gleich?
Macht ihr das dann pro Panel oder reicht es ein Panel, weil die Streuung der
Panel... Die Streuung ist da nicht so groß.
Display-Kall heißt die Software. Display-Kall und...
Display-Kal macht das halt so im Browser und auf dem Bildschirm und der Hack war dann,
dass so eine kleine Software im Hintergrund sich einfach immer die Farbe,
die da in dem Browser gerade angezeigt wird, so geschnappt hat vom Bildschirm
und stattdessen auf die LED gebracht hat, wo das Ding dann tatsächlich drauf klebte.
Und das war also einfach so ein kleiner Hack.
Und ja, damit könnte man das kalibrieren. Wir haben dann allerdings auch in
dieser Situation, wo nicht Glasbausteine davor sind, auch sehen können, dass unsere These,
dass die LEDs, weil sie aus einer Produktion sind, dann doch schon sehr ähnliche
Farbverhalten zeigen sollten,
auch nur sehr eingeschränkt gilt.
Also tatsächlich, wenn man es mal so richtig akkurat haben will,
müsste man eigentlich jede einzelne LED kalibrieren.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen blöd, weil diese LEDs, die du ja in diesen Ketten
bekommst, die sprichst du ja nicht über IDs an.
Und du kannst eine einzelne LED nicht identifizieren.
Du müsstest halt entweder, dass sie an ihrem Farbprofil erkennen,
so eine Art AI, auf welche LED bist du denn und dann habe ich schon mal die
passende Kalibration für dich.
Oder man muss es halt irgendwie anders drehen, dass man halt alle leuchten lässt,
man schaut sich das im Dunklen an,
guckt, wo es starke Abweichungen gibt und dafür nimmt man dann nochmal eine
Kalibration in Kauf und wendet das an.
Also wenn man es perfekt machen will, braucht man für jede einzelne LED eine Farbkalibration.
Aber das würde halt auch bedeuten, wenn du eine Stunde pro LED brauchst,
bei 640 LEDs, ist, dann bist du eine Weile damit beschäftigt.
Das ist dann halt schon mal so ein paar Wochen rumkalibrieren.
Aber eine Stunde ist schon hart, oder?
Eine Stunde ist so ein bisschen...
Also wir haben es eine Stunde lang gemacht. Der muss ja immer die Farbe anzeigen, messen.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie lange das dauert, aber selbst wenn das nur so
eine halbe Sekunde ist, bei 24 Millionen verschiedenen Farben,
kannst du nicht einfach alle durchprobieren.
Sondern du musst halt schon irgendwo so in diesem Range gehen.
Ah, okay, der interpoliert nicht oder wie?
Ja, ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, wie die Software das macht,
aber die versucht sich da halt irgendwie ranzutasten. Und sie sagen halt,
umso länger es läuft, umso besser ist das Ergebnis.
Auf jeden Fall hat das ganz gut funktioniert, aber diese monochromen LEDs,
die waren einfach der Brüller.
Also das war wirklich so ein satisfizierendes Warmweiß, dass man hätte brüllen können vor Freude.
Habe ich auch und ja, das war sozusagen dieser Aspekt,
und die Interaktion war ganz lustig, weil mit so dicken, fetten,
großen Arcade-Buttons drauf zu ballern, wenn irgendwo ein Monster erscheint,
das macht einfach Spaß und da standen halt Leute mit vier,
fünf Leuten gleichzeitig, die dann rumballerten und man musste dann so in Realtime
das Spiel an das Verhalten der Leute anpassen,
weil sie natürlich dann relativ schnell drauf kamen, wenn wir hier zu fünft
sind, Bei 10 Buttons nimmt jeder 2 Buttons und dann kriegen wir das schon irgendwie hin.
Also Monster taucht auf und dann geht das halt immer schneller und es gab einen Highscore.
Irgendwann haben sie dann halt alle nur noch auf den Buttons rumgehauen,
dann haben wir noch eine Tilt-Funktion eingebaut und dann war dann halt auch
das Spiel schwierig. Highscore 298.
Okay.
Ja, ja.
Wenn man jetzt sozusagen auf so Festivals ist, wie ich das gerne mache,
dann kommt ja auch dieses Thema wieder mit dem mobilen Strom.
Wir hatten das Thema in der letzten Sendung. Da gab es ja auch einiges an Feedback
und Interesse an diesem Thema, was ich sehr gut nachvollziehen kann.
Und ich hatte, hab da auch eine neue Episode noch zu erzählen,
die noch nicht ganz abgeschlossen ist Aber vielleicht fangen wir erstmal mit einem Feedback an,
nämlich von Gersh.
Zum Thema Solar slash Victron. Ich bin ein wenig überrascht,
wie knapp ihr Victron dargestellt habt.
Victrons Portfolio besteht im Wesentlichen aus modularen Komponenten für nahezu
jeden praktischen Anwendungsbereich, den man sich in diesem Kontext vorstellen und wünschen kann.
Eigentlich ein Traum eines jeden Informatik- und Technik-Nerds.
Jedes Modul für sich genommen erfüllt eine ganz spezifische Aufgabe und ermöglicht
damit nahezu alle möglichen Konstellationen, die auftreten können.
Ursprünglich aus dem maritimen Bereich kommend sind sie im Off-Grid-Insellösungsbereich
stark vertreten. Nicht ohne Grund.
Bei nahezu jedem Solarnerd wirst du Victron finden.
Ich bin leider sehr spät auf den Trichter gekommen, werde aber bei nächster
Gelegenheit bereits vorhandene Nicht-Victron-Geräte durch eben diese ersetzen,
da sie auch diverse Kleinst-Solarflächen ohne Probleme abbilden können.
Bei diesen Systemen habe ich nicht das Gefühl, dass etwas nicht geht.
Bei den regulären Herstellern war bis vor kurzem ein bezahlbarer Hybrid-Wechselrichter
mit 15 Kilowatt Peak undenkbar.
Bei Victron schon lange kein Thema mehr, wenn auch mehr Geräte und teurer.
Die GX-Geräte sind nicht nur für die Protokollführung gedacht,
sondern das Herz jeder Anlage, die auch nur ansatzweise etwas komplexer ist.
Hierüber werden nahezu sämtliche Einstellungen und Parametrisierungen zum Verhalten
der Gesamtanlage vorgenommen.
Vom Batteriewechsel riecht dann über die Solarregler oder was auch immer und
deren Zusammenspiel in verschiedensten Szenarien.
Alles was irgendwie nach Generator riecht, lässt sich da einbinden, auch Windräder.
Und die weiteren sensorischen Fähigkeiten habt ihr bereits erwähnt.
Bemerkenswert finde ich auch die Nähe zur Community, seien es Plugins oder einfach
mal ein komplettes Image für den Raspi.
Schade, dass Tim hier nicht in seine Community gefragt hat. Ich bin mir sicher,
da hätte es einige gegeben, die hilfreiche Hinweise hätten geben können.
Ich persönlich war etwas verwundert über die 12 Volt Schiene mit den Batterien
in Serie, wären ohne weiteres 24 Volt drin gewesen, aber 48 Volt plus wäre schon
schöner, aber das hat Tim ja auch angemerkt.
Unabhängig davon gerne mehr aus diesem Bereich.
Ja, schöner Kommentar. Ich muss sagen,
was diese Modularität betrifft, so habe ich Victron auch wahrgenommen,
aber ich habe gar nicht so sehr den Vergleich zu dem Produktportfolio anderer Hersteller,
ob es nicht ähnliche Aufteilungen der Produktsystematik dort auch gibt.
Aber das trifft auf jeden Fall zu und umso neuer die Geräte,
umso bedienbarer werden sie auch.
Bei Victron gibt es schon noch das ein oder andere alte Zeug,
was überkommen werden muss. Da komme ich gleich zu.
Vielleicht noch, was er hier erwähnt hat, also GX, diese GX-Geräte,
ich hatte das glaube ich erwähnt, das ist sozusagen die eine Kategorie von Datensammlern.
Und es ist halt tatsächlich mehr als nur ein Datensammler, aber vor allem erstmal das.
Bei meinem Fall ist es noch ein Venus GX, die neuere Version ist der Zerbo GX.
Und es gibt dann noch welche mit eingebauten Bildschirmen, Ekrano GX.
Aber sozusagen diese ganze GX-Kategorie, das sind halt Geräte mit sehr vielen
Interfaces, die eigentlich mit allem verbunden werden können und das dann halt
sammeln und eben optional auch in diese Victron Cloud,
dieses VRM-System, Remote Management System geben kann, wo man halt kostenlos
das alles visualisieren kann, was wirklich, wirklich praktisch und sehr,
sehr übersichtlich ist.
Und ja, die Software dafür ist tatsächlich Open Source.
Also dieses Venus OS liegt auf GitHub und man kann sich das auch einfach auf
einen Raspberry Pi installieren, wenn man denn so möchte.
Das ist sicherlich cool und das hat auch so den Effekt, dass es mittlerweile
eine ganze Reihe von Plugins gibt, die halt so Open Source mäßig dafür entwickelt werden.
Unter anderem sehr populär sind wohl diese GUI-Mods, die dieses HTML-basierte
Visualisierungsinterface erweitern und anpassbar machen.
Das habe ich jetzt selber noch nicht im Einsatz aus verschiedenen Gründen,
ich weiß aber davon und sie entwickeln diese Software auch fleißig weiter,
da wird es demnächst auch einen kompletten UI-Wechsel geben,
dann sieht das auch alles nochmal deutlich moderner aus und funktioniert auch
nochmal ein bisschen hübscher, das ist gerade in Beta.
Aber ich finde es bemerkenswert, dass sie das halt so haben.
Jetzt ist so ein Raspberry Pi nicht unbedingt immer die bessere Wahl,
aber wenn man das halt machen will, dann kann man es halt auch machen.
Deshalb nicht unbedingt die bessere Wahl, weil du nicht wirklich Geld damit sparst.
Denn wenn du dir diesen Zerbo kaufst, was so das aktuelle Gerät ist,
dann kommt das Teil halt für 200 Euro auch schon so mit allen möglichen Bussen.
So, da hast du diesen Victron internen VE-Bus, da hast du Cannbus,
Da hast du irgendwie tausend Tanksensoren, analog, die du anschließen kannst,
digitale Interfaces, also wirklich jeder Pipapo.
Und wenn du dir das dann alles an so ein Raspi über USB oder so dranbammelst,
dann zahlst du mindestens das gleiche, wenn nicht sogar noch deutlich mehr.
Aber es mag halt Anwendungen geben, wo das ist. Was ich noch nicht so ganz rausgefunden
habe oder wo ich noch nicht so viel geschaut habe,
ist, dass du dann halt auch über so Protokolle wie MQTT kommst.
Andere Geräte ja abfragen oder steuern kannst sogar.
Also MQTT heißt MQ Telemetry Transport und das ist so ein leichtgewichtiges
Publish-Subscribe basiertes Protokoll,
wo du halt einfach verschiedenste Devices verbinden kannst, dann halt über IP,
sprich wenn du dann irgendwie so ein Sensornetzwerk hast von Devices,
ist, die eben dieses MQTT sprechen, dann lässt sich das eben damit auch sehr gut kombinieren.
Und damit kann man unter Umständen diese Gesamtsensorik nochmal ein bisschen
attraktiver machen. Und das ist für so ein mobiles Device cool.
Ich habe jetzt irgendwie weiß nicht, ob ich das letzte Mal gesagt habe,
aber irgendwie so Bluetooth- Temperatursensoren im Kühlschrank und im Gefrierfach.
Und habe jetzt so vor den letzten zwei Wochen, wo es so bärig heiß war,
richtig geile, überlagernde Kurven mit so warm war es draußen,
so warm war es im Schrank, so warm war es jetzt im Wohnwagen,
so warm war es im Kühlschrank, so warm war es im Gefrierfach.
Und so viel Strom hat er verbraucht, um die Wärme herzustellen.
Ja, es war in dem Fall nur Gas, aber ja.
Ah, okay.
Auch das hätte man messen können. Also, ist auf jeden Fall ein interessantes
Ökosystem und grundsätzlich funktioniert dieser ganze Victron-Kram ganz gut.
Es sei denn, man übertreibt so ein bisschen mit den Verbesserungsmaßnahmen.
Das würdest du doch nie tun.
Naja, ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr ganz genau, wo wir uns hier das letzte Mal zu
dem Thema gesüngt haben, aber ich hatte mich ja da jetzt etwas tiefer eingelesen
und habe dann auch die letzten Tage, bevor es dann auf den Acker ging,
noch damit verbracht, falsche Verkabelungen zu beheben und vor allem alles schön
mit einem Markierungsgerät zu beschriften und mal so richtig einen Plan zu machen,
wie man das alles hübsch machen kann.
Und dann kommt man ja dann irgendwann so on a roll.
Dann denkst du so, jetzt mach ich noch das, jetzt mach ich noch das und guck
mal, jetzt hab ich ja alle Kabel und alles ordentlich beschriftet und den Fehler
hab ich jetzt behoben und jetzt kann ich auch anfangen mit Verbesserungen und
so. Und dann war ich irgendwie fertig.
Und hat nichts mehr zu tun. Weißt du, so ein Moment, so alle Tasks erledigt.
Warst auf dich selbst zurückgeworfen.
Was?
Sinnlosigkeit deiner Existenz.
Man ist in so einem Aktionismus, man ist auch total pumpt irgendwie und denkt
sich so was, wie, jetzt keine Tasks mehr, aber ich bin noch gerade so voll im
Modus und so weiter und es ist ja auch erst 22 Uhr so und ich fahre ja erst
morgen früh los auf den Acker und so weiter.
Da habe ich nochmal mal so alles durchgeguckt und dann so, ah,
mein Wechselrichter, der hat noch ein Software-Update.
Da könnte man ja noch mal die Firmware aktualisieren.
Mittlere Idee, oder?
Mittlere Idee.
Ich gebe zu, dass es war etwas, wie soll ich sagen, optimistisch und...
Aber ich gebe zu, ich hätte es auch gemacht.
Der letzte rote Button, der da aufleuchtet, den wollte ich doch noch.
Update, Update.
Nur noch den einen.
Ja, jetzt war das leider ein bisschen schwierig mit dem Update,
weil man musste da bestimmte Voraussetzungen erfüllen.
Andere Geräte durften nicht angeschlossen werden. Man kann es auch nicht so
ohne weiteres über das Internet machen.
La la la, auf jeden Fall so auf den letzten Metern dachte ich mir,
ach komm, scheiß drauf, machst du noch. Da ist ja auch ein neues Feature,
das willst du sowieso haben und so.
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Ich habe irgendwie versucht, dieses Update anzustoßen
und ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich es am Schluss dann wirklich gemacht habe.
Meine letzte Erinnerung sagt mir jetzt, habe ich gar nicht, ich habe es nur versucht.
Auf jeden Fall war dann auf einmal, mein Wechselrichter war einfach weg und
hat nicht mehr funktioniert. Lies ich nicht mehr einschalten.
Gar nichts. Keine Reaktion. Schalter umgelegt, keine Reaktion,
nichts. Ich bin wahnsinnig geworden.
Alles ausprobiert. mit Kabel abgezogen, Batterie abgezogen, alles irgendwie
rebooted, resettet, alle anderen Kabel nur mit dem Gerät da,
nur mit dem Gerät daran, nichts.
Gab es auch keine Leuchtdioden, die geleuchtet haben?
Keine Leuchtdioden, die geleuchtet haben. Es war einfach verrückt.
Und ich habe es nicht verstanden. Und ich muss auch zugeben,
um es gleich vorwegzunehmen, ich habe es auch bis jetzt noch nicht,
das Mysterium ist noch nicht komplett entschlüsselt. Aber ich hatte es dann
eilig und dachte mir so, hm, was mache ich denn jetzt? Jetzt ist mein Wechselrichter im Arsch.
Ich habe mir den jetzt wahrscheinlich mit diesem Firmware-Update vergeigt. Das war so mein Gedanke.
Mittlerweile weiß ich, so war es nicht. Bin dann gleich irgendwie bei meinem,
Solar-Dealer meines Vertrauens vorbei und habe mir ein Ersatzgerät geholt und
war schon drauf und dran, das irgendwie einzubauen.
Steht hier noch unverpackt. Du siehst, ich habe das nicht getan.
Unausgepackt.
Ja, ja. Weil ich mich dann festgestellt habe, als ich wieder zurückkehrte zu
meiner Installation und bereit war, wirklich jeden Scheiß zu machen.
Dass sich das Gerät nach einem anderthalb Tag von alleine wieder eingeschaltet hat.
Und das konnte ich sehen, weil ich halt dieses VRM, diese Cloud habe,
wo halt regelmäßig berichtet wird, was das gesamte System macht.
Und einfach so aus dem Nichts, schlups, war es wieder da.
Juhu, ich bin's, deine Mars-Sonde. Mich gibt's noch.
So in etwa. Naja, ich bin total glücklich auf den Acker gefahren,
dort auch schon ein paar Tage wieder ordentlich Strom gemacht und dann gab's
irgendwie wie so ein Strom, wer verbraucht wie viel Ding und dann dachte ich so, ja okay,
hier nochmal ausschalten, nochmal einschalten, so in der Erwartung,
dass alles super ist, aber es war ein großer Fehler.
Wechselrichter ausgeschaltet, wieder eingeschaltet, wieder weg.
Einen Tag gewartet, kam nicht wieder. Wahnsinnig geworden, es war wirklich schlimm. Die Schmerzen.
Und irgendwann bin ich dann drauf gekommen, dass es irgendwo ganz tief verborgen
in irgendeinem GX-Untermenü zu diesem Wechselrichter so einen,
Resette, diesen Bus Button gibt, der dann auch tatsächlich dazu geführt hat,
dass sich das Ding wieder eingeschaltet hat.
Und danach hatte ich weirde Fehlermeldungen, denen ich jetzt so ein bisschen
auf die Spur gehe und meine Vermutung ist, ich habe mir die ganze Scheiße selber eingebrockt,
weil ich irgendwie dieses eine Kabel aus meinem Batteriemanagementsystem rausgezogen
habe und dabei wahrscheinlich diese ganze Pinleiste zerstört habe und ich jetzt
irgendeinen obskuren Wackelkontakt habe.
Naja, also Also nicht viel, was man daraus jetzt lernen kann,
außer Never Change a Running System, kurz bevor du dich drauf verlassen möchtest
und halte dich von Firmware-Updates fern, selbst wenn sie klappen könnten,
wenn du es nicht wirklich brauchst.
Stand natürlich auch überall, hab ich auch überall auf OK gedrückt,
dass ich das zur Kenntnis genommen habe.
Aber ich werde jetzt einfach dieses andere System tauschen und hoffe,
dass mein Problem dann endlich weggeht.
Trotzdem, Victron kann ich empfehlen. Ist toll. Kann man was mit machen.
Ja.
Was auch noch in dem Zusammenhang ganz interessant ist, also man will ja auch
Internet haben, weil sonst kann ja so ein GX-Gerät nicht nach außen kommunizieren.
Und bei der Frage, was will man eigentlich haben, um Internet in so einem Wohnmobil,
Wohnwagen, was auch immer, um wirklich gut Internet zu haben, was nimmt man da?
Lass mich raten, nicht auf jedem Acker liegt Glas.
Naja, wir wissen ja, wie es ist. Also man will natürlich auf jeden Fall einen
korrekten Router haben, der im Idealfall mindestens LTE bzw.
Heute natürlich 5G spricht.
Ja. Und sowas habe ich auch. War allerdings bis vor kurzem noch sehr unzufrieden damit,
weil mir bestimmte Dinge nicht gelangen und ich bei dem User-Interface wahnsinnig
geworden bin und es furchtbar fand und grauenhaft und ganz, ganz,
ganz schlimm und es ist eigentlich auch immer noch so.
Aber ich habe dann nach zwei Jahren mal wieder ein Software-Update gemacht.
Firmware kann auch gut sein.
Und siehe da, sie haben es tatsächlich verbessert.
Wovon rede ich? Ich rede von einem Teltonica RUT-Router.
Konkret habe ich derzeit den Root X11 in meinem Mobil.
Das ist jetzt schon ein paar jährchen her dass dieses produkt auf den markt gekommen ist x11.
Macht komische bilder im kopf.
Das mag sein ja das ist sozusagen die lte variante was jetzt allerdings auf
den markt gekommen ist ist der roth x50.
Und der Root X50 ist quasi dieselbe Geschichte, nur eben mit 5G.
Und was ist gut an diesen Devices?
Also erstmal sie kommen halt in so einem industriellen Alu-Gehäuse daher,
lassen sich halt gut verbauen.
Alle Antennen sind nicht intern, sondern werden halt extern dran geschraubt.
Das gilt also für vier, also beim RUT50 sind es jetzt vier Mobilfunkantennen,
zwei WLAN-Antennen und außerdem gibt es noch, glaube ich, für Bluetooth und
für GPS einen Anschluss.
Und es gibt dazu auch noch die passende externe Antenne, die man gleich oben aufs Dach packen kann.
So eine Kombo-Antenne, wo man sozusagen diesen ganzen Kabbelsalat nach oben,
nach außen führt und dann dort einmal in einer einzigen Maschine quasi alle
Antennen beisammen hat.
Und das ist dann halt einfach so ein schwarzer Blob, den man sich oben auf den
Wagen drauf schraubt, wo halt die ganzen Antennenkabel reingehen.
Und dann hat man quasi mit einer Installation 5G, WLAN auch nach draußen und so.
Also, warum ich mittlerweile doch zufrieden bin mit diesem Teil,
was mich am Anfang so frustriert hat, ist, weil ich jetzt das Gefühl habe,
es funktioniert jetzt das, was ich vorher nicht zum Laufen bekommen habe.
Man kann nämlich da nette Sachen mitmachen. Also in meinem Fall ist es so,
ich habe da LTE drin, kann man jetzt also mit 5G bei dem Route 50 weiterdenken,
also ich habe Mobilfunk drin,
ich habe an dem Warnport von dem Teil optional mein Starlink dran,
wenn das Starlink ausgeschaltet ist, ist da nichts an dem Port und ich kann
das so konfigurieren, dass ich dann eine Priorität vergebe, was er denn benutzt.
Das heißt, Mobilfunk ist für mich mein Fallback. Wenn Starlink an ist,
dann nimmt das Starlink.
Und dann gibt es ja auch noch so diese Momente, wo man auf irgendeiner Veranstaltung
ist und da gibt es dann so ein Konferenz-WLAN.
Und das Konferenz-WLAN mag jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt das bessere Netz
sein, aber das ist zumindest das Netz, wo auch alle anderen Kinder drin spielen.
Und man möchte halt gerne auf irgendwelche lokalen Server, Dienste,
sonst irgendwelche Verheißungen zugreifen.
Sitzt aber jetzt irgendwo draußen ein bisschen weiter weg und möchte ganz gerne
an diesem Netz nippen. Aber es ist aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht zumutbar,
sich das per E-Dernet heranzuführen.
Und also möchte man gerne dem WLAN joinen, aber trotzdem möchte man immer noch
sein eigenes Mobil-WLAN behalten, wo ja vielleicht diverse Komponenten eingeloggt
sind und dann hat man das sozusagen auch lokal. Und genau das geht damit.
Das heißt, man kann einen WiFi-Client-Eintrag machen, den man dann auch in dieser
Prioritätenliste einsortieren kann. Und wenn dann dieses WLAN da ist,
joint er halt diesen WLAN als Client und nimmt das quasi als Internetquelle.
Und ist das aber weg, dann kommt wieder die ganze andere Kaskade.
Also so eine Späße kann man damit machen und noch einiges mehr.
Und wo ich dann so richtig im Kreis gesprungen bin, ist, als ich gesehen habe,
dass es dafür auch ein Tailscale-Plugin gibt.
Das heißt, sie haben auch eine größere Kategorie von so modularen Plugins,
die man dann direkt im User-Interface installieren kann und dann habe ich einfach
Tailscale noch aktiviert und dann kann ich auch über Tailscale,
das hatten wir ja hier schon mal, ist immer noch ein tolles Produkt,
auch auf diesen Router zugreifen, ohne irgendwelche DNS,
dünnen DNS, sonst wie Sperenzien machen zu müssen oder dieses Teltonica Cloud-System
zu benutzen, was anders als das von Victron kostenpflichtig ist.
Ja, also kann ich sehr empfehlen. Der Dirk hat das jetzt gerade auch getestet
mit dem 5G, das funktioniert alles wohl ganz gut.
Von daher, ich kenne jetzt gar nicht so viele andere Produkte und es ist auch
nicht so sehr viel teurer.
Es liegt alles so im 400-500 Euro Range, aber das kosten auch die Fritz 5G Boxen
und die sind beileibe nicht so versatil.
Ja, Fritz die wurden jetzt verkauft, ne?
Ja hab ich auch gehört an.
So eine,
Heuschrecke wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ich weiß es nicht genau um ehrlich zu sein, was da wer AVM gekauft hat,
aber es ist ja immer so, wenn sowas verkauft wird dann ist meistens schlimm,
Ja.
Naja, gut.
Kein Doom und Gloom.
Noch Fragen zum Internet?
Achso, mein Starlink habe ich übrigens auch mittlerweile. Da kann ich auch mal
ein Produkt benennen, auch wenn ich da noch ein kleines Problem habe.
Aber das Gute ist, bei Starlink tut sich ja was. Also es gibt ja jetzt Dishy3.
Dishy3.
Also Dishy ist ja der der Kosename für die Starlink-Antenne.
Also wenn du nach Starlink, Dishy, also Dishy ist sozusagen der korrekte Suchbegriff
für die Starlink-Antenne.
Die heißt aber bei Starlink nicht so, oder?
Nein, aber alle sagen Dishy.
Dishy.
Dishy. Weil die erste ja auch noch Dishy war, aber mittlerweile sind sie ja
Rectangular, aber das nennt sich jetzt keiner Reki. Ski.
Und deswegen ist es Dishy und man sagt Dishy 1 für die Runde,
Dishy 2 für die rechteckige mit Motor und jetzt gibt es Dishy 3.
Wo sie sich diesen Ausrichtungsmotor gespart haben.
Offensichtlich haben sie mittlerweile genug Vertrauen in ihre eigene Antenne
und wollen natürlich auch die Kosten senken.
Und Dishy 3 sieht so ähnlich aus wie Dishy 2, hat aber eben nicht diesen mittleren
Fuß mit dem Motor, wo sich das Ding selber in Position bringen kann,
sondern hat einfach nur so einen kleinen ausklappbaren Standfuß.
Und wenn du DISHI 3 in Betrieb nimmst und es steht nicht in die richtige Richtung,
dann sagt dir der einfach, dreh es mal in die richtige Richtung.
Und dann kannst du auf der App quasi in Echtzeit sehen, wie weit du es noch
drehen musst und dann stellst du es da hin.
Weil an diesem Winkel ändert sich dann auch nichts mehr.
Denn dieser Winkel, in dem sich diese Antenne dreht, also die Richtung,
wo sie hin zeigt, die hat einfach was mit deiner Geoposition und wo die Satelliten langfliegen zu tun.
Und ging ja nicht 20 Minuten später in eine andere Richtung oder so.
Von daher macht das auch Sinn.
Es ist jetzt auch eine Mini-Version, Mini-Starlink angekündigt worden,
die noch kleiner ist, die so ein bisschen rucksackfreundlicher ist.
Also das ist dann so für Satelliten-Internet-to-go.
Sicherlich nicht ganz uninteressant für Leute, die jetzt wirklich in der Wüste sind.
Also so richtig fernab jeder Zivilisation oder Brandenburg.
Ja, also da macht das dann halt schon Sinn so, da kannst du dann halt einen
Notruf absetzen, sonst musst du dein iPhone mit dem deutschen Gruß in den Himmel
halten und hoffen, dass es zu irgendeinem Satelliten dann eine SMS abgeschickt bekommt,
ja deutscher Gruß übrigens ist man hat das Handy in der Hand zeigt nach oben
und dreht sich um 360 Grad um irgendwie noch Netz zu bekommen nur dass wir uns
da nicht missverstehen Wünscht.
Sich ein Daten-Elch herbei.
Ja, genau.
Es gibt jetzt mittlerweile auf Amazonien für Digi2 gibt es jetzt fertige Appliances,
mit denen man dann halt das Teil auch über 12 Volt betreiben kann.
Das funktioniert soweit auch, das ist so ein PoE-Injektor. Ich hatte nur jetzt
gerade auf dieser letzten Veranstaltung enormen Ärger damit,
weil es irgendwie den Eindruck macht, dass sich gerade Starlink anders verhält,
wenn du da direkt rangehst, weil eigentlich ist ja die Schüssel selber schon ein Router.
Also das Ding spuckt die ACP raus, die Schüssel.
Und diesen WLAN-Router, den sie noch mit dazu liefern, dieses klobige weiße Teil,
was auch quasi PoE-Quelle ist, Also das schließt dann 230 Volt an und das macht
dann daraus Power over Ethernet, um dieses Starlink mit Strom zu versorgen.
Aber das ist dann quasi so Doppelmoppel.
Also du brauchst nicht wirklich einen Router, weil die Schüssel selber ist schon ein Router.
Nur irgendwie gibt es da gerade Trouble also wir hatten da irgendwie gerade
mega Probleme die wir dann nur noch dadurch lösen konnten,
dass wir diesen alten Router wieder genommen haben was ein bisschen absurd ist,
weil es gibt schon seit einiger Zeit viele Leute die gesagt haben,
ja nee, brauchst du alles nicht du musst nur so den Injektor mit der richtigen,
Pinbelegung dazwischen bauen und dann funktioniert das alles schon da bin ich
jetzt gerade noch so ein bisschen auf der Suche was da,
funktioniert oder nicht funktioniert oder warum das nicht funktioniert,
da kann ich hoffentlich in der nächsten Sendung schon mehr dazu sagen,
aber es gibt so fertige Kits auf Amazon,
wo man halt so diese ganze 48 Volt Versorgung aus 12 Volt und dann eben das
Umpolen und das Umsetzen auf diesen Starlink-Stecker quasi so in einem Produkt hat.
So viel zu dem Thema.
Wollt ihr jetzt noch mal ein Thema machen? Danach komme ich mit meinem Scheiß-Thema.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Also vielleicht ganz kurz.
Es ging in der Gaming-PC-Welt gerade ganz steil durch, dass die Intel-Prozessoren der 13. und 14.
Generation massiv Probleme haben. Die kacken also in Data-Centern ab,
die kacken bei den Leuten zu Hause ab.
Es gibt Spieleentwickler, die nach ein bisschen hin und her in ihren Statistiken
sehen, wie ihre Spiele also bei Intel-Usern deutlich häufiger abstürzen als bei AMD-Usern.
Und ich glaube gestern oder so hat Intel dann tatsächlich mal ein Press-Release dazu gemacht,
indem sie davon sprechen, dass ihre Prozessoren von den Spannungsgeneratoren
die falsche Spannung verlangt.
Und eigentlich mit zu viel Spannung fahren und deshalb halt auf irgendwann kaputt gehen.
Das Problem ist, wenn der Prozessor einmal instabil geworden ist,
dann hilft nichts mehr. Dann muss der getauscht werden.
Sie haben versprochen, dass es für die Motherboards ein Firmware-Update geben wird Mitte August,
wo sie dann dieses mit den falschen Spannungen beheben wollen.
Gleichzeitig kam aber noch das Gerücht auf und sie haben es auch so halb bestätigt
in irgendeinem tief in einem Reddit-Thread drin, dass sie also auch Probleme
mit Oxidation von Durchkontaktierungen von Kupfern und so weiter und so weiter haben.
Oxidation, auch Explosion und Feuer genannt.
Nee, es ist mehr Rost.
Also schon die langsame Variante, aber es ist halt so, dass das mit der Oxidation betrifft wohl nur 13.
Generation, zumindest haben sie es nur für die 13. Generation zugegeben.
Ja. Muss man jetzt mal sagen. Und sie sprechen auch davon, dass es wirklich nur wenige sind.
Keine Ahnung. Also die ganze Situation ist extrem unklar.
Und das liegt, glaube ich, auch daran, dass Intel versucht, diesen Geist noch so lange wie möglich,
möglichst halbwegs in der Flasche zu halten, um überhaupt genug Prozessoren
zu haben, die sie den Leuten tauschen können, die ein Problem damit haben.
Was ist denn die aktuelle Generation?
14.
Ach so. Also die aktuelle und die vorletzte.
Genau und die 12er Generation ist wohl okay, da ist nichts bekannt.
Das Ding ist, viel machen kann man da jetzt erstmal nicht.
Allerdings sollte man halt gucken, wann diese Firmware-Update mit dem neuen Microcode kommt,
wenn man tatsächlich solche Chips irgendwo im Betrieb hat und dann auf jeden
Fall ein Firmware-Update oder BIOS-Update von dem Motherboard machen.
Also das wird noch interessant, was da noch so passiert.
Ich wollte es nur mal gesagt haben,
vielleicht haben das ja manche Leute überhaupt gar nicht mitbekommen.
Also wenn, wie gesagt, wenn die Rechner instabil sind und es ist völlig unklar,
was es ist, könnte es das sein, wenn man so einen Prozessor hat.
Dann hilft aber auch das Update nicht mehr.
Vielleicht doch ein AI-PC kaufen?
Du, keine Ahnung. Also es ist wohl so, dass das AMD jetzt gerade sehr gefragt
ist, besonders im Serverbereich,
weil die aktuelle Generation jetzt kein Problem hat.
Lustigerweise hat die nächste Generation, die quasi in den Startlöchern steht,
da hat AMD sämtliche Review-Samples wieder einkassiert oder versucht,
die wieder zurückzukriegen, weil sie gesagt haben,
sie wollen lieber nochmal mit der QA nochmal richtig drüber gucken.
Sie wollen sich wohl nicht die Blöße geben, dass bei irgendeinem der Reviewer
jetzt das Teil nicht die Leistung bringt, die sie versprochen haben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich das richtig verstanden habe, aber es klingt ja für mich
so ein bisschen, als wäre das eher ein Designfehler gewesen bei Intel, als ein Prozessfehler.
Das ist, glaube ich, alles noch ein bisschen unklar. Also...
Vielleicht ist es ein Designfehler, vielleicht ist es ein Prozessfehler.
Es ist wohl auch so, dass es Chargen gibt, die sind völlig in Ordnung.
Vielleicht gibt es eine Produktionsstraße betroffen, eine nicht.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht fliegt Intel momentan auch einfach zu nah an der Sonne,
weil sie einfach gegen die derzeitigen AMD-Prozessoren nicht so richtig was können,
außer die Dinger halt irgendwie quasi so hochtakten, wie sie sie irgendwie kriegen.
Und wenn du hochtaktest, musst du natürlich auch ordentlich Strom drauf geben
und dann musst du auch ordentlich kühlen.
Also es ist völlig unklar. Vielleicht ist es auch das Memory Interface, man weiß es nicht.
Also es wird gemunkelt, dass diese Microcode Update möglicherweise dazu führt,
dass man hinterher nur noch mit eingeschränkter Speichergeschwindigkeit die
Prozessoren fahren kann.
Das hieße natürlich, dass man insgesamt weniger Leistung aus dem Ding rauskriegt,
aber das ist alles noch unklar.
Also ich denke, in zwei Monaten oder so weiß man da mehr.
Momentan halten sie sich sehr bedeckt und ich kann das gut verstehen,
die haben einfach zu viel davon verkauft und wenn jetzt die Leute massenhaft
anfangen würden, die Dinger zu tauschen, hätten sie einfach nicht die Chips
auf Lager, um den Leuten neue zu geben.
Also das ist irgendwie und dementsprechend, ja.
Das ist ja für Intel echt der totale Super-GAU.
Ja, klar ist nicht, ob Laptops betroffen sind oder nicht.
Es gibt Leute, die sagen ja, es gibt Leute, die sagen eher nicht.
Also das ist noch unklar zu dem jetzigen Zeitpunkt.
Ich versuche mich gerade zu erinnern,
ob ich so eine Schlagzeile quasi eigentlich schon mal gelesen habe.
Also fast unabhängig, egal ob jetzt von Intel oder AMD oder Nvidia.
In zwei, drei Jahren hatten einige AMD-Chips das Problem, dass die irgendwie
quasi richtig in Rauch aufgegangen sind und dann auch den Sockel beschädigt haben und so weiter.
Das heißt, wenn die durchgegangen sind, dann hast du auch gleich ein neues Mainboard gebraucht.
Ansonsten nee, es ist momentan ist die, wie gesagt, ist alles noch ein bisschen
unklar Klar ist nur, dass sie jetzt dieses Firmware-Update dieses BIOS-Update
versprochen haben und klar ist auch,
wenn man ein entsprechendes Board mit einem entsprechenden Prozessor hat sollte
man dieses Update auch tatsächlich machen,
weil man weiß nie, wie lange hält der Prozessor durch, bis er dann durchbrennt Also es ist wohl so,
dass wenn du einen Prozessor dauerhaft mit zu viel Spannung fährst,
dann wandern da irgendwie nicht nur Elektronen, sondern halt auch Atome rum
und dann geht die Leitfähigkeit der Leiter runter und so.
Keine Ahnung, ich bin kein Chemiker, kein Festkörperphysiker,
hab das nur so am Rande mitbekommen.
Aber klar ist...
Und wenn man es sich leisten kann, vielleicht die Geräte überhaupt erstmal außer
Betrieb zu nehmen, man weiß es nicht, könnte auch helfen.
Aber ja, Auge drauf und Update machen.
Wenn man Intel hat.
Wenn man Intel hat, das betrifft wirklich nur Intel dritte, 13. und 14. Generation.
Leute mit AMD-Prozessoren oder mit Apple Silicon sind da eher nicht von betroffen.
Aber das kann Apple genauso passieren, je nachdem was es ist und wer da was
verbockt hat. Das ist halt wie gesagt alles noch ein bisschen unklar.
Mit meinem alten MacBook Air ist auch und meinem Mac Pro Also es ist wohl so
Die letzten Intel-Maschinen hier aus der Meta-Ebene verschwunden Also.
Es ist wohl so, dass Prozessoren insgesamt, neuere Prozessoren halt auch eine
begrenzte Lebenszeit haben Also wenn du die wirklich,
ordentlich fährst, dann kann das halt sein, dass nach 10 Jahren der Chip durch
ist wegen diesem Material Wanderung und hast sie nicht gesehen,
Also, weiß ich nicht.
Aber dass das jetzt so schnell geht und vor allen Dingen die 14.
Generation gibt es ja auch erst seit einem Jahr oder so und dass die schon wieder
Probleme kriegen, das ist, ja, die haben da irgendwie was Größeres verbockt.
Ich selber glaube, dass dieses Update von dem Motherboard, von der Firmware
auch nur so ein Patch ist, der wahrscheinlich versucht,
die Degradation ein bisschen aufzuhalten, damit sie noch Zeit um den Leuten
dann tatsächlich echte funktionierende Chips zu geben, aber das ist nur so meine
Privattheorie an der Stelle.
Also Intel entwickelt sich so ein bisschen zum Boeing der Prozessorindustrie,
habe ich so den Eindruck.
Also das ist schon sehr hart ausgedrückt, aber sie sind glaube ich nicht gewöhnt,
nicht Nummer eins zu sein und haben Probleme damit,
jetzt irgendwie auch einfach mal die Führung abzugeben und ein guter Verfolger zu sein.
Ja.
Also ich glaube, das ist so ein Teil des Problems da dran, dass sie sich einfach
mal eingestehen müssen, okay, jetzt ist vielleicht eine Zeit lang jemand anders besser als sie.
Da ist ja nicht nur jemand anders besser, sondern es ist ja nahezu fast alle
ziehen ja jetzt an ihnen vorbei.
Apple ist an ihnen vorbeigezogen, was die Effizienz betrifft und die daraus
resultierende Performance.
ProVata kann Intel überhaupt nicht mithalten.
Dann AMD ist davon gezogen, was Reliability betrifft. Qualcomm ist davon gezogen.
Auch Performance, je nachdem, was man für eine Anwendung hat. Ja.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich noch mehr. Es zählt einfach mal nur so auf.
Jeder hat da auf jeden Fall was abgeliefert.
Und auch Effektivität. Deswegen sage ich ja, sie fliegen ein bisschen nah an
der Sonne, weil du kannst so ein 13., 14.
Generation Topmodell von den Prozessoren kannst du ohne Wasserkühlung nicht
betreiben, weil die einfach so viel Strom verbrauchen.
Während du das mit einem AMD näher unterschmerzt, aber du kriegst es hin.
Also die verbrauchen einfach weniger Strom.
Das ist die Verbrennungstechnologie des Prozessors.
Und ich glaube, da muss Intel halt einfach auch die Backen zusammenkneifen und
einfach mal sagen, okay, wir sind jetzt eine Weile Zweiter, aber wir kommen
wieder auf den ersten Blick.
Zweiter, also Nvidia ist auf und davon mit ihren GPUs und NPUs sozusagen.
Also da hat Intel sozusagen gar nichts zu melden. Qualcomm war schon immer bei
Mobile Chips und so weiter vorne.
Das GSM, das LTE-Business haben sie an Apple verkauft.
Apple ist es bisher auch noch nicht gelungen, daraus ein Produkt auf die Beine zu stellen.
Ob das jetzt an dem Zuschauer von der Intel-Gruppe lag oder ob das sozusagen
jetzt nur Apple spart sich das für ganz zum Schluss auf, aber da haben sie irgendwie
keinen Durchbruch gehabt. Jetzt haben sie Zuverlässigkeitsprobleme.
Apple ist in Effizienz vorne, AMD, was du schon sagtest.
Also vier, fünf große Unternehmen sind besser, in den FABs ist TSMC sowieso
far and beyond, also ihr ganzes Modell mit wir machen alles selbst,
wir designen den Prozessor, wir designen den Code, wir machen das ganze FABing
selber, wir sind einfach die Geilsten, funktioniert auch nicht mehr so richtig.
Also ich habe so ein bisschen...
Also der Fairness halber muss man sagen, dass Qualcomm mit dem Snapdragon nicht
so ein großes Ding gelandet hat, wie sie es gerne darstellen.
Nö, ist richtig, aber...
Gut, und dass Windows auf ARM immer noch nicht richtig performt.
Ist nochmal ein anderes Thema. Immerhin tun sie da was. Intel hat ja gar nichts.
Also sie machen ja überhaupt nichts mit ARM.
Ja, aber das ist glaube ich auch so ein politisches Ding, wo,
wie gesagt, auch da sie halt sich einfach mal eingestehen müssen,
dass andere Väter haben auch schöne Töchter und dass, wenn Intel weiterkommen will,
so ein Not-Invented-Here-Syndrom ihnen halt auch nichts bringt.
Also sie müssten eigentlich auch bei ARM wieder einsteigen und sagen, okay,
ARM entwickelt sich zum neuen Architekturstandard, was CPUs anbelangt.
Ist es schon.
Kann man so oder so diskutieren? Ja, klar. In allem, was man mit Batterie mit
sich rumträgt, ist ARM der absolute King. Das ist klar.
Im Data Center gibt es auch viel ARM.
Ob da der Krieg schon vorbei ist, keine Ahnung. Kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Aber auf jeden Fall geht ARM erstmal nicht mehr weg und ist auch glaube ich, wie gesagt,
Intel müsste einfach zugeben, okay, das mit dem ARM haben wir unterschätzt,
das ist dicker gekommen, als wir dachten, wir müssten da einsteigen.
Und jetzt rennt der Geldsinger halt rum und versucht irgendwie Leute zu finden,
die in der Intel-Fab fertigen, weil sie die Auslastung nicht mehr hinkriegen,
weil sie selber gar nicht genug verkaufen für das, was sie da machen.
Also ich meine, Intel versucht es jetzt mit Grafikkarten einigermaßen gut sogar,
aber ich glaube, sie haben völlig unterschätzt, wie schwierig es ist,
einen guten Treiber für diese Dinge herzustellen.
Also inzwischen laufen 95% der Games, aber diesen Nimbus, naja,
Intel-Grafikkarte, funktioniert das denn alles so, den sind sie noch nicht wirklich los.
Also das dauert glaube ich noch eine Generation, aber da hat sich auch AMD ganz
fürchterlich abgearbeitet, bis sie jetzt an dem Punkt sind, wo man sagen kann,
ja, kannst du eine AMD-Grafikkarte nehmen, ist kein Thema, muss nicht Nvidia sein.
Tja, ja.
Ja, so viel zum Thema Intel.
Wie emuliert das Boeing?
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Sie tun mir so ein bisschen leid, weil es ist alles so unnütz.
Es müsste alles einfach nicht sein.
Alright. Alright. Ralf, wollen wir mal über die Subscribe reden?
Haben wir ja letztes Mal schon gemacht haben.
Wir schon gemacht.
Und da habe ich gesagt, jetzt gibt es auch bald Tickets und.
Jetzt gibt es Tickets.
Kaufen, kaufen, kaufen allerdings habe ich ein paar Wochen gebraucht dafür es
wollte eigentlich schneller gehen, aber ich war abgelenkt ihr habt ja die Storys
gehört, ich musste mich um meinen Wechselrichter kümmern,
aber nun ist es also soweit wenn ihr also teilnehmen möchtet wie gesagt,
das richtet sich vor allem, aber nicht nur an Podcaster und Zopferentwickler
die irgendwie im Podcasting-Bereich unterwegs sind Oder wer auch sonst noch
meint, dort interessante Beiträge leisten zu können, das können auch Metathemen sein.
Wir hatten schon immer sehr schöne Metadiskussionen über Diskurs, Kultur und all sowas.
Narrative versus Diskurs.
Ja genau. Ich habe wahrscheinlich deine Kino diesmal.
Ich habe den Chart jetzt reingeworfen, hatten wir ja vorhin.
Wann wird Narrativ und Diskurs bei Google Trends?
2012 hatte ich es predicted, das war zu optimistisch, aber 2018 war es dann
sehr wuchtig und nachhaltig.
Wann hattest du es nochmal predicted?
Das war 2010 oder 2011. Also in einem Jahr war glaube ich so die Prediction ungefähr.
Achso, du hast gesagt in einem Jahr und es waren dann?
Es waren dann irgendwie acht.
Manche Dinge dauern halt länger. Viele Dinge dauern halt länger.
Aber es ist passiert.
Ja, aber das ist glaube ich so ein Ding. Wir denken immer, das müsste alles
viel, viel, viel früher kommen, weil ist ja klar, ist ja logisch.
Und genauso ist es auch mit den Tickets. Ja, klar müsste das alles viel schneller
kommen, aber es dauert dann immer so ein bisschen. Also ich habe jetzt diesen
Shop online und ihr könnt jetzt sozusagen da Tickets kaufen.
Solltet ihr auch bitte tun, weil sonst kann die Veranstaltung nicht stattfinden.
Das wäre ja jetzt nicht so schön, aber so weit sind wir noch lange nicht.
Und ja, ich sorge jetzt mal gleich dafür, dass hier der Shop auch gleich in die Show Notes kommt.
Subscribe.de ist sowieso die Seite, wo dann die ganzen Informationen stehen
und den Shop habe ich natürlich,
wie sollte es auch anders sein, wieder bei Pritix eingerichtet,
weil Pritix bestes Ticketkaufsystem der Welt.
Auch in Bibliotheken sehr weit verbreitet übrigens. Tatsächlich mittlerweile?
Ja, in der Stabi haben wir es eingeführt, jetzt in der ZDB hatten wir es.
Aus Gründen muss es da jetzt wahrscheinlich gegen was anderes weichen,
aber an deutschen Bibliotheken hat das ein gutes Standing.
Ja, ist einfach super anpassbar. Mittlerweile muss man sich schon ein bisschen
mit dem System beschäftigen,
um nicht durcheinander zu kommen mit all diesen ganzen Korrelationen,
weil Ticket kaufen, wer hätte es gedacht, kann ein komplexer Vorgang sein.
So Kontingente und was zieht sich jetzt wovon ab und was hältst du mit irgendeinem
Voucher frei und so weiter.
Es gibt auch noch tausend Plugins. Wir hatten ja den Rami hier irgendwann mal
auch in der Freakshow, ist schon eine Weile her.
Da hat er ja berichtet von...
Der Reise, die er da mit diesem Projekt angegangen ist, nebenbei,
schlage ich kurz nach, das war Freakshow 254 vom 10.12.2020,
also knapp vier Jahre her,
Chatroulette Business Edition, ganz toller Titel.
Ich sehe gerade auf der eigentlichen Subscribe11 Seite haben wir die Tickets
noch gar nicht verfügbar, das baue ich hinterher nochmal.
Doch, meinte ich eingebaut zu haben, aber das müssen wir in der Tat nochmal checken. Genau.
Sonst ist nicht sehr viel nachzutragen. Zu dem, was wir letztes Mal gesagt haben,
ist halt eine Veranstaltung, die toll ist.
Und ich würde mir wünschen, dass ihr auch alle kommt.
Genau. Lange ist es her und es wird sofort sein wie früher. Ich bin da ganz
zuversichtlich. Das ist glaube ich ein Format, was einfach immer funktioniert.
Womit wir in gewisser Hinsicht auch bei WordPress-Themes angekommen sind,
weil ein solches hast du ja auch für diese Subscribeseite mal eingesetzt und
das ist ja so dieser moderne Kram mit so Kästchen und Dinge bewegen sich und so.
Ich muss zugeben, da bin ich ganz oldschool.
Mir ist irgendwie so eine einfache HTML-Seite mit Überschriften und so weiter
und ohne irgendein JavaScript-Schischi und Rollover hier und hast nicht gesehen
und einblenden beim Scrollen und so.
Mich macht das wahnsinnig. Und ehrlich gesagt, im Backend ist es ja noch schlimmer,
wenn man dann überall diese ganzen kleinen Kästchen hat und nicht einfach mal,
zack, Edit Source Code, zack, bumm, rein, Text ändern, save, fertig.
Insofern musst du das mal weiter pflegen die nächsten Tage, weil ich kriege
da jedes Mal ein bisschen Hirnschmadder.
Was ich allerdings, weswegen ich dieses Thema aufbringe, was ich allerdings
gerne mal hätte, ist, also ich benutze ja, Wordpress-Freunde aufgepasst,
Allen anderen wird das jetzt wahrscheinlich wenig sagen, aber bei WordPress
heißen ja immer diese ganzen Default Themes, heißen ja immer so wie das Jahr ausgeschrieben.
Und ich verwende tatsächlich auf der Meta-Ebene aus Gründen,
seit, ich muss nur mal kurz gucken, welches das Jahr genau war, welches ich verwende.
Ich verwende glaube ich 2011 oder 2012.
Tja, Tim wird alt.
Du hörst noch gleich.
2011.
Solange es nicht 1990 ist.
Aber da gab es natürlich kein WordPress.
Jetzt natürlich die berechtigte Frage, Tim, 2011, dieses Team ist 13 Jahre alt,
was erlaube Meta-Ebene?
Und die Antwort ist einfach, diese ganzen 2012, 14, 15, 2020,
hast du nicht gesehen, Teams, sind alle ganz anders.
Also ihr Default-Team ist jedes Jahr komplett anders.
Was ja einen gewissen Sinn hat, finde ich.
Dass du eben einfach Auswahl hast.
Also die alten Themes werden ja noch weiter gepflegt, was Security-Patches angeht und sowas.
Du hast dann halt bei WordPress die Möglichkeit zwischen sehr unterschiedlichen
Blog-Ansätzen, am Ende des Tages soll es immer noch ein Blog sein,
sehr unterschiedliche Blog-Kommunikations-Paradigmen dir auszusuchen.
I'm all for it.
Bisschen moderner, geht vielleicht auch. So, ich meine, bei diesem 2011 hat
es, glaube ich, sechs oder sieben oder acht Jahre gedauert, bis das dann mal
auf dem Mobiltelefon halbwegs ordentlich gerendert hat.
Ja, und gerade so dieses Anpassen an Größen von Bildschirmen und so,
da kann man ja schon einiges machen.
Aber, keins dieser neuen Themes,
bis heute, ich habe sie nicht wirklich alle jetzt wirklich bis zum Rest durchgetestet
und sehe es mir nach, vielleicht liege ich auch auch komplett falsch,
aber meiner Meinung nach all diese ganzen neuen Themes können aber eins nicht.
Du kannst nicht einfach mal einen Blog machen, ganz normal, also du kannst ihn
nicht ganz einfach benutzen, wo einfach rechts immer ein Sidebar ist.
Geht nicht. Und das ist für mich so ein bisschen der Inbegriff von Bloggen.
Also so dieses Predictability eines Webseitendesigns.
Also Blogs Das fand ich...
Immer schon toll, weil sie auf der einen Seite im Backend für die Benutzer einfach zu pflegen waren.
Sie waren im Konsum mit RSS, sehr einfach.
Aber sie hatten auch so einen gewissen optischen Appeal. Und mittlerweile muss
alles so fancy schmancy sein.
Und ehrlich gesagt, ich sehe den Vorteil nicht. Wo ich so richtig ins Kotzen
komme, was Apple ja mittlerweile leider auch macht.
So dieses, du scrollst und erst beim Scrollen kommt da der ganze Content reingefahren.
Und dann schiebt sich links nochmal so ein Elefant rein. und dann löst sich
alles auf und es ist quirlig und ich werde wahnsinnig.
Also wo sind die einfachen Webseiten?
Ja, das ist schlimm. Vor allen Dingen ist es dann immer so hakelig und dann
willst du zurückscrollen und dann rollt sich das.
Muss der Elefant wieder zurück.
Ja, aber genau so fühlt es sich an. Das ist schlimm.
Also, bevor das jetzt hier Old Man Yelling at Clouds noch schlimmer wird.
In dem Fall stimmt es wirklich. Der alte Mann, ich schreie die Wolke an und sage, geht's noch?
Also, mal ein bisschen so mein Blick auf dieses Thema.
Also ich mache jetzt in den letzten Jahren auch nicht mehr so viel,
wie ich mal gemacht habe, aber ein bisschen was habe ich da ja mal gemacht in dem Bereich.
Und in der Tat, das Theme, was ich eigentlich immer verwendet habe und auch,
wenn ich jetzt was Neues machen muss, immer noch verwende, ist Enfold.
Es gibt so ein paar sehr große, sehr flexible, sehr mächtige Mainstream-Themes
und davon ist Enfold so eins. Ich glaube, aus Österreich kommt das im Original.
Die sind aber relativ ähnlich, das heißt also welches dieser drei,
vier großen man am Ende nimmt, ist glaube ich ziemlich wurscht.
So und diese Themes ermöglichen halt einem auf Basis von WordPress eben ganz
andere Dinge zu machen als ein klassisches Blog.
Du hast dann halt so eigentlich das Ganze eher als ein Content-Management-System.
Und kannst dann relativ doch interessant, modern, aufwendig aussehende Seiten machen.
Und ja, vieles davon ist dann irgendwie Gimmick und man braucht den Elefanten
nicht, der sich reinschiebt.
Aber apropos reinschieben, ich verweise jetzt mal auf unsere gute alte Das-Sende-Zentrum.de-Seite.
Also das-sendezentrum.de.
Ruf das doch mal hier auf dem Beamer auf, Tim.
Schiebt sich da auch der Elefant rein?
Ja, da schiebt sich auch was durch, aber da hat es halt einen semantischen Sinn.
Sprich, das Sendezentrum war ja immer ein Zusammenschluss von verschiedenen
Podcast-Projekten und Ideen, die Tim, Claudia und ich hatten.
Und die haben wir dann ja auch in so einer Icon-Familie zusammengeführt,
dass also jedes dieser Unterprojekte, ja also Subscribe, Sendegate,
Sendezentrum vor Ort, dann eben ein eigenes Icon hatte.
Und das haben wir eben dann jetzt auf dieser Startseite vom Sendezentrum auch
so abgebildet, dass wenn man die Seite hochschiebt, links dieses Haupt-Icon
immer stehen bleibt und dann je nachdem in welchem Bereich man quasi gerade erklärt bekommt,
schiebt sich halt, wird das jeweilige Icon so flüssig ausgetauscht.
Das finde ich nach wie vor einen irre guten Effekt.
Es wackelt etwas.
Es kommt auf den Rechner an oder auf den Browser oder was auch immer.
Ja, sieht ganz gut aus. Kann man nichts gegen sagen.
So und das ist halt eine Sache so, da wird was durchgeschoben und da passiert
was, aber es hat halt einen semantischen Sinn, weil es eben die Grundidee verdeutlicht,
es gibt das Sendezentrum und es besteht aus mehreren einzelnen Komponenten und
hier werden sie dir nacheinander flüssig erklärt.
Die Webseite ist ja auch noch unter den vorhin genannten Umständen hochgradig
benutzbar und straightforward, aber du weißt auch was ich meine,
also dass da alles möglich sich auseinander faltet und von links und rechts reinkommt.
Apple Mac Pro zum Beispiel.
Ist das immer noch so eigentlich?
Ich glaube schon, wo sie dann den Rechner aufmachen und dann ranzoomen und dann
hier noch dieses Feature und da noch jenes Feature. Also das ist ganz schlimm.
Dauert allein ewig, bis da irgendwas passiert, oder?
Ja, da werden auch Megabytes übertragen.
Ja, jetzt zoomt der Prozessor rein und dann.
Da kann ich noch mit leben. Das geht aber hier noch. Haben sie es etwas runtergedimmt?
Ja, haben sie. Haben eine ordentliche Webseite draus gemacht. Guck an.
Ja, jetzt kommt hier das Gehäuse geht hoch und solche Sachen.
Also es ist weniger worden. Das stimmt.
Es geht gerade noch so.
So und dieses Framework Enfold, wie gesagt, ist es nicht das einzige,
sondern es steht jetzt halt pass pro toto für durchaus andere Frameworks, die das ähnlich machen.
Die sind halt so flexibel, dass wir an der Stabi, Staatsbibliothek Berlin,
haben wir das genommen, um den kompletten Bibliotheksguide,
Damit zu bauen. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt nicht irgendeiner Entwicklungsbude Geld gegeben,
Achtung, baut uns jetzt mal eine Museums-App für unser Stabi-Museum,
sondern wir haben das auf Basis von WordPress mit einem Enfold-Theme gemacht,
sodass du da jetzt deinen Plan hast und kannst sagen, vor welchem Exponat stehe
ich jetzt eigentlich hier gerade und dann kriegst du interaktive Inhalte und so weiter.
Und das läuft dann vor Ort im Museum, kriegst du also am Anfang ein iPad in
die Hand gedrückt und hast dann also dort den Museumsguide drauf und der kommt
einfach nur aus dem WordPress raus.
Das ist so eine Ebene von wieder Selbstermächtigung und irgendwie Dinge enablen,
ohne dass du also ein super tiefes technologisches Verständnis brauchst,
was ich total nur abfeiern kann, weil ich kann mit so einer Technologie,
die drücke ich halt bei mir Bibliothekarinnen in die Hand und die können das
warten und pflegen und brauchen keinen riesen.
Keinen Riesenvertrag und müssen nicht sonst wo bei der Bude irgendwo einen Log-In-Effekt
sich reinholen, wo du für jedes einzelne Update dann wieder sonst was die Hand aufgehalten wirst.
Das können Leute lernen, Normalsterbliche.
Cool. Das ist ein ganz anderer Use-Case, als du einfach nur einen Block mit
rechts einer Seitenleiste haben willst, aber es gibt halt auch einfach ganz
andere Szenarien und andere Welten, die man mit WordPress bespielen kann und
da helfen solche Themes ganz enorm.
Und jetzt für die Subscribe-11-Seite, ja, das hat mich also insgesamt irgendwie
15 Minuten gekostet, weil du einfach halt den ganzen Inhalt der einen Seite
quasi einmal in eine Zwischenablage reinkopieren kannst,
die in Fold selber mitbringst und auf eine neue Seite ausrollst und dann musst
du quasi nur die 10 durch eine 11 ersetzen und dann hast du im Wesentlichen
dann deine Subscribe-11 vernünftig an den Start. Also das sind schon...
Ja, hör zu, so macht man Konferenzen.
Das ist schon... It just works.
Ich schmeiße nochmal den Link zum Stabi-Kulturwerk rein.
Ich habe übrigens in meinem Editierwaren deine Webseite komplett zerpflückt.
Also du musst sie auch wieder heile machen.
Ich habe Sachen reingeschrieben und dachte die fehlen, weil das da nicht drin war.
Dann habe ich es reingeschrieben, um festzustellen, dass da unten irgendwo so
ein komisches Kästchen ist, wo das
dann nochmal separat drin stand und ich schreibe das halt einfach raus.
Ja, und es unterscheidet halt
auch zwischen Desktop-Ansicht und quasi Tablet-Ansicht und Mobil-Ansicht.
Das kann man halt auch in unterschiedliche Bereiche reinmodellieren.
Mir ist das zu viel Gezuppel.
Also ich will einfach Informationen haben, wenn ich auf eine Webseite gehe,
dann soll das da einfach stehen und fertig.
Schön in Assembler selber gecodet.
Naja, wir kriegen das schon hin. Aber falls jemand da noch einen Tipp hat für
so ein Team. einfach nur.
Einfach nichts kann.
Einfach Content links und rechts zeitbar und zwar immer auf jeder Seite.
Aber auch das kannst du in der Tat mit den Folds sehr einfach machen.
Ja, aber warum geht es dann nicht einfach?
Wieso? Du machst einfach das Gerät am Anfang. Also das ist halt quasi so dieser...
Man macht dann Seiten und bei den Seiten ist dann immer wieder alles weg.
Nee, also wenn du einen Block haben willst, dann musst du einfach nur das Gerät
für das Standardblock anpassen.
So, und das ist halt so dieser Ansatz.
Das Gerät für das Standardblock anpassen?
Was heißt denn das? Twitter Bootstrap, schon mal gehört. Webseiten werden in Grids gebaut.
Ja, meine Webseite wird nicht in Grids gebaut.
Wenn du eine Seitenleiste hast, du willst es nur als Table formatiert haben.
Mir ist doch egal, wie das rausgerennert wird. Ich will aber keinen Grid für
konfigurieren. Ein Sidebar hat einfach da zu sein. Ich brauche einen Eintrag
Content und den anderen Sidebar.
Ja, genau. Das ist ein Zweier-Grid, wo du sagst, zwei Drittel des Contents ist
der Content, ein Drittel ist die Sidebar und fertig.
Das ist nichts für alte Leute.
Ah, okay. Sehr alte Leute. Ja, sehr alte Leute.
Oh mein Gott.
Gleich schreit die Klausel.
Ah ja, genau. Für sehr alte Leute habe ich noch einen Tipp. Das wollte ich das
letzte Mal schon machen.
Ihr kennt das ja sicherlich. Dieses, ich will mal den Inhalt einer Webseite abspeichern.
Oh ja.
Das ist ein echtes Thema und in den letzten Jahren, naja, es gab ja schon immer
die Möglichkeit einfach das HTML abzuspeichern, aber heutzutage ist in diesem
HTML ja fast nichts mehr drin,
weil dann irgendwie natürlich noch tausend JavaScript-Seiten nachgeladen werden
und Bilder und so weiter.
Alter, das heißt, man hat dann zwar das HTML-Gerüst und wenn man es aufruft,
dann naja, im Idealfall funktioniert es dann auch noch lokal,
aber nicht unbedingt ohne Internet,
weil dann halt alle möglichen Ressourcen noch reingeladen werden müssen und
so weiter. Was macht man dann stattdessen?
Man druckt es in PDF und immerhin haben so Browser wie Safari und wahrscheinlich auch die anderen,
im Safari finde ich ist es verhältnismäßig elegant gelöst, du hast dann im Ablagemenü
das als PDF exportieren und dann kriegst du es dann auch nicht so als A4 Seiten,
sondern du kriegst die ganze Webseite als ein lang gestrecktes PDF.
Allerdings auch mit bestimmten Grenzen, also ab einer bestimmten Länge macht
er dann auch zwei Seiten, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wo diese Grenzen sind und
das ist ja auch alles schon mal irgendwie ganz nett.
Aber eigentlich ist es nicht das, was man haben will.
Also es ist nicht das, was ich haben wollte, sondern manchmal will ich halt
auch einfach nur diese Webseite so komplett für sich haben und soll aber auch
noch eine Webseite bleiben.
Sie soll nicht ein PDF sein, sondern man will sie auch wie eine Webseite im
Browser benutzen können, aber
eben ohne Internet, also irgendwie gut wegarchivieren sozusagen. zu sagen.
Und da gibt es ein kleines Plugin, das heißt Single File.
Und wenn man Single File installiert, dann hat man so einen kleinen Button in
der Menüleiste und dann speichert er alles in Single File.
Nämlich auch die Bilder und all das. Das heißt, du hast die ganze Webseite dann
in einer Datei und kannst halt einfach mal sowas wegarchivieren.
Ist das dann eine .html Datei? Und da kodiert er auch auch die Bilder irgendwie rein.
Ja, das sind alles inline.
Ah, okay.
Ja, finde ich aber eine tolle Sache und so hat das zu sein kein großes Ding,
aber fand ich schön und absolut erwähnenswert.
Ist sehr praktisch.
Single file.
Ich probiere das hier gerade mal live aus. Also er schreibt das dann als HTML-Seite,
aber was macht er dann quasi mit den Bildern?
Na, Inline.
Wie, Inline?
Na, Inline-Bilder. Du musst ja nicht immer einen Link geben,
sondern kannst die Bilder ja auch Inline da reinballern.
Mhm.
Ja, ja, das Web. Apple hat jetzt übrigens das Web auch entdeckt.
Es gibt jetzt Apple Maps auf dem Web.
Keine 19 Jahre nach Google. Haha, Google, seht ihr mal, ne?
Apple ist auf der Spur.
Beta.maps.apple.com kann man jetzt aufrufen und dann hat man sozusagen so die Maps App im Browser,
ist jetzt natürlich kein wie soll ich sagen,
man steht nicht staunend da und sagt, boah echt im Web, wie habt ihr das denn gemacht, it's magic,
ich hab mich nur gefragt warum hat es eigentlich so lang gedauert Was hat Apple
eigentlich immer davon abgehalten? Und dann fiel mir ein,
was macht Apple eigentlich überhaupt im Web?
Außer ihrer eigenen Webseite und ihrem Kundenkontakt und ihrem Shop.
Gibt es eigentlich überhaupt irgendwelche Dienste, die Apple im Web hat?
Naja, es gibt diese iCloud-Dinge mit den entsprechenden Programmen.
Ja, es gibt iCloud, das ist richtig. dich, aber es ist ja nicht wirklich so
ein Web-Angebot, sondern es ist ja, das benutzt du ja nicht unabhängig von einem Macintosh.
Naja, du kannst die ganzen Dinger schon auch auf Windows benutzen, das geht schon.
Ja, aber dann ist es trotzdem so mit einer Apple-ID und irgendeinem Apple-Gerät verbunden.
Du kannst nicht sagen, oh, ich gehe jetzt mal zur iCloud und mache mir einen
Account im Web und dann benutze ich das auch nur im Web.
Äh, müsste gehen. Also einen Apple-Account machen kannst du ja jederzeit.
Ich glaube nicht, dass du dazu ein Apple-Gerät brauchst.
Aber gut, das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
So ein Cavoli und so weiter. Das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Aber mal ehrlich, das macht doch kein Mensch.
Das ist ein anderes Thema. Natürlich macht das niemand, aber gehen würde es wohl.
Genau, aber bei Maps macht es natürlich schon Sinn und ich bin gespannt,
ob da irgendwas bei rauskommt, was jenseits von MeToo ist, also was wirklich irgendeinen Value hat.
Ich muss sagen, Google Maps versus Apple Maps, ich weiß nicht,
wie eure Erfahrungen so sind damit?
Also ich selber benutze Google Maps relativ selten. Ich höre nur von Leuten
links, rechts, vorne, hinten, dass sie alle am Abkotzen sind,
weil Google Maps schlechter geworden ist.
In welcher Hinsicht?
In allerlei Hinsicht, in Sachen Routing, in Sachen Akkuratesse und so weiter.
Ich habe sehr viele Leute um mich herum, die sich beschweren,
ob sie das zurecht tun oder nicht, ist ein anderes Thema.
Ich kenne halt nur Leute, die genervt sind davon.
Also ich nutze eigentlich zu 90% Apple Maps und kontrolliere nur nach,
was solche Dinge wie Öffnungszeiten Restaurants angeht, weil da Apple häufig
hinterherhinkt oder es überhaupt gar nicht modelliert hat oder gibt es das Restaurant
eigentlich gerade überhaupt noch.
Also diese Point-of-Interest-Datenbank, da ist einfach Apple immer noch nicht wirklich gut.
Aber ansonsten, was die reinen Kartenfunktionen angeht, wechsle ich glaube ich
exakt nie mehr auf Google rüber.
Warum?
Warum? Ich finde es in der Tat grafisch belastet mich das Zusehen.
Ich finde, die werden immer schlechter in der Farbwahl und in der Deutlichkeit so.
Also ich rede jetzt nicht von dem View, was fotorealistisch angeht,
also die Satellitenview, sondern ich meine jetzt so den normalen Kartenmodus.
Da finde ich einfach es ästhetisch Apple Maps in Bezug darauf so,
wie sind die Kontraste gesetzt, wie sind die Farben ausgewählt,
wie sind die Point of Interest dann irgendwie sichtbar.
Finde ich alles sehr viel geschmackvoller und augenfreundlicher und der Detail,
in welcher Zoom-Stufe werden welche Details angezeigt.
Das finde ich funktioniert eigentlich alles durch die Bank bei Apple angenehmer. so.
Ist kein Riesenunterschied, aber schon so der Unterschied, dass ich denke so,
ich muss da nicht zu Google rüber, weil da halt nichts irgendwie besser ist.
Aber Point of Interest, das lässt sich glaube ich nicht wegdiskutieren.
Das lässt sich überhaupt nicht wegdiskutieren, da ist Google sowas von vorne.
Also es hat einerseits was damit zu tun, wie gut Google da vorgearbeitet hat
und es hat natürlich andererseits was damit zu tun, dass viele Leute Apple Maps
als Contender auch überhaupt nicht wahrnehmen.
Aber Apple selber verstrauchelt es dann noch zusätzlich, weil also,
worüber ich mich wirklich täglich aufrege und vielleicht hört ja irgendjemand
zu da draußen bei Apple mal.
Es sind viel mehr Point of Interest modelliert in Apple Maps,
als du auch in der höchsten Zoom-Stufe angezeigt bekommst.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt hier, so bei uns, Brenzlauer Berg,
das ist ja nur wirklich Point of Interest an Point of Interest und lokal an,
da gibt es nicht mehr, aber an sonst was, Shop.
Jeder einzelne Haus hier hat eigentlich ein Point of Interest.
Und die kannst du alle suchen in Apple Maps, die sind alle da.
Aber wenn du in der Karte auf maximal Zoom gehst, dann siehst du nur Häuser
und keinen Point of Interest, obwohl da drei oder vier hinterlegt sind und die
du über Suche alle findest.
Ja, finde ich jetzt nicht, aber also auf höchster Zoomstufe ist das,
glaube ich, das Teil des Problems, dass du halt wirklich reinzoomen musst, bis es nicht mehr geht.
Nein, also dass die Point of Interest sich dynamisch anpassen und du je nach
Zoomstufe quasi nur die relevantesten findest, das ist völlig d'accord.
Aber wenn ich maximal reingesucht, gesucht habe, will ich alles sehen.
Was siehst du denn zum Beispiel nicht?
Roddy ist jetzt gerade hier in der Schönhauser Allee-Ecke.
Stargarder Straße.
In der Web-Variante und der sieht deutlich mehr als ich hier,
glaube ich, in der Maps-App sehe.
Jetzt schauen wir mal, was die Konkurrenz sagt.
Das muss ich da aber erstmal hin.
Oh ja, jetzt merke ich, was du meinst von wegen Ansicht. Es ist echt schwer zu sehen.
Also ich wollte gerade was anderes bemängeln, habe aber gerade festgestellt,
dass Apple das wohl kurzfristig geändert hat, kurz bevor ich drüber ranten konnte.
Wenn man nach irgendeiner Adresse gesucht hat, dann haben sie irgendwie nie
einem die Postleitzahl dazu gesagt.
Das hat mich wahnsinnig gemacht. Und das ist für mich eine Hauptanwendung von
Google Maps ist, für irgendwelche Adressen die Postleitzahl zu ermitteln.
Weil wo kriegst du die Informationen sonst zuverlässig her?
Und Apple war einfach nicht in der Lage, eine Postleitzahl anzuzeigen.
Haben sie offensichtlich mittlerweile geändert, sie tun wohl was an diesem Projekt.
Womit ich positive Erfahrungen habe, übrigens bei Apple Maps sind Änderungen tatsächlich.
Also oft sind ja Sachen nicht eingetragen und ich mache mir dann so oft die
Mühe und trage es dann halt ein.
Öffnungszeiten, Namensänderungen, Adresskorrekturen, Positionen.
Ich habe das noch nie erlebt, dass irgendwas davon nicht übernommen wurde und
zwar spätestens nach zwei oder drei Tagen war es so und dann kriegst du auch
eine Notification dafür, was sehr ordentlich ist.
Das kenne ich auch. Ich habe irgendwann mal gesagt, hier ist keine Ampel mehr,
hier ist ein Kreisverkehr-Foto dazu.
Und das hat zwei, drei Wochen gedauert. Und dann war da der Kreisverkehr.
Also ich mache jetzt den Live-Nachweis meiner, nicht nur Theorie, sondern so ist es halt.
So, ich suche jetzt hier nach Formoso Pizzeria. Das ist ja die Pizzeria,
bei der wir ab und zu auch mal was geholt haben. Bekommen die hier angezeigt.
So, jetzt gehe ich in den maximalen Zoom-Level. Wir sehen oben drüber ist Luftschlösschen,
unten drunter Stephan Ehrlich Choreografie.
So, und jetzt nehme ich die Suche raus, dass mir nur dieser Bereich hier angezeigt wird.
Ja, wie kriegt man das hin?
Ja, wie kriegt man das hin? und jetzt steht da nur noch Boliviana,
die Seele Boliviens plötzlich, die vorher nicht zu sehen war und meine Pizzeria
ist schlicht verschwunden. Sie ist nicht mehr da.
Aber gibt es das andere auch?
Das andere ist gerade ganz frisch aufgemacht und die Pizzeria hat sich umbenannt nebenbei.
Hatte sie die jetzt schon fünfmal umbenannt in den letzten zwei Jahren?
Ja, ja.
Okay, das scheint mir aber auch wirklich ein Problem zu sein.
Das ist aber kein Problem der Umbenennung, sondern das ist reproduzierbar bei
zig Läden hier in der Gegend.
Das ist einfach dann nicht auftaucht sozusagen.
Ja, es ist suchbar, es ist in den Daten vorhanden, aber es wird im höchsten
Zoom-Level nicht angezeigt.
Das gleiche Verhalten zeigt aber auch Google.
Da ist auch deine Boliviana und die Famoso, die ich gerade gesucht habe.
Wie gesagt, Famoso heißt sie nicht mehr. Die haben sich umbenannt. Da taucht sie auf.
Anekdotische Evidenz ist jetzt immer so ein bisschen schwierig.
Grundsätzlich muss man sagen,
Pro Apple Maps immer schon Kartenqualität im Sinne von, also seit dem letzten Update,
ich meine mittlerweile ist die Auflösung, also in Berlin sind wir jetzt besonders
verwöhnt, aber sie haben ja wirklich von jeder Kreuzung die Platzierung der
Spuren, der Fahrtrichtungsanzeiger,
der Überwege, die Fußgängerüberwege sind eingezeichnet, die Ampeln und so weiter.
Also das ist schon alles ziemlich Töfte.
Und ihr Kartenmaterial ist eigentlich auch besser, also ihr Satellitenkartenmaterial
ist auch besser, weil höher aufgelöst.
Ich finde, dass ihr Streetview, wie heißt das, ihr Lookaround ist dann auch
besser gemacht als Streetview.
Nicht nur weil sie nicht so viel ausgeigste Gebäude haben, sondern weil du da
so flüssig durchlaufen kannst, benutze ich aber jetzt auch nicht so oft klares
Pro bei Google Maps wiederum,
dass sie halt Earth da eingebaut haben und das hat vor allem diesen Vorteil,
dass du ordentlich das auch wegkippen kannst, sodass du immer den Horizont siehst,
und das ist bei Apple unmöglich den Horizont zu sehen und teilweise empfinde
ich das als absolut erforderlich um eine ordentliche Orientierung zu bekommen
Aber sie begrenzen diesen Kippwinkel dermaßen und umso krasser, umso näher du ran bist,
dass du da bloß nicht so ein 3D-View kriegst, den sie aber ansonsten eigentlich
locker hinbekommen müssten.
Also von daher ist Google Earth und Google Maps, was ja mehr oder weniger jetzt
zusammengewachsen ist,
dann an der Stelle dann doch hilfreicher, zusätzlich eben zu dem,
dass die Leute dort schneller ihre eigenen Businesses updaten und gar nicht auf die Idee kommen,
auch mal ein iPhone in die Hand zu nehmen und es dort auch noch einzutragen ohne Not.
Was sie jetzt tatsächlich bei iOS 18 nachgerüstet haben, wo ich jetzt sagen
würde, endlich mal, ist, dass du die Suche benutzen kannst mit Hausnummern.
Vorher war das halt so, du hast angefangen, Straßennamen zu tippen,
dann hast du in der Suchliste schon den Straßennamen gehabt,
hast den Straßennamen angetippt und dann bist du direkt in die Karte gekommen,
aber du konntest die Hausnummer nicht mehr hinten anfügen und das geht jetzt.
Oh ja, das ist furchtbar gewesen. Das hat mich zum Wahnsinn gebracht.
Das haben sie jetzt gefixt.
Ja, schön, aber warum muss das so lange dauern? Das verstehe ich irgendwie nicht.
Also ich meine, das waren ja so offensichtliche Probleme und ich hoffe,
dass sie jetzt eben auch diese Amerikanismen weg haben.
Was immer noch scheiße ist, wo Google tatsächlich jetzt was geändert hat,
zumindest in Earth, ich weiß nicht, ob es auch in Maps geändert ist,
aber was mich rasend macht als Europäer, wisst ihr schon, worauf ich hinaus will?
The under appreciation of Trains.
Eine Eisenbahnlinie ist in Amerika so ein Feature wie,
ein Graben.
Ja.
Wenn du ganz nah ran zoomst, dann kriegst du so eine dünne, schwarze Linie.
Hier könnt ihr auch mal einen Zug vorbeifahren, aber ansonsten ist das ja nicht so interessant.
Zoomst du auch nur ein bisschen raus, Raus verschwindet die Linie einfach komplett.
Das ist bei Google Earth mittlerweile besser. Da haben sie jetzt auch aus der
einfachen schwarzen Linie eine schwarze Linie mit so Schwellen gemacht,
sodass du auch erkennst, dass diese schwarze Linie eine Eisenbahnlinie ist,
weil sie noch weiße Schwellen dran hat.
Dafür gebe ich Ihnen Gummipunkte. Aber bei Apple ist es halt besonders krass,
dass einfach Eisenbahnlinien als Infrastrukturelemente der Welt keinerlei nennenswerte
Bedeutung haben. Sie verschwinden halt einfach sofort.
Es sei denn, du stellst natürlich auf öffentlichen Nahverkehr um,
dann bekommst du alle Linien angezeigt.
Okay, I'll give you that. Aber die Dinge sind ja, ich will ja die Infrastrukturelemente
sehen, nicht nur wenn ich jetzt Zug fahren will, sondern ich will die Stelle
finden, wo die Eisenbahn die Straße quert.
Einfach weil das ein Ort ist, den ich mir merke. Weil einfach Eisenbahnlinien
überall sind und weil für mich das zu dieser Welt gehört. Und das können sie
halt einfach mal mit einbauen.
Ja, sehr deutlich ist es nicht, aber wenn ich jetzt hier gucke,
Eberswalder Straße, also zumindest bei Ebers 18 ist es jetzt so,
dass man tatsächlich die einzelnen Spuren der Straßenbahn erkennen kann.
Und im Erkunden-Modus.
Die einzelnen Spuren der Straßenbahn?
Ja, also schlecht, aber sie sind eingezeichnet.
Aber nicht die einzelnen, nur die Linie ist eingestellt, nicht die Schienen. Doch, die Schienen.
Wie gesagt, mit sehr dünnen Linien, aber eingezeichnet sind sie.
Was? Achso, aber nicht als Doppellinie, sondern als eine hin und eine zurück.
Eine kleine, ganz kleine Linie.
Na gut, da kann man sich auf jeden Fall bei OpenStreetMap mal abgucken, wie das geht.
Naja, auf jeden Fall beta.maps.apple.com vielleicht taucht es was,
aber ich glaube, das wird noch eine Weile dauern, bis das etwas ist, was man verlinkt.
Also ich finde es von der Fluffigkeit, von der Wupptizität finde ich es eigentlich ganz gut.
Es ist nicht so, dass man das Gefühl hat, es würden jetzt einzeln Kacheln nachgeladen
und vergrößert und verkleinert, sondern er zeichnet es schon relativ flott.
Das stimmt. Das ist unter Garantie alles so stimmt. Sehr vektorisiert nehme ich mal an.
Ja, also das haben sie schon gut hingekriegt.
Geht doch, Apple, geht doch. Weiter so.
Ja, so halb.
Wie kriege ich das schon noch hin?
Ich hätte da für die Ferienzeit was mit Karten auch direkt dran.
Ja.
Und zwar so ein Feature aus der Rubrik, warum hat es mir nie jemand gesagt,
vielleicht kennt ihr das auch alle, ich kannte es nicht.
Die Reiseführer-Funktion von Apple Maps.
Ja, die nervt.
Weil sie mir ständig Dinge in Australien oder in Amiland anzeigen,
die mich überhaupt nicht interessieren.
Ja, die meine ich aber nicht. Sondern ich meine die eigene Reiseführer anlegen.
Achso, das habe ich schon länger mal gemacht. Da kannst du halt unter quasi
unter einem Album kannst du dann Dinge speichern.
Genau. Also das ist das, was Google auch schon irgendwie seit Jahr und Tag hat.
Ich glaube, Apple hat das seit drei Jahren oder sowas ungefähr.
Müsste sein, ungefähr.
So um den Dreh, dass du also eine Möglichkeit hast, jetzt beispielsweise für
deinen nächsten Urlaub zu sagen, so, das sind jetzt die Locations,
die mich für diesen Urlaub interessieren.
Dann legst du einen sogenannten Reiseführer an, wo du dann sagst Sommerurlaub
24 und dann kannst du halt, egal auf welchem Device du bist und in welchem View du bist,
kannst du dann halt bei einem Ort sagen, so füge das diesem Reiseführer hinzu
und dann bekommst du die auch hinlänglich übersichtlich irgendwie beisammen.
Bis dahin denkt man so, oh, das haben sie jetzt hier aber mal schön gemacht,
das ist ja praktisch, muss ich nicht mehr zu irgendwie Web2-Dienst XY,
um solche Sachen zu katalogisieren.
Und dann gibt es so Details, dass man sich denkt, so schön wäre ja,
wenn man die jetzt umsortieren könnte und wenn man jetzt auch zwischen diesen
einzelnen Point of Interest nochmal irgendwie die Routen gleich irgendwie einfacher,
aber gut, alles nice to have.
Das Problem fängt an, wenn du sagst, so, jetzt möchtest du das aber mal mit
deinem Reisepartner teilen und sagen, so, ihr wollt ja zusammen diesen Urlaub organisieren.
So wie man sich jetzt so ein Shared-Fotoalbum wo man ihn irgendwie vorstellen würde.
Und es gibt die Funktion, so einen Reiseführer zu teilen.
Da kommt dann ein Link raus und den schmeiße ich jetzt mal in den Chat rein. Share Guide, genau.
Und er hat schon so eine verdächtig aussehende, lange URL.
Und du kannst ihn dann aufrufen.
Aber das ist einfach nur die Point-of-Interest-IDs serialisiert über die URL.
Das heißt also, es ist eben jetzt nicht eine ID zu dieser Sammlung von Point-of-Interest,
sondern einfach nur halt in der URL alle stumpf reinkodiert.
Bedeutet natürlich, wenn du danach dann einfach noch zwei neue Punkte hinzufügst,
bekommen alle Leute, denen du das geteilt hast, kein Update,
sondern die sehen nach wie vor ihre komplett alte Karte.
Und die können natürlich, obwohl sie quasi irgendwie ein scheinbar geteiltes
Map haben, können die also nichts selber hinzufügen und sagen,
so diese zwei Locations möchte ich mir auch noch gerne angucken.
Wo ich dann wieder so denke, so, why Apple, why?
Das ist so gut verstandene Technologie, das Datenmodell, hast du in fünf Minuten runtergeschrieben.
Sie haben Vergleichbares in anderen Diensten schon laufen. Warum bleiben sie
bei so einer Geschichte dann wieder so richtig auf halbem Weg irgendwo stehen?
Dann setzt du doch ein Team eine Woche dran, dann ist das doch echt fertig.
Also, hört sich jetzt immer so ein bisschen bold an, aber das ist doch nur wirklich
ein triviales Datenmodell.
Ja, eine Woche ist schon sehr, sehr bold.
Ja, du verstehst, was ich meine.
Ja, klar, du willst das synchronisieren, du willst es nicht nur sharen,
du willst es auch synchen. Synchen kostet extra.
Synchen kostet extra, ja, ist halt Cloud und alles mit Cloud ist Apple dann halt...
Ja, vor allen Dingen, wenn es halt von lokal nach Cloud wieder zurück nach lokal
und so weiter. Das ist wie gesagt, Sync ein Kostex.
Was ein Hoffnungsschimmer ist, bis ich glaube vor einem Jahr,
synkte es noch nicht mal zwischen deinen Devices selber.
Das heißt also, wenn du dann auf dem iOS-Device irgendwas hinzugefügt hast,
war das auf den anderen Sachen nicht zu sehen.
Das haben sie mittlerweile hinzugefügt. Das gibt mir die vage Hoffnung.
Das war doch immer so, oder?
Also ich habe heute extra nochmal recherchiert und es gibt in der Apple Knowledge
Base zig Einträge, die sich darüber monieren.
Kann sein, dass da der Fehler vor der Tastatur lag, aber das hörte sich irgendwie
einigermaßen plausibel an, wo sie beschrieben haben, warum was wo nicht funktioniert.
Und das geht aber mittlerweile.
Vielleicht haben sie sogar ein Team dran gesetzt, die was tun.
Aber zumindest jetzt Stand heute, ich habe hier die macOS Beta mit Share immer
noch nicht wirklich Sync Share gemeint.
Schade, schade. Ah, die Frage kommt hier gerade im Chat. Wie lang darf eine
URL eigentlich maximal werden?
Genau, da gibt es, ich glaube, 2048 Zeichen. Das ist, glaube ich, das, was Apple hier hat.
Was da nämlich auch ein Effekt war, wie Leute darauf gestoßen sind,
weil sie dann so einen Reiseführer mit 90 Orten hatten, von denen dann nur 50
quasi rüberkommen über einen Share, weil dann wird halt die URL abgeschnitten
und dann fehlten halt so die Hälfte der IDs. Das ist halt auch scheiße.
Hast du Favoriten in deinem Apple Maps?
Ganz wenige, weil ich die jetzt alle in Reiseführern organisiere. Wie viele? 90.
Wie viele Favoriten?
Favoriten 90.
90?
91, um genau zu sein. Weil ich dieses Reiseführer Feature erst vor ein paar Wochen gefunden habe.
Erst 90 Favoriten?
Ja, ist das jetzt zu viel oder zu wenig? Ich bin unsicher.
Favoriten heißt jetzt Pint, oder?
Nee, Favoriten heißt, dass das, wenn du auch Apple Maps aufrufst,
dass das sozusagen die ersten Angebote sind, wo du jetzt immer mal wieder hinfährst.
Gut, vielleicht haben sie es umbenannt oder Places.
Also Reiseführer würde ich halt mit 90 überhaupt nicht mit der Wimper zuzucken.
Aber die haben ja auch eine Reihenfolge und in der Reihenfolge erscheinen sie
dann zum Beispiel auch auf dem Telefon. Und wenn ich halt hier in die Meta-Ebene
fahre, was ich halt sehr oft tue, dann will ich, dass das das Erste ist, was da zu sehen ist.
Drag mal irgendeines von diesen Favoriten vor ein anderes.
Du meinst diese Liste hier?
Ja, diese Liste hier.
Da habe ich 45.
Ich versuche gerade hier das Datenmodell erstmal. Mir ist glaube ich bisher
der Unterschied zwischen angepinnt und Orte nicht bewusst gewesen. Ich weiß gar nicht.
Was angepinnt sein soll.
Angepinnt ist, glaube ich, das, was du Favoriten nennst.
Also ich habe unter Favoriten einen McDonalds an der A2.
Der hat diesen Status sicher nicht verdient. Da steht auch Favoriten.
Den lösche ich jetzt mal weg.
Aber in der macOS-App heißt es nicht Favoriten.
Selbstverständlich heißt es in der macOS-App Favoriten.
Nö.
Hast du da jetzt das neue macOS oder das alte?
Ja, ich habe hier das neue.
Ja, da gibt es keine Favoriten mehr im neuen.
Hier gibt es Favoriten.
Ja, ich habe hier auch Favoriten. Favoriten.
Ja, ja, hier nicht.
Favoriten ist, wenn man das Herzchen klickt.
Ist das das neue?
Das frische, neue.
Mediathek? Was ist denn das?
Mac OS 15. Genau.
Mediathek. Achso, okay, dann haben sie das umbenannt. Okay, dann kannst du mal,
mit Drag & Drop die Reihenfolge ändern.
Ah, okay. Eine Verbesserung. Bei mir crasht es nämlich.
Echt? Bei mir? Ich hab das alte noch drauf, da crasht nix.
Bei mir crasht alles.
Ich habe es jetzt irgendwie 16 Mal hintereinander versucht. Man kann auch bestimmte
Dinge nicht umbinden. Das ist alles eine Katastrophe.
Aber wahrscheinlich muss ich nur meinen Rechner neu aufsetzen.
Anyway, das sind ja alles Details.
Wir haben es jetzt besprochen. Jeder hat so seine Vorlieben.
Und ja, Google My Maps ist übrigens auch noch ganz interessant,
wenn du wirklich was im Web sharen willst und große Karten machen willst und
sozusagen Web-only bist.
Jetzt, wo Apple auch ins Web geht, Könnten deine Reiseführer sozusagen auch
für Nicht-Apple-Nutzer interessant werden, aber das ist halt immer so das Problem
mit Apple, dass sie einfach nicht großplattformen genug sind.
Vielleicht ändert sich das jetzt auch ein bisschen.
Schön finde ich hier bei diesem Web Maps noch, dass sie unten diesen Button
haben, have a business on Maps, manage your business.
Oh ja, das funktioniert auch überhaupt nicht.
Hast du das schon versucht?
Ja, ja.
Okay, ist halt noch Beta.
Ist bei Google aber auch eine totale Katastrophe. Ja, ich musste dann immer
hier irgendwie Meta-Ebene rausschmeißen, weil sie da irgendwelche das gepriesen
haben, als wäre das hier so ein Ladengeschäft oder so, weißt du?
Was du übrigens gerade meintest, diese Guides, also diese Reiseführer,
die laufen jetzt schon webbasiert.
Die haben nämlich auch eine eigene URL, guides.apple.com.
Ja, ist doch gut.
Das sind aber diese vorbereiteten Guides, ne?
Ne, das ist jetzt mein eigener Berlin mit Kindern Guide.
So, muss man sich da irgendwie anmelden?
Nö, den klickst du, ist ja einfach nur die URL, klick drauf.
Also das ist ja hier im Slack, kannst du ja ausprobieren.
So. Naja.
Ich glaube, das Thema können wir jetzt beenden, oder? Ja. Dann erzähl uns doch
nochmal deine Erfahrung mit Find My, dann sind wir gleich in dem Thema das auch noch durch.
Ich hab's geschafft, das Case von meinen von meinen Airpods zu verlieren von meinem Airpods Pro.
Und hab dann den merkwürdigen Effekt gehabt.
Also du kannst bei Find My von den Airpods Pro sowohl die einzelnen rechts und
links Hörer als auch das Case finden.
Das Problem, was er aber hat, ist, wenn du beide Hörer drin hast und hörst,
dann geht er davon aus, dass das Case auch in der Nähe ist.
Oh, tut er das?
Es hat mich wahnsinnig gemacht. Ich hab das Case dann doch gefunden und zwar
der Trick war halt einfach die Hörer in eine Blechkiste zu tun,
beziehungsweise in eine kleine Blechkiste, die in eine große Blechkiste und
dann erfährt niemand mehr davon,
dass die irgendwo sind, weil die nicht mehr durchkommen mit dem Funk und dann
wartet man halt, bis genug iPhones dann an dem Case vorbeigekommen sind,
dann als sich das dann an der Karte irgendwie an einem Punkt manifestiert hat
und alle Stunden mal geupdatet hat,
ja, wieder gesehen worden ist, immer noch an dem Ort bin ich da hingeladen,
Und dann lag es tatsächlich auf so einem Mäuerchen, hat es jemand hochgelegt
und dahin und dann habe ich es dann abgeholt.
Aber so dieses, dass das Case irgendwie scheinbar immer so ein bisschen den
Kopfhörern folgt von der Location, das fand ich sehr, sehr weird.
Also, wie gesagt, aber der Trick ist halt einfach, die Dinger,
die dürfen dann nicht mehr, wenn die nicht geordnet werden, geortet werden eine
Weile lang, dann kann man sich sicher sein, okay, das Case ist auch da,
wo er es anzeigt und nicht da, wo du vor zwei Stunden vorbeigelaufen bist,
weil das Case annimmt, dass es bei den Hörern ist. Das ist ganz merkwürdig.
Alright,
Ich komme jetzt zum Scheiß-Thema Oh, oh, oh Ja, das muss jetzt mal besprochen
werden auch wenn es ein Scheiß-Thema ist Ah.
Was eine Kacke.
Die Notdurft ist ja ein Thema, was uns täglich begleitet.
Ja, wo viel Versorgung, da viel Entsorgung.
So kann man das sagen. Und es ist insbesondere, wenn viele Menschen zusammenkommen,
ein logistisches Problem.
Aufgabe.
Ja, eine Herausforderung geradezu.
Ja.
Dafür zu sorgen, dass das alles in kontrolliertem Maße, Bahnen und so weiter abläuft.
In nicht verstopfte Röhren.
Ja, dass da nichts verstopft, dass da auch die richtigen Mengen vorgehalten werden, Kapazitäten,
dass es auch schnell genug abgefahren wird, um einfach so einen grundsanitären Zustand herzustellen.
Also jeder, der schon mal irgendwie was mit Toiletten zu tun hat,
also alle, kennen das Problem und es ist insbesondere auf solchen Festivals
natürlich ein besonderes Thema,
weil das eben auch so eine Infrastruktur ist, wo es sich immer so ein bisschen
rächt, wenn man dran spart und es kostet dann aber doch eine ganze Menge Geld. Deswegen...
Plastertoilette in hellblau und in...
Naja, also das Dixi-Klo war ja seinerzeit eine Revolution.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wann ist das Dixi-Klo überhaupt auf den Markt gekommen,
wie lange gibt es das jetzt schon?
Jeder kennt es, Dixi, Blau, Dixi.
Ich weiß es nicht, aber es gibt es mindestens seit den 80ern.
Also das Unternehmen wurde 73 gegründet. Genau.
Tja.
Toy Toy wurde 83 gegründet und 97 sind die dann fusioniert.
Also so irgendwie so in den 80er Jahren, 70er, 80er Jahren, so ist das so entstanden
und in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch eine Revolution. Natürlich wieder eng verbunden
mit der chemischen Industrie, dass man diese Kunststoffe so herstellen konnte.
Merke, Woodstock war noch ohne Dixi. Das gibt dem eine ganz andere Note.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Also nicht nur Woodstock, aber auch Woodstock.
Und jetzt denkt man so, okay, dann war ja alles gut, aber wer schon mal so mit
Dixi-Toiletten interagiert hat, weiß auch, das ist ein Problem. Leben.
Und das Hauptproblem ist die Vermischung.
Die Vermischung von Scheißerei und Pinkelkram.
Und das macht man sich ja nicht so klar, dass das das eigentliche Problem ist.
Man denkt immer so generell, das Abortieren an sich sei ein Problem.
Aber das eigentliche Problem besteht darin, dass wir wieder etwas vermischen, was der Körper trennt.
Das ist schon mal eine wichtige Erkenntnis. Es kommt ja nicht alles aus einem
Loch, sondern wir haben ja sozusagen separate Entsorgungssysteme und der Mensch
in seiner Faulheit kam auf die Idee, oh,
das wollen wir beides nicht, dann können wir das ja auch beides wieder zusammen vermischen und dann...
Sehen wir mal, was dabei rauskommt.
Pecuniam Non-OLED.
Ja, und was kommt dabei raus? Scheiße kommt dabei raus.
Es stinkt. Und es ist wirklich unerträglich.
Und es bilden sich die unangenehmsten Gerüche.
Und das Ganze ist halt auch sehr schwer zu handeln.
Jedes vollgeschissene Dixi ist halt auch irgendwann dann einfach nicht mehr
zu benutzen. Das ist einfach widerlich.
Und wenn du dann nicht auf dieser Veranstaltung, sagen wir mal,
zweimal am Tag dieses Ding leerpumpst.
Den Dixi-Schlürfer rumschickst.
Den Dixi-Schlürfer, genau. Was ja auch schon mal so ein Vorgang ist,
wo man sich denkt, das stinkt ja dann auch nochmal enorm.
Das ist so ein Job, den möchte man echt wirklich nicht machen.
Wenn er gut bezahlt ist.
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Ob der gut bezahlt ist oder keine Ahnung oder ob man dann einfach auch irgendwann
nicht mehr so merkt. So ist ja auch mit der Müllabfuhr ähnlich.
Du meinst, das Organ stumpft ab?
Sicherlich, aber ich will nicht darüber spekulieren, wie der Lebensalltag der
Menschen, die in dieser Branche beschäftigt sind, aussieht.
Sicherlich gibt es auch noch andere Berufsvorstellungen, die infrage gekommen wären.
Aber bleiben wir bei dem Klo. Das Klo an sich ist halt ein Problem,
also das normale Dixi-Klo, weil alles wieder zusammengerührt wird,
was die Natur trennen wollte.
Und weil das so ein großes Problem ist, gibt es mittlerweile auch eine ganze
Menge findiger Unternehmer, die auch für Veranstaltungen dieses Problem lösen wollen.
Unter anderem gibt es in Deutschland das Unternehmen Finizio.
Und Finizio ist wirklich pfiffig, weil die einfach dieses ganze Abortproblem
so richtig frontal angehen.
Ja, also es gibt dort Trockentoiletten, also oder sagen wir mal Trenntoiletten,
also es gibt mehrere Begriffe, die hier dazukommen, die mehr oder weniger alle dasselbe bezeichnen.
Ja, es wird einfach nicht wieder zusammengeführt, was die Natur getrennt hat.
Scheißerei und Pinkelei sind einfach zwei Dinge und siehe da,
wenn man es nicht vermischt, stinkt es auch erstmal gar nicht so.
Ja, es ist sozusagen, die Frage ist halt nur, wie machst du das?
Also wie verhinderst du, dass wieder das vermischt wird, was gerade im Körper
noch getrennt war, aber sich dann doch verdächtig nah beieinander befindet?
Das ist halt schon so eine Herausforderung, da muss man sich richtig was einfallen lassen.
Du hast einfach viel zu viel Spaß in diese Details zu gehen, habe ich das Gefühl.
Zu viel Spaß? Na, fass mal ab. Ja, also speziell, wie nennen sie das so schön,
die Humus-Sphäre, die Trockentoilette für Festivals, Version 4.1, schreiben sie hier,
die sieht man in letzter Zeit häufiger oder ich sehe die zumindest in letzter
Zeit häufiger und die sind wirklich cool gelöst.
Das ist sozusagen so eine leicht aufgebockte Toilettenrauminstallation.
Die Tür besteht aus einer Folie, die man so sehr elegant mit einem Slider einfach
zuschieben und einhaken kann.
Wenn man es aufhakt, fällt es durch Gravitation automatisch,
es ist automatisch offen. Das heißt, du weißt, wenn es nicht verriegelt ist,
ist es auf jeden Fall offen.
Du siehst sofort, es ist offen.
Während Dixi-Kloster musst du immer, ist da jetzt grün, ist da rot,
Tür auf, hat nicht verriegelt, oh peinlich und so weiter.
Kannst du mal die Bilder weiterschalten, ob sie diese verschiedenen States auch
hier irgendwo sinnlich erfahrbar sind?
Und man geht so zwei Treppen hoch und dann sieht man dort zwei Löcher.
Nein, das ist nicht das eine für Pinkeln und das andere für die Scheißerei,
sondern man hat tatsächlich einfach nur ein Loch zum Reinmachen und ein weiteres
Loch für einen Müllbeutel.
Dieser Müllbeutel ist für Toilettenpapier, sonstige Sanitärprodukte oder was
auch sonst, wo du auf dem Klo gerade loswerden möchtest, was sich nicht um natürlichen Abort handelt.
Und unter diesem Loch steht dann einfach eine Mülltonne, die natürlich leicht modifiziert ist.
Vor dem ganzen Apparat steht noch ein dicker Sack mit Sägespäne und so Metallbechern.
Und was du halt jetzt machst ist, du gehst da hin, machst diesen Becher voll
mit Sägespäne, marschierst in eine Kabine rein, kackst da rein.
Hinterlässt vermeintlich vermischst du alles wieder, aber tatsächlich sind diese
Mülltonnen so gemacht, dass das Flüssige sofort abgepumpt wird.
Und das funktioniert erstaunlich gut. Das heißt, da hinten ist eine Pumpe am
Werk, die regelmäßig alles, was irgendwie flüssig ist, aus diesen Mülltonnen wieder rauspumpt.
Und übrig bleibt sozusagen nur die Scheiße, die du dann am Schluss großzügig
mit dieser Sägespäne garnierst. Vielen Dank.
Und du guckst jetzt schon so ein bisschen verklärt und denkst dir so,
das soll funktionieren?
Die Antwort ist, es funktioniert hervorragend. Also es ist überhaupt nicht zu vergleichen,
wie wenig Geruchsbelastung von diesen Toiletten ausgeht im Vergleich zu halbwegs
benutzten Dixi-Toiletten.
Die einfach irgendwie nach den ersten 10, 20 Sessions ist es einfach schon alles
ganz schlimm und noch ein bisschen Temperatur dazu. zu uns wird alles noch viel schlimmer.
Die gab es auf dem Camp, die Dinge.
Auch, ja.
Das war so das Einzige, was mich daran gestört hat, war erstens war nicht ordentlich Licht drin. Ja.
Zweitens, du hast keine Klobrille. Du sitzt quasi auf dem blanken Metall mit
so einer leichten Farbschicht drauf.
Und das Dritte, was wirklich nervig war, da waren gefühlt 40,
50 von diesen Kabinen und drei Wasserhähne zum Händewaschen.
Ja gut, das ist ja ein anderes logistisches Problem, das muss man natürlich anders begegnen.
Also es ist nicht so, dass es da keine Klobrille gibt. Du sitzt da nicht auf dem Metall.
Ja, aber es ist nur ein Stück, ist nur ein bisschen Farbe. Also es ist nicht
so, dass das eine richtige Klobrille wäre, sondern es ist wirklich nur ein bisschen Farbe.
Aber das Toilettenpapier kommt dann also nebenan in diesen.
Genau, das Toilettenpapier ist auch nicht parat. Aber in einem Eimer.
Da habe ich doch dann dieselbe Geruchsproblematik.
Nee, das ist überhaupt gar kein Problem. Zumal, wenn das irgendwie korrekt betrieben
wird, werden diese Müllsäcke auch regelmäßig geleert, ausgetauscht,
also der ganze Service davon ist relativ easy,
weil es da eigentlich nie wirklich schlimm ist.
Also durch diese, jetzt erstmal nochmal dieser Effekt, also dadurch,
dass das Urin von der Scheiße getrennt wird.
Die werden dann übrigens in so IBC-Container gepumpt, die regelmäßig dann mit
dem Radlader weggefahren werden.
Dadurch, durch diese Trennung und vor allem auch durch dieses Hinzufügen von
dieser Sägespäne, die sozusagen die Restfeuchtigkeit auch noch aufnimmt,
trocknet das alles relativ schnell weg und es entsteht quasi kein Gestank.
Also ich würde nicht behaupten, es ist vollständig geruchsfrei,
aber es ist überhaupt gar kein Vergleich zu der, wir scheißen einfach alles
mit Flüssigkeit zusammen und passen schon irgendwie und stellen das bei 30 Grad in die Sonne.
Ja, es ist wirklich auch nah an einer schlecht gereinigten Standardtoilette.
Also es ist wirklich nicht so schlimm. Also es ist überhaupt kein Vergleich zu Dixi.
Genau, es ist überhaupt gar kein Vergleich zu Dixi und es funktioniert halt ganz gut.
Das mal nur so als Hinweis, was sich so im Festivalbereich da tut.
Es gibt noch einige andere Firmen, die das machen.
Es ist auch sehr interessant, mal bei Finitio nachzulesen, was sie damit machen,
weil durch diese Trennung hast du ja noch einen Vorteil.
Während dieser ganze Dixi-Kram ja mit ordentlich Chemie noch voll geballert
wird und danach einfach ins Klärwerk geht und da aufwendig geklärt werden muss,
produzierst du ja hier Dünger.
Urin selber ist ein hervorragender Stickstoffträger und derzeit kaufen wir industriell
hergestellten Dünger aus Russland, Klammer auf, Ausrufezeichen, Klammer zu,
um hier irgendwie unser Zeug auf dem Acker mit ausreichenden Nährstoffen zu
versorgen, dass irgendwie unsere Turbo-Agrarwirtschaft auch das liefert,
was wir im Supermarkt gerne sehen wollen.
Während wir eigentlich den ganzen Tag Stickstoff ausscheiden, den aber nicht sammeln.
Also Wasserclues.
In den Häusern sind eigentlich genauso Irrsinn, weil wir eigentlich eine wertvolle
Ressource vergeuden und dazu uns auch noch den ganzen Aufwand machen,
nachdem wir es wieder vermischt haben, zum Klärwerk wieder aufwendig voneinander zu trennen.
Mit all dem ganzen anderen Kram, der da auch noch mit drin landet.
Während würde man eben das Prinzip einer Trenntoilette, einer Trockentrenntoilette
auch schon in Häusern in irgendeiner Form umsetzen, was zugegebenermaßen eine
Herausforderung darstellt, aber ich würde nicht sagen,
dass es unwahrscheinlich ist, dass man da nochmal eine gute Lösung findet.
Dann würdest du einfach schon eine ganze Menge Ärger loswerden und du hättest
vor allem eine riesige Stickstoff-Ressource in Deutschland.
Also wo einfach Unmengen, ich meine, wenn alles, was gepinkelt wird,
irgendwie gesammelt wird und als Rohstoff verwendet werden kann,
dann wäre schon eine Menge gelungen.
Man kann natürlich auch aus der getrockneten Scheiße ordentlich Dünger machen,
weil derzeit hauen wir die Kuhscheiße und die Schweinsscheiße irgendwie auf unsere Felder.
Mit der entsprechenden Nitratproblematik?
Ja genau, Menschenkot im Übrigen
darf in Deutschland nicht auf Felder aufgebracht werden, wegen ISO.
Das ist etwas, was gerade im politischen Prozess ist, das vielleicht zu ändern,
aber derzeit ist es sozusagen nicht erlaubt.
Naja, Erreger und so. Es ist schon sinnvoll, dass du Keime, die einen Menschen
krank machen und aus einem Menschen auch rauskommen,
nicht direkt auf ein Feld aufbringst, wo du hinterher vielleicht Früchte erntest,
die Menschen wieder essen.
Also eine gewisse Sinnigkeit ist schon dahinter, aber vielleicht kann man es auch nicht.
Ja, aber auch nur eine gewisse, weil Schweine haben nahezu identisches Verdauungssystem
und da läuft halt auch alles durch und die werden auch die ganze Zeit mit Antibiotika
vollgeballert, während es bei uns eher die Ausnahme ist.
Also das funktioniert halt nur theoretisch besser.
Ja, ich sag nur, also traditionell hat das schon so seinen Sinn.
Aber es gibt auch Methoden, wie man eben diese Keime auch in den Griff kriegen
kann. Mit Erhitzungsprozeduren etc.
Und da arbeiten die auch dran. Die
haben da auch irgendwie große Forschungsprogramme und Labor und pipapo.
Weiß ich jetzt im Detail alles nicht auswendig, aber ist definitiv ein Thema
in dieser Szene, um das zu re-usen.
So, aber jetzt zurück zu dem eigentlichen...
Wir sind nicht zu Hause Problematik, weil wenn man nämlich
jetzt in der Wohnwagen-Wohnmobil-Camping-Welt, da wird ja auch gekackt.
Man glaubt es gar nicht.
Was du nicht sagst.
Du bist draußen in der freien Wildbahn und denkst, alles ist anders,
trotzdem Klo immer noch ein Thema.
Und jetzt haben diese ganzen Wohnwagen und Wohnmobile heutzutage natürlich auch Camping-Klos.
Und was macht man da? wie beim Dixi alles in ein Loch und ordentlich Chemie dazu.
Und wenn du auf dem Campingplatz mal so ein bisschen das Geschehen verfolgst,
man liegt am Strand und man haut sich eine Wurst rein, ja, es wird halt auch
eine Wurst auch wieder rausgehauen und was passiert damit?
Was passiert mit der Wurst? Die Wurst wird dann nach drei Tagen,
weil dann nämlich die Kacke echt anfängt zu stinken und auch die Kapazität von
diesem Campingklo, was so üblicherweise bei ungefähr 20 Litern liegt,
nicht mehr ausreicht, weil du ja da nachspülst, dann hast du noch deine Chemie
da drin, dann wird reingepinkelt, reingekackt.
Das heißt, wenn da zwei, drei Leute dieses Klo benutzen, dann hält das bestenfalls zwei Tage.
Und spätestens nach drei Tagen, selbst wenn du das alleine nur beschickst, dann.
Stinkt das einfach. Weil irgendwann, klar, du kannst dann irgendwie noch mehr
Chemie reinhauen und dann nimmst du die blauen und nicht die grünen Tabletten
sondern dann hält es vielleicht auch eine Woche, aber du musst es dann entsorgen.
Und entsorgen heißt, du läufst dann auf diesem Campingplatz an die Entsorgungsstelle,
wo du dann irgendeinen Schlot hast, wo du dann dein vollgekacktes Kassettenteil
da irgendwie schlurps reindrücken kannst.
Da hast du hinten noch so eine Belüftungstaste und dann kommt dieser ganze Strunz
in einem Schwall da irgendwie raus.
Es ist widerlich, stinkt, es ist schwer, 20 Kilo, die du nicht hier gegendrängst.
Es ist einfach alles ganz furchtbar. und man fragt sich.
Muss denn das sein? Gut, dass wir Kapitelmarken haben.
Ich habe ja gesagt, das ist ein echtes Scheißthema. Aber ich komme ja auf den Punkt.
Jetzt gibt es aber auch im Campingbereich, insbesondere für so kleine Camper,
gibt es ein Riesenangebot an Trockentoiletten, die genau dieses Problem nicht haben.
Das sind im Prinzip einfach so kleine Sitzeimer, wo du halt einfach separat,
abführst. Also du hast halt irgendwie hinten sozusagen Sammelbehälter,
wo du dann deine Sägespäne noch mit dazu ballerst oder irgendein anderes Trockenpulver.
Da gibt es so diverse Produkte, die genau die gleiche Funktion übernehmen.
Katzenstreu oder was?
Und Urin sammelst du halt einfach vorne separat.
Ist an sich eine tolle Idee und sollte man eigentlich auch machen,
weil er hat nämlich den Riesenvorteil, wieder stinkt nicht, hält aber auch länger.
Weil die Kapazität auf einmal ausreicht, weil du spülst da nicht mehr nach,
hast dann nur das Urin, dann hängt das einfach alles davon ab und das Beste daran,
Urin kannst du halt einfach in die Botanik kippen, du musst es nicht irgendwie,
in irgendeine Klärwerksentsorgung geben, weil ob du nur in den Wald pinkelst
oder erst sammelst und dann in den Wald pinkelst, macht jetzt so einen großen Unterschied nicht.
Also du verseuchst jetzt nicht die Umwelt, wenn du jetzt nicht,
was weiß ich, den Urin von 30.000 Leuten nur noch an einer einzigen Stelle ausgibst.
Klar, das ist natürlich ein anderes Problem, aber jetzt so als Einzel-User irgendwo
das loszuwerden, ist an sich kein Problem.
Jetzt habe ich so einen Wohnwagen und der hat natürlich auch so eine Tada,
super moderne Campingtoilette mit einem Loch, wo alles reinkommt und die ganzen
Probleme hat, die schon das Dixi-Klo hat.
Und gerade wenn du so auf Festivals bist, die einen etwas alternativeren Charakter
haben, dann hast du auf jeden Fall eins nicht, eine offizielle Entsorgungsstation
für Chemie-Toiletten. Gibt's halt einfach nicht.
Wenn du Glück hast, kannst du zur nächsten Tankstelle fahren und dich da irgendwie,
hinschleichen. Manche haben sowas, manche nicht, wie auch immer.
Also es gibt einfach überhaupt gar keinen Ort, wo du das sozusagen hinbringen
kannst und wenn nach drei Tagen, spätestens fünf Tagen, allein schon das dass
gestangs wegen, aber auch wegen der Kapazität dieses Problem entsteht,
dass du dieses Klo entleeren musst, dann stehst du da.
Und dann dachte ich mir so die ganze Zeit, ich will auch eine Trockentoilette
haben. Das kann so nicht weitergehen.
Ich glaube, auf vielen Autobahnparkplätzen, wo so ein Klohäuschen ist,
haben sie auch eine Möglichkeit, die Dinger zu entleeren.
Wahrscheinlich, weil die Leute es sonst sowieso einfach nur in die Landschaft...
Genau, das ist nämlich das andere Problem. Und wir haben sehr viele Wohnwagen
und Wohnmobile in diesem Land und die werden im Sommer heftig benutzt,
kannst du davon ausgehen.
Und klar, es muss dieses Problem halt auch irgendwie lösen.
Jetzt habe ich geschaut, vielleicht kann man das ja umbauen.
Und siehe da, es gibt mittlerweile einen Markt, wo du so etablierte Camping-Toiletten-Modelle,
vor allem so Dometic, Tedford, das sind so die Marktführer in diesem Bereich,
wo du dann aufwendig mit neuen Ersatzteilen und das musst du gegen das machen
und dann hast du die Schüssel und die hat dann irgendwie zwei Löcher und nicht
eins und dann hier nochmal einen Schlauch und die Kassette wird in zwei Teile
geteilt und dann kannst du das auch irgendwie trennen.
Und dann durch Magie kannst du dann sozusagen deine bestehende Campingtoilette
in so eine Trockentoilette umbauen mit ein bisschen Aufwand,
aber auch mit nicht zu verachtenden Kosten.
Also es geht so irgendwie so 1000, 1500 Euro. Das ist so das,
was ich irgendwie derzeit gefunden habe.
Und dachte mir so, also nur um das irgendwie zu trennen. Das kann ja wohl nicht
euer Ernst sein. Irgendwie 1400 Euro, ich bin doch nicht bekloppt.
Außerdem baust du natürlich deine Toilette dann so massiv um,
dass du ja auch wieder Gedanken machst mit, was ist, wenn das alles nicht funktioniert,
kriegst du das dann wieder zurückgebaut und so.
Ja, theoretisch bleiben die Teile dann übrig, aber warum hast du dann 1400 Euro ausgegeben?
Macht irgendwie alles keinen Spaß. Naja, auf jeden Fall war das für mich so
ein bisschen Back and Forth.
Und dann habe ich es gefunden. Eine geniale Lösung und alle Leute,
die ein Wohnmobil haben, wollen sich das auf jeden Fall anschauen.
Ganz einfach. Da hat mal jemand nachgedacht und das Produkt heißt Flexaport.
Unglaublich. Flexaport. Ich bin einfach begeistert.
Es sieht auch aus, als ob es 5 Euro kosten dürfte.
30.
30, okay.
Genau.
Also es ist schon ein China-Gadget. Vom Aussehen her ist es ein China-Gadget.
Nein, sorry, es ist großartig.
Es ist ein schwarzer Eimer mit weißen Flügeln.
Ja, das eigentliche Wunder ist dieses weiße Plastikteil. Also ein sicherartiges Plastikteil.
Und es gibt das für alle gängigen Campingtoiletten, die auf dem Markt sind.
Das heißt, die haben sich einfach die Maße von all diesen Toiletten genommen
und haben dafür jedes Ding eine spezialisierte Plastikform designt,
die da genau reinpasst in diese Schüssel.
So, dass wenn das Ding da drin liegt, es fest sitzt und in der Mitte ein rundes
Loch hat, wo du dann einfach so einen kleinen schwarzen Eimer reintust.
Also im Prinzip so eine Art Plumpsklo aus deinem normalen Campingklo machst.
Aber der Urin geht immer noch in den Tank.
Aber der Urin geht immer noch in den Tank. Aber nur noch das Urin geht in den Tank.
Und damit wird dein Tank zu einem reinen Urinspeicher und da du auch nicht mehr
mit Wasser nachspürst, warum werde ich gleich erklären, ist die Kapazität auf
einmal verdreifacht oder verfünffacht.
Jetzt denkst du dir natürlich die ganze Zeit reif mit deinen Stirnrunzeln und
deinem skeptischen Blick Sehr skeptischer Blick. Sehr skeptischer.
Ich soll jetzt hier einfach in so eine schwarze Schüssel reinschießen?
Das kann es ja wohl auch nicht sein. Ist ja auch nicht so. Weil da kommt ja noch eine Tüte rein.
Und die Tüte ist sozusagen einfach so ein Entsorgungsvehikel sozusagen für die Einmalbenutzung.
Also wie beim Hund.
So wie beim Hund, genau. Im Prinzip reden wir von Hundekaketüten. In größer.
Weil wir sind ja keine Hunde.
Genau. Und die Form erfordert sozusagen eine gewisse Größe.
Und da war ich dann auch schon ein Sinnput, so, ja, okay.
Und dann, was machst du dann? Dann musst du irgendwie so einen Mülleimer suchen,
wo es dann okay ist, wenn da so die Scheiße so langsam vor sich hin stinkt.
Lass mich raten, dafür haben sie auch eine Lösung?
Richtig, dafür haben sie auch eine Lösung. Es gibt erstens gruchsdichte Tüten.
Ja.
Die man dann wie verschließt?
Keine Ahnung, ich kenne nur die Lösung Verwindeln.
Mit einem batteriebetriebenen, über USB-C ladbaren Folienschweißgerät. Es ist so großartig.
Vakuum-Kacke oder was?
Ja, du schweißt es einfach mit einmal so ein Clip. Das ist so,
als würdest du einen Locher benutzen.
Tüte rein, klack, einmal drauf, zack, verschweißt.
Und die ganze Die ganze Thematik ist sozusagen luftig verpackt.
Du kannst es sogar im Wagen lagern, wenn es jetzt keine andere Möglichkeit gibt.
Aber du kannst es auch einfach in irgendeinen Müllbeutel reinwerfen, der irgendwo rumsteht.
Es macht keinerlei, nichts wird imitiert.
Bleibt noch ein Restproblem.
Das Restproblem heißt, auch Urin tendiert dazu, irgendwann ein bisschen zu stinken.
Benutzer von Kaffee Achteck wissen, wovon du redest.
Was ist Kaffee Achteck?
Das sind diese Altberliner Urinale in dunkelgrün, die so achteckig sind.
Das kennst du den Ausdruck Kaffee Achteck?
Vollkommen. Achso. Ah, ah, echt?
Oh ne, also Entschuldigung, den Begriff, den kannte ich tatsächlich noch nicht.
Okay, ich dachte, der wäre... Kaffee Achtig? Der wäre üblich.
Öffentliche Pissbasen, okay. Ja, die habe ich mal rumstehen sehen,
aber ehrlich gesagt noch nie benutzt. Gibt es die noch?
Es gibt noch einige. Die in Betrieb sind? Jaja, also in Tegel gibt es eins, von dem ich weiß.
Es gibt in Moabit gibt es eins, von dem ich weiß.
Guck an.
Genau. Wir sind jetzt ganz kurz vorm Ziel. Verstehst du?
Du baust irgendwas um für wenig Geld. Also Tüten plus irgendwie Schweißgerät
plus dieses Einsatzteil in Investitionen von 80 Euro.
Jetzt bleibt nur noch ein Problem. Der Urintank könnte müffeln.
Er könnte müffeln.
Genau. Insbesondere wenn man den Fehler macht, dann noch Wasser reinzumachen.
Das ist ein großer Fehler. Aber manchmal muss man ja schon mit irgendwas spülen.
Was nimmt man dann? Und die Antwort ist Zitronensäure. Die es überraschenderweise
wirklich in jedem Supermarkt gibt.
Ja, als Entkalker.
Als Entkalker. Aber es hat noch einen anderen Effekt. Es wirkt nämlich darauf
hin, dass wenn du das in den Urintank gibst, dass die Ammoniakbildung unterbunden wird.
Okay.
Und das Ergebnis ist, du kannst jede Campingtoilette, die heute in irgendwelchen
Wohnmobilen verbaut ist oder Wohnwagen,
die einen total nervt, weil man einfach viel zu wenig Kapazität hat,
viel zu oft das entsorgen muss, die Entsorgung völlig nervig,
anstrengend und eklig ist.
Und du vor allem, wenn du dich in einem Environment befindest,
wo es überhaupt gar keine offizielle Entsorgungsoption gibt,
immer vor der Wahl stehst, jetzt entweder die Natur zu zerstören,
oder dein Environment sozusagen nicht zumutbaren Geruchsbelastungen auszusetzen,
dann hast du auch eine andere Option.
Und alles, was du dafür brauchst, ist Flexaport und Zitronensäure.
Ja, oder halt Klappspaten und Gurt und dann surfen.
Was? Ein Gurt und surfen? Was meinst du damit?
Du machst einen Gurt um einen Baum herum und dann hängst du dich in diesen Gurt
hinein, als würdest du Windsurfing machen und dann kannst du ganz entspannt in den Wald kacken.
In meiner Jugend hieß das Surfing. Ich geh mal surfen.
Ja, okay. Okay, verstehe.
Und ja, wie gesagt, wenn du nett bist, nimmst du einen Klappspaten mit,
hebst noch ein kleines Loch aus, das du dann wieder zuschütten kannst.
Jetzt fragt einer, wenn man jetzt nur mit Zitronensäure arbeitet,
naja, in einer normalen Toilettenkassette.
Das Problem ist, wenn du da noch reinscheißt dazu, dann geht die Rechnung nicht auf.
Sozusagen. Man muss, also es gehört getrennt, was die Natur gerne getrennt entsorgen möchte.
Das ist schon eine ganz gute Idee gewesen eigentlich.
Ich weiß, das ist ein Scheiß-Thema, aber das musste jetzt raus.
Weil es ist einfach, ich sag dir jetzt schon, es wird viele Leute bewegen und
Flexaport ist eine absolute Entdeckung.
Also du würdest jetzt sagen, du hast das Licht gesehen?
Ja, ein bisschen. also zumindest kann ich belegen dass es funktioniert und das ist wirklich toll,
so kann man also aus einem,
altmodischen Entsorgungsmodell ein neumodisches Entsorgungsmodell machen ohne
sich finanziell zu überfordern das ist ja auch schon mal ein Feature oder.
Äh ja das stimmt die sind hier,
Was kostet denn sowas?
Also es ist halt überhaupt.
Zwischen 30 und 50 Euro Einsatz mit Eimer, oder? Oder ist es nur der Einsatz?
Genau, mit Eimer.
Mit Eimer, okay. Das ist absolut zumutbar.
Weil es halt auch nicht viel ist. Und vor allem, du hast keine bauliche Veränderung.
Du kannst es auch wieder rausnehmen und alles ist so wie vorher.
Und das ist schon cool. Das macht, sagen wir mal so, das Vanlife steht es dann
schon nochmal auf eine andere,
Ebene, weil diese Campingtoiletten an sich sind ja ganz praktisch und nett und
so und ja nicht selten in diesen Badeinfassungen auch noch,
wegdrehbar und gut mit Duschen kombinierbar und so weiter und das ist halt einfach so ein bisschen...
Da frage ich mich jetzt, ob es beim Thingiverse was für den 3D-Drucker gibt,
um das selber zu drucken.
Das kann man sich selber drucken, wobei ob es dann so glatt ist und so nett,
also du kannst hier auch noch zwei verschiedene,
Plastikvarianten wählen. Ich habe vergessen, was es war.
Schreiben Sie das hier. La la la.
Nein, das ist...
Der Behälter, Sie nennen ihn netterweise Wurstfänger.
Das wäre jetzt in der Tat, ich lese mal kurz eine Passage vor,
die mich gerade schon ein bisschen umtreibt.
Anatomisch bedingt können Frauen nicht so einfach nach vorne pinkeln und brauchen etwas Übung.
Alternativ kann der Bälle kurzzeitig entnommen werden. Das heißt also,
Männlein und Weiblein haben hier schon etwas unterschiedliche Voraussetzungen.
Definitiv, aber es ist jetzt auch kein Problem, wenn da jetzt irgendwie ein
bisschen Pinkelei noch im Beutel landet, weil du entsorgst es ja eh.
Hauptsache der Tank bleibt frei. Das ist der entscheidende Punkt.
Ja, fair enough.
Kein Kot im Tank.
In der Natur als Dünger entsorgen. Dö-dö-dö-dö-dö.
So ist das.
Was für ein scheiß Thema.
Was für ein scheiß Thema, oder? Aber es bewegt die Leute.
Ich sag's dir, es ist auf jeder Veranstaltung da draußen immer wieder so ein
Thema, was irgendwie getackelt gehört.
Und das ist definitiv der beste Ansatz, den ich bisher gefunden habe.
Wie ist denn das? Die Plastiktüten, die ich zuschweiße, heißt,
die sind aber jetzt nicht biologisch abbaubar.
Nein, das sind sie nicht. Du bist nicht ohne Müll.
Es gibt allerdings auch die Möglichkeit, du kannst natürlich dann nach eigenem
Gusto auch einfach Kaffeefilter verwenden zum Beispiel.
Papiertüte.
Papiertüte, dann bist du komplett öko. Dann kannst du es halt nicht einschweißen,
dann musst du es halt unmittelbar irgendwo hin entsorgen.
Je nach Gesamtsituation ist das dann die bessere Wahl oder zumutbar oder die einzige Option.
Weiß ich nicht, aber sie haben alles mögliche von,
leichter abbaubare Tüten, normale Hundetüten und dann halt diese speziellen,
einschweißbaren, geruchsdichten Tüten, die jetzt, sagen wir mal,
für die Situation, wenn zu viele Leute um dich herum sind und dann die Müllentsorgungsoptionen
auch eingeschränkt sind, dann ist das sozusagen die Wahl.
NASA und U-Boot tauglich.
Genau. Your mileage may vary.
Das war es eigentlich zum Scheiß-Thema. Ich finde ja, ich meine, jetzt mal ehrlich,
dieses ganze Entsorgungssystem, was wir so in Städten haben,
ist halt eigentlich der totale Irrsinn.
Also man müsste da einfach einen anderen Ansatz finden, um einfach mehr Ressourcen zu nutzen.
Naja, sagen wir mal so, die Klärwerke, Ich glaube, da kommt schon auch relativ
viel Zeug raus, was du dann als Dünger wieder verwenden kannst.
Also schlimm wird es eigentlich erst, wenn du zu viel Zeug dabei hast,
wo die Leute Sachen runterspülen, die du halt auch nicht wirklich irgendwie
dann biologisch abbauen kannst.
Dann wird es, glaube ich, eklig. Ansonsten, naja, es ist nicht optimal,
aber es ist jetzt auch keine Katastrophe, würde ich mal sagen.
Gut, ich kenne mich eigentlich auch nicht aus.
Ist auf jeden Fall eine logistische Herausforderung und technische Herausforderung
und eine kulturelle Herausforderung, weil natürlich dann auch sozusagen das
Modell, das moderne Modell drin muss.
Ich meine, Klo ist ja auch von Land zu Land sehr unterschiedlich,
wie damit umgegangen wird.
Also Autobahnen, Frankreich, Süden und so weiter sind ja immer noch so Stehtoiletten,
immer noch sehr weit verbreitet.
Wo dann so der Deutsche sagt, das ist aber irgendwie komisch und so.
Aber eigentlich ist es sehr viel sauberer in Anführungsstrichen,
weil du halt nicht die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Klobrillen mit anderen Leuten teilst.
Ja, ja.
Unter solchen Aspekten.
Ja, ich kann die Argumentation nachvollziehen.
Aber es warst kulturelle Hemmnisse.
Ich finde es nicht sehr angenehm, diese Art von Klos, nein.
Letzten Endes aber alles so eine Frage der Gewöhnung in gewisser Hinsicht.
Ich habe das bei meinem ersten Besuch in Russland erlebt, dass sie tatsächlich
irgendwie normale Klos zu einem Podest so zusammenbetoniert haben,
dass es dann eine Hocktoilette wurde,
wo man dann da so hoch mit Treppe hochgegangen ist und dann da,
also das fand ich sehr, sehr weird.
Aber naja.
Ja, dann sind wir durch mit unseren Themen. Machen wir heute früher Schluss oder was?
Wenn du vor zwölf früher Schluss machen willst. Ja, doch, können wir aber mal.
Ist ja den Reif halt noch ein wichtiger Beitrag.
Nee, ich wäre auch nicht gänzlich unglücklich.
Die Liste ist soweit abgehakt.
Schwieriger Tag.
Ich dachte, wir hätten ja mehr drüber zu diskutieren. Ihr steigt jetzt hier
richtig ein auf das Scheiß.
Hemmnisse.
Naja, was soll man sagen, also einerseits leuchtet das alles ein,
andererseits wüsste ich jetzt auch gar nicht, was für eine Position ich denn
da bitte verteidigen möchte.
Mal ganz ehrlich, ich meine, es ist ein unangenehmes Thema und alles was hilft, hilft.
Also ich sehe vor allem den Punkt, dass man halt Laufzeiten verlängert und unabhängiger
wird von sonstiger Infrastruktur, wo man irgendwie dann sonst wohin fahren muss,
um irgendwo kramlos zu werden.
Aber so einen Septiktank von
so einem Wohnmobil zu leeren, das stelle ich mir extrem unangenehm vor.
Also ich habe das noch nie gemacht und ich glaube, ich will es auch nie machen.
Und ich glaube, diese Variante kommt mir doch deutlich angenehmer vor,
als jetzt wirklich so einen richtig fiesen Chemiekot-Urin-Mix da irgendwo abzuklappen
und wenn der Wind falsch steht, dann reierst du gleich mit hinterher. Also nee. Nee.
Also im Wohnmobil-Trend geht ja alles so in Richtung größer.
Wohnmobile werden größer, Wohnwagen, okay, beim Wohnwagen ist es so,
aber bei Wohnmobilen hast du...
Enorme Schwarzwassertanks, wie man das so schön nennt. Du hast ja immer Frischwasser.
Eigentlich müssten sie Braunwassertanks heißen.
Heißen aber Schwarzwassertanks. Dann hast du halt einfach viel und dann fährst
du die ganze Scheiße halt einfach quer durch die Botanik.
Solange bist du dann eben wirklich so einen richtigen Absauggestutzen hast,
wo du dann eben mit den Details nicht so in Verbindung kommst.
Aber auch das ist immer wieder Abhängigkeit von Infrastruktur und ich muss sagen,
irgendwie ist es sehr viel entspannender, sich von externer Infrastruktur unabhängig
zu machen in jeder Hinsicht.
Da ist das Stromthema schon mal relevant, in gewisser Hinsicht halt auch das
Internet, auch wenn das ja sozusagen der Inbegriff der Abhängigkeit von externer
Infrastruktur ist, aber naja, zumindest brauche ich halt keinen Festnetzanschluss,
und dann bleibt halt noch Wasser und Klo.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, ich meine, Das konterkariert ja auch so ein bisschen die
Idee des Campings, dass man eben mit weniger Infrastruktur irgendwie eine Weile
lang näher an der Natur lebt.
Und wenn man dann aber Technologie am Hals hat, wo man mehr Infrastruktur braucht,
als man es zu Hause hat, dann ist es irgendwie so.
Dann passt das nämlich auch wieder nicht zusammen.
Ja, also keine Ahnung. Aber ich glaube, ich bin auch nicht der Typ Riesenwohnmobil. irgendwie.
Ist auch nicht jeder Typ Camping, aber es ist ja schon durchaus verbreitet.
Ich werde dann im September übrigens wieder zum Caravan-Salon fahren und mir
mal so den Stand der Dinge anschauen.
Das ist ja so ein bisschen so diese Wohnmobil- CeBIT.
Wo wirklich, also Düsseldorf ist das so die große Messe. Da gibt es wirklich
jeden Scheiß zu sehen. Auch in der Hinsicht.
Und es ist immer sehr interessant zu sehen, Es ist ja ein super konservativer
Markt, dieser ganze Wohn-Camping-Bereich, wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt,
wie langsam das jetzt so geht.
Immerhin gibt es jetzt den Trend zu Electric Wohnwagen, auch wenn der noch so
ein bisschen in die falsche Richtung zeigt.
Was ist denn Electric Wohnwagen?
Naja, sie wollen, also Elektrik heißt, also ich glaube der korrekte Begriff ist gasfrei.
Sie wollen gaslos werden, weil Gas ist halt Aufwand einbauen,
brauchst halt Platz für die Flaschen, brauchst diesen Gastank,
das nimmt dir Gewicht, das nimmt dir Volumen.
Aber ist die Flasche nicht der Gastank?
Du brauchst den Ort, wo die Flasche reinkommt. Also du brauchst den,
wie heißt der, Gasfach, Entschuldigung, Gasfach.
Ja, das ist dieses Dings da, das ist kapuff vorne dran.
Das ist kapuff vorne dran, was eigentlich nur erforderlich ist wegen der Gasflaschen.
Weil das muss halb offen sein, das hat unten diese Rillen, damit das Gas dann
auch, sollte es austreten, nicht geschlossen bleibt, sondern dann nach unten ablaufen kann.
Und Gas ist halt klar mittlerweile zu machen, aber für die meisten Leute gar
nicht so wichtig, weil sie den Wohnwagen sowieso nur im Sommer benutzen.
Das heißt, sie heizen eigentlich selten.
Also richtig Heizung ist für viele gar nicht so das Thema. Klar,
ist manchmal ganz praktisch.
Kalte Nächte gibt es auch im Sommer und so weiter.
Heizdecke fertig, oder?
Man kann ja auch mit Strom heizen, in gewisser Hinsicht.
Dann gibt es warmes Wasser, kann man auch mit Strom machen. Und mittlerweile
gibt es halt auch Induktionskochfelder, die günstig zu machen sind und viele
andere Vorteile haben, weil sie eben diesen ganzen Gasaufwand, Sicherheit,
Abgase, was da so mit dranhängt, auch nicht haben.
Also gibt es jetzt gasfreie Wohnwagen, die auf diese ganze Gasinfrastruktur
verzichten und stattdessen eben elektrische Komponenten haben in unterschiedlicher Ausprägung.
Das ist allerdings jetzt noch nicht klar.
Dann mit Solar und mit Wechselrichter und eigenem Stromsystem,
sondern diese gehen natürlich davon aus, du fährst auf den Campingplatz,
hängst dir da in die Steckdose ran und dann hast du alles, was du brauchst und
dann zahlst du sozusagen noch für den Strom.
Relativ viel, üblicherweise.
Ja, ich weiß gar nicht, was die so berechnen. Oft gab es das ja auch so als
Tagespauschale, weil die Leute eh kaum was verbraucht haben und wenn du 5 Euro
pro Tag zahlst, dann war das schon irgendwie alles abgedeckelt.
Aber heute kommen sie ja alle mit ihrem Tesla und stecken dann erstmal ihr Auto
ran und ziehen sich dann mal so ihre 20, 30, 40 Kilowattstunden.
Dann reichen auch die 5 Euro Tagespauschale irgendwann.
Naja, also ganz so viel kriegst du, naja über Nacht kriegst du es vielleicht
schon hin 20, 30 reinzuladen, aber so richtig viel Strom kommt ja über einen normalen Anschluss an.
Ja, wie auch immer. Es muss ja dann aber auch die Leistung gebracht werden und
wie viel Ampere hast du da jetzt wirklich drauf.
Und wenn du jetzt so ein Induktionskochfeld hast, wo die verbrauchen zwar insgesamt
nicht viel, aber sie verbrauchen viel innerhalb kürzester Zeit.
Ich habe eins zu Hause im Haus. Du weißt, wie das läuft.
Das Kochfeld, das kann schon ordentlich mal auf Boost und allem 4 Kilowatt.
Was halt cooler wäre, wenn es Induktionskochfelder gibt, die nicht so viel verbrauchen
würden, die dann zwar nicht so schnell sind, aber immerhin auch noch elektrisch,
dann kann man das wiederum ganz gut mit einem solargestützten Stromsystem in
so einem Wohnmobil auch kombinieren.
Aber derzeit will alles irgendwie mindestens 1800 oder 2000 Watt haben,
um ordentlich durchzukochen.
Weil wenn du schon ein Induktionskochfeld hast, dann willst du auch schnell das Wasser aufkochen.
Muss ja jetzt nicht so schnell gehen. Würde vielleicht auch reichen,
wenn man sagt, ja, ziehst du jetzt mal einen Kilowatt. Das kann meine Batterie
auch liefern, passt schon.
Naja, so ein Wasserkocher geht halt irgendwie auch. Da braucht man ja kein Induktionskochfeld.
Ja, ist richtig. Zum Wasser kochen ist das ja sozusagen die einfache Methode,
aber du willst ja jetzt auch ordentliche Herdplatten noch haben und wenn es
halt nicht Gas ist, dann ist es eben Strom.
Ja klar.
Um heizen und kochen und Internet betreiben kannst. Aber eben auch damit fahren
kannst, aber das alles ein integriertes System ist.
Da gab es von irgendeinem Hersteller mal so eine Studie, da hatten die einen Wohnwagen gebaut,
wo glaube ich 20 Kilowattstunden oder 30 Kilowattstunden Akku drin war und die Räder angetrieben,
sodass der Wohnwagen an sich auch während er gefahren wird noch ein bisschen
Vortrieb leistet, damit dann auch das Zugfahrzeug mehr Reichweite hat und so weiter.
Das war ein Prototyp von Bosch, den gab es schon vor 2-3 Jahren Ich glaube Detlefs
oder so war das Ja, aber in Kooperation glaube ich mit Bosch weil die ja selber
sowas gehalten haben Aber ich weiß nicht.
Was da draus geworden ist Ja.
Da ist glaube ich, soweit ihr weißt da bin ich jetzt auch gespannt,
ob sich da jetzt mehr abzeichnet, da ist jetzt erstmal noch nichts draus geworden
weil da gibt es die Kunden nicht so für,
Aber eigentlich ist das geil weil es geht ja gar nicht mehr nur also erstens,
wenn du aus demselben Akku den Wohnwagen antreibst, brauchst du nicht mehr so
eine starke Zugmaschine.
Das heißt, du kannst mit einem kleineren Wagen den Wohnwagen ziehen.
Und, Nebeneffekt, du hast halt auch automatisch einen Mover drin.
Du hast einen Mover drin, genau.
Das heißt, das Ding kann sich, und das auch mit ziemlicher Kraft,
dann kriegst du den auch mal einen Bordstein hoch und kannst wirklich mit dem
Teil dann irgendwie ein Rennen fahren.
Das ist schon mal besser, gerade wenn es schlammig ist oder so.
Diese normalen Mover sind ja nur so Zahnräder, die sich dann so in den Reifen reindrücken.
Und wenn es dann nass ist und schlammig, dann kriegst du das Ding fast auch
gar nicht mehr bewegt, schon gar nicht aus einer Matschkuhle rausnavigiert.
Und da wäre natürlich ein in die Felgen, in die Radkappen, wie nennt man das,
in die Radnaben eingebauter E-Motor sinnvoller.
Und wenn man es richtig macht, kannst du damit natürlich auch gleich so Anti-Schlinger-Software
einbauen. Das heißt, wenn der Wagen aufschaukelt, wäre er in der Lage,
aktiv gegenzusteuern, wenn man das mit der Software richtig hinkriegt.
Und du hast natürlich genug Akku, um einfach mal in dem Wohnwagen zu machen, was du willst.
Da diskutierst du dann nicht mehr über Kochfelder.
Genau.
Da kannst du den ganzen Tag durchkochen. Oh, ich mache jetzt nochmal einen Liter Wasser.
Schon drei Liter Tee getrunken, ich mach noch einen.
Also das wäre auf jeden Fall mein Traum, so ein komplett elektrisches Wohnmobil
mit so einer Einheitsbatterie, was daran sowohl diesen Wagen bewegen kann,
als auch vor Ort dafür sorgt, dass irgendwie alles versorgt ist.
Oben ordentlich Solar durchgeballert, wo diverse Kilowatt bei rauskommen und dann,
wenn man nicht mehr weiter kann, Dann bleibt man einfach mal ein paar Tage stehen
und wenn man wieder Strom hat, fährt man weiter. Dann brauchst du auch keine Tankstelle mehr.
Naja, da muss man wahrscheinlich sehr realistisch betrachten,
wie viel Strom du von wie viel Solarzelle bekommst, um damit wirklich fahren zu können.
Ich habe jetzt einen Vortrag gehört von Zweien, die sind tatsächlich durch Afrika
gefahren mit so einem Skoda Enyaq und die hatten insgesamt 30 Solarmodule dabei.
30? Ja, aber so ganz flache, dünne, leichte.
Und die haben dann tatsächlich immer einen Tag geladen, einen Tag gefahren.
Und die haben wirklich dann das Ding hingestellt und einmal irgendwie,
keine Ahnung, diese ganzen 30 Module einmal aufgebaut und hingelegt und verkabelt
und dann einfach mal einen Tag laden lassen, weil du brauchst einfach die Leistung.
Ja, wenn du weit kommen willst,
Muss ja nicht unbedingt weit kommen.
Naja, die sind halt wie gesagt von, ich glaube, von Gibraltar irgendwie runter.
Ich habe es nicht mehr so genau in Erinnerung, aber sie sind glaube ich fast
bis Südafrika gekommen oder so. Sie sind relativ weit gefahren.
Links, links, wir brauchen mehr links, Roddy.
Das war auf einer firmeneigenen Veranstaltung, wurden die so als Zuckerchen
gebucht. Ich kann da jetzt, ich kann nochmal nachgucken, ob ich irgendwie rausfinde, wie die hießen.
Das waren so zwei Holländer, so ein holländisches Pärchen, das irgendwie,
ja keine Ahnung, die meinten, dass selbst die von Skoda sehr erstaunt waren,
dass sie das hingekriegt haben, dass das so funktioniert hat.
Das Problem war so ein bisschen, dass sie das Auto so stark mit Technik vollgepackt
haben und alle Sodarmodule und so weiter, dass sie eigentlich überladen waren.
Die mussten dann stärkere Federung einbauen und irgendwie, dass das Auto irgendwie
nicht quasi direkt auf dem Boden liegt und so weiter.
Ja, da müssen wir noch ein bisschen mehr Effizienz rausholen,
sowohl in der Energiegewinnung als auch in der Nutzung.
Dass die Karren nicht so viel verbrauchen?
Nicht viel verbrauchen. Ich glaube, woran es irgendwie immer noch hakt,
ist der Batteriepreis. Also Batterien sind ja viel, viel, viel billiger geworden.
Aber da gibt es noch ein bisschen, noch einen Weg zu gehen. Ich glaube,
in fünf Jahren diskutiert man es nicht mehr.
Aber ja.
Oh, ich glaube, da hat jemand tatsächlich den Link gefunden.
Da siehst du mal. In den Shownotes.
Ja, ja, genau, der war das. Das ist genau der richtige Link gewesen.
Such mal mein Bild, wo alles aufgeklappt ist. Ah, okay, dann.
Ja, das ist auf jeden Fall, das sind schon eine Menge Solarpanels.
Ja, ja, genau. Also die waren auch total witzig, die beiden. Holländer halt.
Irgendwie, ich kenne fast nur Holländer, die total witzig sind.
Es gibt bestimmt auch andere, aber...
Und die ganzen Panels haben sie komplett oben auf dem Dach quasi,
übereinander hinten drin, weil obendrauf ist auch so ein großer Aufbau.
Ja, sieht für mich auch so aus, als ob es das oben drauf war.
Nee, obendrauf waren, glaube ich, nicht die Panels, sondern Gepäck.
Die hatten extra so eine komische, so ein komisches Regal hinten eingebaut mit
so Schubladen, wo sie die Teile reingetan haben und Schubladen rein und so weiter.
Also ich habe das Auto ja aus der Nähe gesehen und auch angefasst.
Sieht in der Tat aber auch sehr geländegängig aus hier. Also da sind schon einige Pisten dabei.
Ja, wie gesagt, die haben da an dem Fahrwerk auch nochmal montiert,
damit das tatsächlich irgendwie...
Zeigen wir hier in diesem doofen Video echt deutlich zu wenig die Solarpanels.
Zu viel Auto fährt durch Matsche. Das ist doch nicht der Punkt, um den es hier geht.
Und?
Komm, wir lösen mal hier den Ralf, der ist schon wieder durch.
Demnächst mehr Camping-Feedback. Ihr wolltet das Thema haben,
also haben wir das jetzt hier auch gemacht.
Und ich hoffe, nächstes Mal habe ich großartige Meldungen zum Thema Victron
und alles in den Griff bekommen und so weiter.
Ja.
Uah. Uah, okay.
Ich mach's kurz, Ralf.
So, Leute, das war's. 281. Ganz kleines bisschen kürzer als sonst, aber...
Viertelstunde.
Dicht bepackt. Und von daher sagen wir Tschüss.
Kurz vor dem Datumswechsel.
Bis denn.
Tschau.
Tschüss, tschüss.